NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS IN HERE
TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS. TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE
ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THE SOCIAL
DISSING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND
WILL BE USING. TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY FOR
ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON A
COMMITTEE WEBSITE WILL BE
DISPLAYED. ON THE SCREEN I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. THE
PARTICIPANTS NUMBER IS. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHT NINE FIVE FOUR. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS SEVEN TWO. FIVE
FIVE. THREE SEVEN SIX. DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. WE MOVED TO PUBLIC
COMMENT YOU'LL BE PROMPTED BY
MODERATOR DIAL ONE THEN ZERO
FOR SUPPORT OPPOSITION PRESSES
ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER. THERE
MAY BE A SHORT WAITING PERIOD
ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER YOU WILL WAIT IN THE
QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR CALL
YOUR LINE NUMBER AT THAT TIME
YOU WILL BE ON MUTE IT AND
YOU'LL BE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT'S
IMPORTANT WE HEAR YOU AND WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I
WILL MAINTAIN THE CHROME DID IT
DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE HEARING
SERVICE. OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTION MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HIRING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS AND IS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME
LIKE TIMES ARE PARTICIPANTS
WERE JUST IN THE NEW USE OF THE
ONLINE TOOLS AND TECHNOLOGIES.
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT TO ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES SO EVERYONE CAN BE
HEARD. DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF
HEARINGS TEXTILE.
CONSIDERATIONS INCLUDING
PROTOCOLS I'M INSTRUCTING TIME
LIMITS ON TESTS ON. EACH SIDE
WITH MINUTES EQUAL AMOUNT OF
TIME. WHICH IS TWO WITNESSES
FOR TWO MINUTES EACH I MAY MAKE
EXCEPTIONS OF THIS- ON ONE BILL
TODAY. BUT OTHERWISE IT'S TWO
MINUTES. TWO MINUTES EACH. ALL
OF THOSE WISHING TO TESTIFY
MUST LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS TO
THEIR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE MEASURE. ONE
MAKE IT CLEAR UP FRONT. A
PERMIT EACH SIDE. TIP TO PRIMER
WITNESSES AS I STATED. YOU'LL
GET TWO MINUTES EACH UNLESS I
ALLOCATE OTHER TIME- BEFORE THE
IN WE WILL ALWAYS DO SO SUCH
THAT EACH SIDE GETS. EQUAL
TIME- BEFORE YOUR PRESENTATION
THE BILLS LET'S STILL WHICH
CORN CHIEF COUNSEL PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. FOR PURPOSES OF
ESTABLISHING A QUORUM- BURKE
YOUR- AMBERG HERE BOARD YES.
FORGES PRESENT CARRY IT OVER.
HERE BARRETT OKAY HERE DID I
THOUGHT. ONCE I LIST. GONZALEZ
HERE HERTZBERG. JONES LAYERED.
LAYERED HERE STERN. WHITE COW
SKI. HERE WHITE HERE WINNER.
YOU HAVE A QUORUM THANK YOU
MINUTES CHIEF COUNSEL WITH
SIXTEEN BILLS AND DAYS GENDER
EIGHT OF WHICH ARE ON CONSENT
THE ITEMS OF THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ARE AS FOLLOWS FILE
NUMBER THREE EIGHTY ONE ONE
FOUR THREE BY SEVEN MEMBER
BERMAN FILE NUMBER FOUR EIGHTY
SIX THREE THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CALLED RUN WITH
THE MEMBERS FILE NUMBER FIVE
EIGHTY TWO EIGHTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHAN FOUND OVER
SIX AB THREE THREE TWO BY
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND TOXIC
MATERIALS COMMITTEE. FILE
NUMBER SEVEN EIGHTY THREE EIGHT
ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER DAVIS
FILED UNDER EIGHT AB ONE ZERO
SEVEN NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GALLAGHER FILE NUMBER TEN A. B.
FOUR THREE ZERO BY SEVEN MEMBER
GRAYSON WITH AMENDMENTS FILE
NUMBER THIRTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT
EIGHT SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LEVIN. IS EMOTIONAL CONSENT
COUNTER SIMILAR MOVES. THIS
CONSENT CALENDAR. TICKETS
PLEASE CALL ROLL. ON THEY CAN
CAN. AMBER HI AMBER HI FORGES.
BARGES HI COVEY. ABIERTO I DID
I SAW WANT TO LET. GONZALEZ I
HURTS JONES BARED ALL THERE ICE.
I CAN SKI HI WHITE HOUSE HI
WEINER. YOU HAVE SO FAR ALL
RIGHT WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL
SIMILAR MEMBER BAR KAY AND YOU
HAVE BEEN VERY PATIENTLY
WAITING THANK YOU SO MUCH- THE
FLOORS NOW YOURS. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS FIRST I WANT TO THANK
THE CHAIR IN THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR EXTENSIVE WORK
ON THIS ISSUE AND THEIR
DEDICATION TO STRENGTHENING
PROTECTIONS FOR VULNERABLE
CONSUMERS HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
I'D LIKE TO UPDATE THE
COMMITTEE THAT WE ARE IN GOOD
FAITH NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO ADDRESS THEIR
CONCERNS AND I'M COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH ALL PARTIES.
INCLUDING THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCIAL PROTECTION TO ENSURE
THE BILL BILL IS EFFECTIVE
ENFORCEABLE AND WORKABLE WITH
THAT I AM PROUD TO PRESENT AT
THIRTEEN TWENTY. THE BILL TO
PROVIDE NEEDED CONSUMER
PROTECTION FOR THIS DIGITAL
AGE. WHEN KOBE HIT A YEAR AGO
FINANCIAL TRANSACTIONS MOVED
ONLINE AT THE SAME TIME THAT
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS LOST
THEIR JOBS. CASH TRANSFER
SERVICES EXPLODED IN POPULARITY
AND ARE USED FOR EVERYTHING
FROM SMALL BUSINESSES TO MUTUAL
AID. FOR THOSE HIT HARDEST APPS
LIKE ZELLO INVENT MO OFTEN
BECAME A SIGNIFICANT SOURCE OF
INCOME. THESE SERVICES OFFER A
LIFELINE THAT IS. INSECURE AND
TREACHEROUS THE APPS ARE OFTEN
FULL OF GLITCHES AND SERIOUSLY
VULNERABLE TO SCAMS WHEN PEOPLE
ENCOUNTER PROBLEMS THEY OFTEN
HAVE NOWHERE TO TURN. THEY
OFTEN FALL VICTIM TO ANOTHER
SCAM BECAUSE OF THAT CONFUSION.
CURRENT REGULATIONS DO NOT
OFFER SUFFICIENT PROTECTION AND
VULNERABLE USERS ARE LEFT
WITHOUT RECOURSE. AB THIRTEEN
TWENTY SIMPLY REQUIRES CASH
TRANSFER SERVICES TO LIST A
CUSTOMER HELP PHONE NUMBER.
PROMINENTLY ON THE WEBSITE AD
RESPOND TO CUSTOMERS WITHIN A
REASONABLE TIME FRAME. THE BILL
WILL PROTECT THE MILLIONS OF
CASH TRANSFER CUSTOMERS WHO
RELY ON THIS MONEY. IT GIVES
THEM A LIFELINE PROTECTS THEIR
FUNDS AND HOLD COMPANIES
ACCOUNTABLE WITH ME TODAY ARE
SARAH ROBINSON DIRECTOR OF
PUBLIC POLICY AT THE NATIONAL
CONSUMER LEAGUE. AND CHUCK BELL
PROGRAMS DIRECTOR OF ADVOCACY
AT CONSUMER REPORTS. MR BELL
ARE YOU ON THE LINE OR MISS
ROBINSON. THIS IS TERRIBLE BUT
I'M HAPPY TO HAVE IT AGAIN- ALL
RIGHT GO AHEAD MISS ROBINSON
AND- THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS OF LOOKING ON THE
NINETEEN OKAY ARE ALMONDS
PUBLIC POWER MANAGE AT THE
NATIONAL CONSUMERS LEAGUE I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
APPEAR BEFORE THE COMMITTEE AND
PROVIDE TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
AND EIGHTY THIRTEEN TWENTY. AND
IN EIGHTEEN NINE AND THE
ALKALINE MISSION I'M FOR AND
ECONOMIC. ON BEHALF OF
CONSUMERS AND WHAT. THE ELSE
LIKE HOLD UP .ORG WE COLLECT OF
CONSUMER COMPLAINTS AND- THAT
WE WITH OUR NETWORK OF MORE
THAN TWO ONE. PARTNERS SEVEN
O'CLOCK TWELVE MONTHS ARE NOT
WORKING WITH RECEIVED ALMOST
ONE THOUSAND COMPLAINTS INVOLVE
MONEY. AND LIKE HALF. MEN MEN
OF HOW AND. MEDIA LOSS REPORTED
DOLLARS FOR DOLLARS HOW WE
HEARD FROM CONSUMER YEAH LOST
FAR MORE. INCLINED HAVING IN
CAMBRIDGE THAT THEY WANT THEIR
ENTIRE LIFE SAVING. ANYTHING
PLANE GOT I CAN ONE GOVERNMENT
MAY POP REPORTED. IN THE LAST
YEAR AND CONSUMER FINANCIAL
COULD BUREAU RECEIVED MORE THAN
TWENTY. TWO ABOUT MONEY
TRANSFER SERVICE. I THOUGHT IT
DATA NOT HOW I IN THAT THE MEAN
FROM PURCHASE VOCAL THE LACK OF
CUSTOMERS OF THEY RECEIVED WHEN
THEY CONTACT THE MANAGER.
COMPANY HOW. RIGHT DOWN THE
HALL AND MONEY TRANSFER SERVICE
APARTMENT PLAN WORK. TELL THEM
HOW EITHER TAKE PART IN
RESEARCH NUMBER ON THIRD
ENGINES AND ON MEDIA. EIGHTY
TRAINING HER. BUT MANY
TRANSFERS MAINTAIN CUSTOMER
SUPPORT ONLINE. AND RESPOND A
TIMELY MANNER THEY WERE. AND
THE COMMON AND PROTECTION RIGHT.
HELLO HELP CONSUMERS BEGIN TO
FIGHT BACK AGAINST CRIME. REBEL
AVAILABLE. GOING ONCE. GOING
TWICE GOING THREE TIMES LET ME
ALL RIGHT TAKE OTHERS AND
SUPPORTING THE GALLERY IN ONE
SPORT IN THE GALLERY- IF YOUR
SUPPORT GIVE US YOUR NAME YOUR
AFFILIATION IN YOUR POSITION IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE I SEE NO ONE IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE LET'S TURN TO
THE PHONE LINE MR MODERATOR MR
BELL APPEARS WE'LL TAKE HIM
OTHERWISE LET'S GO AHEAD AND
TAKE OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WE MODERATOR YOU THERE.
POLITIES OUT SAYING THAT ON
MUTE LATED M. IF YOU WISH TO
MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO YOUR HAIR TONY CAME
IN PLACE INTO THE QUEUE YOU MAY
REMOVE YOURSELF FROM THE QUEUE
AT ANY TIME BY PRESSING ONE
THEN ZERO AGAIN. SPEAKER PHONE
PLEASE PICK UP HABIT PRESSING
OF THE NUMBER. IN OUR FIRST
COMIC COMES FROM A LINE OF ONE
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
APPLICANT ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE
MODERATOR. THERE IS CURRENTLY
NO ONE ELSE CAN KILL ALL RIGHT
OF THE MISTER BELL APPARENTLY
IS NOT AVAILABLE SO LET'S TURN
TO OPPOSITION- IF THERE IS
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION- I HAVE
MISTER ADAM FLEISCHER- IN
OPPOSITION AS MISTER FLEISCHER
AVAILABLE. HELLO YEAH THIS IS
CONTEMPLATION ALL RIGHT GO
AHEAD SIR. THANK YOU SIR MY
NAME'S ADAM FRAZIER I
REPRESENTED ME MONEY SERVICES
ROUNDTABLE P. M. S. ARE KEY-
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME AND
GIVING ME THE OPPORTUNITY WE
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE ABLE TO SPEAK WITH YOU ALL
TODAY- OUR- FAMILY SERVICES
ROUNDTABLE IS COMPRISED OF
LEADING NON BANK MONEY
TRANSMITTERS IT OPERATES
THROUGHOUT THE UNITED STATES.
EITHER LIVES STREAM MICHAEL
TWENTY TEN RIGHT ANY CHANCE.
THEY'RE COMMITTED TO PROVIDING.
WITH A SAFE AND RELIABLE WAY
SEND MONEY TO FAMILY AND
FRIENDS THEY BUILD ENTERTAIN
OTHER FINANCIAL SIR. AT THE
TIME I COPPER THROUGH OF YOU
CAN. AND OKAY ALL PROVIDE
SERVER TO THE CHINA. YEAH MY
NAME IS ADAM I REPEAT THE MONEY
GONNA TRY. BY ALL WORK WITH A
LARGE NUMBER OF MONEY.
COMPANIES. BUT PARTY GAVE HIM
MONEY COMMISSIONS TO ALL
DIFFERENT TYPES WHICH IN MY-
THE MIGHT SEE A LOT OF THE
TECHCONNECT IN THE- PROVIDED IN
THAT SPACE. PARKER FOR MONEY
SERVICES CONCERN. WE DO A- THAT.
ALL THE CONCEPTS. IS
CONFLICTING WITH YOUR THRUST
AND SHARING BACK THERE IS
BECAUSE SERVICE ABOUT. TO
CONSUMERSWITH THAT BEING SOME
OF THE CAR OF THE NEW AND WAIT
INVESTING LAW TOP AND IN OTHERS.
AND FEDERAL BECAUSE PROTECTION
THAT APPLY TO MONEY COMPANIES
SUCH AS DETERMINED TRANSFER
ROLE AND THE CRICKET WILL ALL
OF HE. INSURING THAT CUSTOMERS
HAPPY NOTED THE CONTRACT
LICENSEES FOR ASSISTANCE WITH
THEIR MONEY TRANSMISSIONS. WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE HAVE BEEN
ONGOING NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE AND WE WERE OUT
OF SUPPORT EFFORTS TO CONFIRM
AND CLARIFY THAT HE MIGHT SEE
THAT PROVIDE A PHONE NUMBER
THAT CONSUMERS CAN CALL THE
CUSTOMER ASSISTANCE. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE NEW
PROVISIONS PROPOSED BY THE
LEGISLATION. WE ALSO BELIEVE
THAT THE NATURE OF THIS
LEGISLATION IT CENTRAL. THE
BILL SPECIFYING WHICH
REQUIREMENTS APPLY TO CONSUMER
TRANSACTIONS ONLY DID NOT APPLY
TO MONEY TRANSMISSION SERVICES
PROVIDED TO COMMERCIAL ENTITIES
FOR COMMERCIAL PURPOSES.
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS FIFTY
TRANSACTION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH THE LEGISLATURE RIGHT. ALL
RIGHTY THANK YOU MR FLEISCHER-
ANYONE IN THE IN THE GALLERY
OPPOSED. TWO A. B. ONE THREE
TWO ZERO SAYING NO ONE NO ONE
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE- LET'S GO TO
THE PHONE LINE TAKE OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE GIVE US YOUR
NAME YOUR AFFILIATION IN YOUR
POSITION. MODERATORS ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE. WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO AB.
ONE THREE TWO ZERO. RELATED JIM
IF YOU WISH TO WAIT A YEAR AND
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS. ONE
ZERO. IF SOMEONE HAS A CUTE ONE
MILLER ONE OPERATOR GETS IN
THEIR LINE NUMBER. I'M SORRY
MODERATOR IS THERE ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSITION. THEY
JUST QUEUED UP AN OPERATOR IS
GIVING THEM THEIR LINE NUMBER
AT THE MOMENT. OKAY. AND
OPPOSITION WE HAVE LINED UP ONE
FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YOUR CHAIR AND MEMBERS ARE JUST
AN AMOUNT THAT SOMEBODY HALF
ELECTRONIC TRANSACTIONS
ASSOCIATION- MISTER CHAIR- WITH
YOUR PERMISSION- WOULD BE OKAY
IF I READ IT I JUST A FEW BRIEF
REMARKS IN REGARDS TO THE BILL.
SURE WE'VE ONLY HAD ONE WITNESS
AN OPPOSITION THUS FAR GO HEAD.
THANK YOU BUT AGAIN ARTISTS
AMANDA FROM THE APPLE
ACCOUNTING TRANSACTIONS
ASSOCIATION CALLING IN TODAY
WITH AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION- I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR ALLOWING ME- THE
OPPORTUNITIES BRIEF REMARKS BUT
BEFORE I BEGIN THOUGH I DO WANT
TO THANK ASSEMBLYMEMBER POWER
KEY HAND FOR HER CONTINUED
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH US AND
OUR CONCERNS WITH THE BILL- WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING THAT
DIALOGUE HER STAFF HAS BEEN
FANTASTIC IN TERMS OF LISTENING
TO US AND WE- GREATLY
APPRECIATE THAT. WE AGREE WITH
HIS FAMILY MEMBER THAT
CONSUMERS DESERVE HIGH LEVELS
OF CUSTOMER SERVICE WHEN IT
COMES TO MONEY TRANSMISSION
ISSUES- WE AGREE WITH THAT
FOUNDATIONAL PREMISE THAT- IN
THIS BILL. BERS INVEST A LOT OF
TIMES STAFF AND RESOURCES TO
GIVE CONSUMERS CHOICES ON HOW
THEY CAN GET IN CONTACT WITH
OUR COMPANIES WHEN ISSUES
ARISE. IN THAT WE SHARE THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS CONCERNED IN
THAT RESPECT. WHERE WE DIFFER
WITH THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS ON
THE PRACTICAL IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE BILL OF LANGUAGE- THAT'S
CURRENTLY IN PRINT TODAY-
ACROSS THE ENTIRE LICENSEE
UNIVERSE. OUR CONCERNS ON THIS
FRONT CAN REALLY BE BOILED DOWN
INTO FOUR MAIN THINGS. NUMBER
ONE WE ARE STRONGLY CONCERNED
ABOUT EIGHTY THIRTEEN TWENTIES
PROPOSE REQUIREMENTS THAT A
LICENSEE. REPLY WITHIN TWENTY
FOUR HOURS TO CONSUMER CONTEXT
LICENSEE FOR CUSTOMER SERVICE
ISSUES. AND THE SPECIFIC
OBLIGATIONS OUTLINED IN THE
BILL WITH RESPECT TO HOW OUR
MEMBERS REPLY TO THIS ISSUE. MR
SCRIPTED REQUIREMENTS FOR THE
TIMING AND NATURE OF THE
RESPONSE TO ANY OUTRAGE A
LICENSEE CONFLICT WITH OTHER
REGULATORY OBLIGATIONS THE
LICENSEES HAVE. IN MANY CASES
COULD INADVERTENTLY RESULT IN
CONSUMERS RECEIVING INFERIOR AT
ASSISTANCE. SOLVING MATTERS.
NUMBER TWO WE ARE CONCERNED
THAT A B. THIRTEEN TWENTY TO
PROPOSE REQUIREMENTS TO PROVIDE
A QUOTE INDIVIDUALIZED REPLY IN
QUOTE WITHIN THAT TWENTY FOUR
HOUR TIME FRAME OF BEING
CONTACTED. BY A CONSUMER FOR A
CUSTOMER SERVICE ISSUE WOULD
CREATE SIGNIFICANT COMPLIANCE
AND LOGISTICAL CHALLENGES FOR
LICENSEES AND COULD DISRUPT
PROCESSES CURRENTLY IN PLACE TO
ADDRESS CUSTOMER CONCERNS AND
ISSUES RELATING TO LICENSEES
PROVISION A MUD MONEY
TRANSMISSION SERVICES. THE
REQUIREMENT TO PROVIDE AN
INDIVIDUALIZED REPLY TO ANY
CONTACT RECEIVED BY THE
LICENSEE RELATED TO CUSTOMER
SERVICE ISSUES AS BROAD AND
VAGUE AND INCONSISTENT WITH
CURRENT NATIONWIDE STANDARDS.
REGULATORY MEASURES THAT
LICENSEES HAVE TO MEET. NUMBER
THREE ALL RIGHTY THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LAPTOP. YOU'RE BEYOND YOU
TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN APPRECIATE YOUR TIME
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT A FAIRLY
FOUND MISTER BELL SO- ALTHOUGH
WE'RE IN OUT OF ORDER BUT
MISTER BELL. THANK YOU SO MUCH-
CHAIRMAN NUMBER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS CHUCK BELL
I'M PROGRAM DIRECTOR FOR
CONSUMER REPORTS. WE'RE A
NATIONAL NONPROFIT MEMBERSHIP
ORGANIZATION THAT WORKS WITH
CONSUMERS FOR FAIR AND
TRANSPARENT MARKETPLACE. THE
POPULARITY OF CASH TRANSFER
APPS AND ONLINE SERVICES HAS
GROWN BY LEAPS AND BOUNDS WITH
MORE THAN NINETY MILLION ADULTS
NOW USING MOBILE PAYMENT APPS.
IN OUR RESEARCH CONSUMER
REPORTS ABOUT CONSUMERS DO
SOMETIMES HAVE SIGNIFICANT
PROBLEMS USING THESE SERVICES.
AND WHEN THEY DO THEY WANT TO
BE ABLE TO CONTACT THE COMPANY
DIRECTLY TO GET HELP QUICKLY.
YET FEW SERVICE PROVIDERS MAKE
TELEPHONE CONTACT NUMBERS
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE LEAVING
CONSUMERS HIGHLY FRUSTRATED. BY
NOT PROVIDING PHONE NUMBERS
MONEY SERVICE BUSINESSES ARE
LEAVING THE DOOR OPEN FOR
SCAMMERS TO POSE AS HELPLINES
FOR THE APPLE OR SERVICE. AND
GAIN ACCESS TO THE USER'S
HIGHLY SENSITIVE PERSONAL
INFORMATION TO COMMIT FRAUD. IN
ADDITION TWITTER AND REDDIT ARE
FULL OF COMPLAINTS FROM
CONSUMERS WHO ARE URGENTLY
SEEKING HELP FROM COMPANIES
THEY ENTRUSTED THEIR MONEY TO.
SOME LIKE VICTOR ON TWITTER
EXPLAINED HE TRIED EMAILING A
MONEY TRANSFER APP COMPANY AND
THEN GET A RESPONSE FOR TWO
WEEKS. AND IS DESPERATE TO FIND
A PHONE NUMBER FOR CUSTOMER
SERVICE REPRESENTATIVE TO TALK
TO. HAS MONEY TRANSFER APPS
BECOME MORE POPULAR CONSUMERS
ARE INCREASINGLY RELIANT ON
DIGITAL FINANCIAL TOOLS TO
MANAGE THEIR PRECIOUS HOUSEHOLD
FUNDS. WHAT'S THE FUNDS COULD
BE CATASTROPHIC TO FAMILIES
EXPERIENCING FINANCIAL HARDSHIP.
PEOPLE RELIANT ON MONEY
SERVICES BUSINESSES TO MOVE
MONEY SHOULD NOT HAVE TO SEARCH
SO HARD FOR HEALTH. PROVIDER
SHOULD BE REQUIRED TO DO MORE
TO PREVENT PEOPLE FROM FALLING
VICTIM TO SCAMMERS WHEN SEEKING
ASSISTANCE. SO FOR ALL THESE
REASONS AB THIRTEEN TWENTY IS
AN EXCELLENT FIRST STEP TOWARDS
ENSURING THAT PROVIDERS LIVE UP
TO CONSUMER EXPECTATIONS TO
PROVIDE ASSISTANCE IN THE EVENT
THAT THE USERS ENCOUNTER
DIFFICULTIES. BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMERS WE REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA CONSUMER REPORT
STRONGLY URGES AND I FELL ON A.
B. THIRTEEN TWENTY NINE THANK
YOU MISTER BELL. BY GOING BACK
TO THE OPPOSITION- WE NOTED NO
OPPOSITION IN THE GALLERY NOR.
OPPOSITION IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
GO BACK TO TH PHONE LINES.
MODERATOR ANYONE ELSE ON THE
PHONE IN OPPOSITION TO- A. B.
ONE THREE TWO ZERO. SHARE IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO SHOW
OPPOSITION TO AB THIRTEEN
TWENTY PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME.
A. T. T. OPERATOR IS GOING TO
GIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER I PLAN
PLEASE YOU BACK INTO THE QUEUE.
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. AND WE WILL GO TO LINE
ONE THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE THIRTY THREE TOOK
YOURSELF OUT OF THE QUEUE WOULD
YOU LIKE TO RE QUEUE. THEY ARE
NOT RE QUEUEING- THERE'S NOBODY
ELSE THANK YOU ALL ONE FINAL
REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE.
FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO SHOW
OPPOSITION. FOR BILL AB.
THIRTEEN TWENTY. TRANSITIONAL
PARTICIPANTS QUEUING UP OUR E.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- LET'S
BRING BACK THE CHAMBER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS I SEE-
CENTER BOARDS MICROPHONE UP.
THEIR FOR JUST. LIKE MOST MAKE
MOTION AS YOU. MOVE ON THE BILL.
ALL RIGHT THERE'S A MOTION- ANY
OTHER. COMMENTS NO OTHER
COMMENTS QUESTIONS SECTION ALL
RIGHT. YES I'M SORRY SENECA
EURO THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MAYBE
I MISSED THIS BUT I THERE WAS
AN ISSUE THAT WAS RAISED IN
REGARDS TO- WHETHER THE
REQUIREMENT TO RESPOND WITHIN
TWENTY FOUR HOURS WAS TO HAVE
SOLVED THE ISSUE THAT WAS. THAT
THAT WAS THE SUBJECT OF THE
COMMUNICATION OR WHETHER IT WAS
JUST A PERSONAL. COMMUNICATION
THAT WAS REQUIRED WITHIN TWENTY
FOUR HOURS ALL RIGHT LET ME ASK
THE AUTHOR. CERTAINLY MEMBER.
THANK YOU M. CENTER CAREER- AND
IF I DON'T UNDERSTAND YOUR
QUESTION PLEASE. TELL ME- SO
CURRENTLY THE LAW REQUIRES THAT
WITHIN TWENTY FOUR HOURS THEY
PROVIDE INDIVIDUALIZED RESPONSE
ALTHOUGH WE ARE I WILL CLARIFY
THAT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
OPPOSITION HAS ASKED IS FOR US
TO HAVE A SAFE HARBOR. FOR
COMPANIES THAT DO PROVIDE
SIGNIFICANT CALL CENTER TIME
FOR THEM TO GET THAT
INDIVIDUALIZED RESPONSE ON THE
PHONE AND WE ARE WORKING ON
THAT LANGUAGE AND ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT THEY HAVE ASKED FOR
IS FOR US TO EXTEND OUT THE
TWENTY FOUR HOUR TIME PERIOD
NOW I'LL BE HONEST WITH YOU THE
FBI. HAS CONCERNS ABOUT THAT
BECAUSE THEY WERE THEY'VE ASKED
US TO MOVE IT TO THREE DAYS AND
IN FACT THERE ARE CERTAIN
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS THAT WILL
BE WEAKENED IF WE MOVE IT DOES
THAT TWO THREE DAYS SO WE ARE
WORKING WITH BOTH THE AGENCY.
AND OPPOSITION TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT THE RIGHT TIME FRAME IS TO
PROTECT CONSUMERS. AND MAKE IT
FEASIBLE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
APPRECIATE THAT I THINK- I
REALLY LIKE THE BILL BECAUSE
THERE'S NOTHING WORSE. THAN NOT
HAVING A LIVE PERSON TO ASK A
QUESTION. OF WHEN YOU'VE- WHEN
YOU'VE BEEN A GOOD CUSTOMER AND
IT'S A GOOD BUSINESS CUSTOMERS
I SUPPORT- THE EFFORTS HERE
AND- I'M I'M HAPPY WITH YOUR
YOUR RESPONSE AND- I LOOK
FORWARD TO SEE. YOU KNOW HOW IT
CHANGES BY THE TIME HE GETS THE
FOUR BUT I'M GOING TO BE
SUPPORTING IT TODAY AND- I WILL
MOVE THE BILL WHEN IT'S
APPROPRIATE MIXTURE. THANK YOU
SO THE CAREER CENTER BOARD IS
ALREADY BEAT YOU TO THE PUNCH-
MAN CHIEF COUNSEL- CINDER BAR I
MEAN TO ME SO THE MEMBER BAR
KAY AND DO CARE CLOSE. THANK
YOU ALL AND- WE WILL CONTINUE
WORK ON IT AND WE WILL UPDATE
YOUR OFFICES BEFORE IT COMES TO
THE FLOOR BUT I RESPECT LAST
YEAR I THINK. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU COUNSEL YOU CALL THE ROLL
YES THIS IS THE A. B. THIRTEEN
TWENTY WITH THE MOTION BY
SENATOR FOR JESS THE MOTION IS
TO PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
AMBERG. I AM BERG I PORGES
GORGEOUS BY PROBABLY AT ALL I.
HAD A I DID ALSO. WANT SILAS HI
WHEN SELES I HURTS. BURG JONES.
JONES I. LAYERED ON LAYERED I.
STERN WHITE HOUSE SKI. WHITE
HOUSE SKI FIVE WINNER. YOU HAVE
SEVENTY ZERO SO FAR. CLUB PLACE
SAID BILL ON CALL-
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BERMAN. WAITING
IN THE WINGS. NEXT UP IS ITEM
NUMBER TWO FILE NUMBER TWO A.
B. THREE NINE ZERO BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN. SEVEN MEMBER
BERMAN CLOSURES THANKS MISTER
CHAIRMAN SENATORS. HAVE YOU
EVER TRIED TO CANCEL A SERVICE
ONLINE ONLY TO BE CONFRONTED
WITH AN INCONVENIENCE CONFUSING
TIME CONSUMING PROCESS THAT
SEEMS DESIGNED TO GET YOU TO
GIVE UP AND KEEP PAYING. OR
SIGN UP FOR FREE TRIAL OFFER
SUBSCRIPTION AT A PROMOTIONAL
PRICE ONLY TO FORGET AND LATER
BE CHARGED FULL PRICE FOR A
PRODUCT OR SERVICE YOU DON'T
REALLY WANT OR NEED. TAKE FOR
EXAMPLE THE EXPERIENCE OF A
FORMER CAPITOL STAFFER WHO
STRUGGLE TO CANCEL HER CLASS
PASS SUBSCRIPTION. SHE WORKED
HER WAY THROUGH THE APP HOPING
TO FIND A BUTTON TO CANCEL BUT
THERE WASN'T ONE. SO SHE
RESORTED TO USING THE CHAT
FEATURE. HER STRUGGLE CONTINUED
AS THE CUSTOMER REPRESENTATIVE
ASKED FOR AND ASKED HER
NUMEROUS QUESTIONS. FORCING HER
TO EXPLAIN THAT SHE WAS
QUITTING HER JOB MOVING GOING
BACK TO SCHOOL I COULD NO
LONGER FOR THE SERVICE. ALL
PERSONAL INFORMATION THE
CONSUMER SHOULD NOT HAVE TO
SHARE THE CANCELLATION IN SAP.
THE BUSINESS ALSO TRIED
OFFERING HER OTHER SERVICES
WHICH SHE DECLINED. THIS
EXPERIENCE AND OTHERS HIGHLIGHT
THE NEED TO STRENGTHEN
CALIFORNIA LAW TO PROTECT
CONSUMERS EIGHTY THREE NINETY
WOULD DO TWO THINGS FIRST IT
WOULD REQUIRE BUSINESSES TO
NOTIFY CONSUMERS BEFORE THE
EXPIRATION OF A FREE GIFT TRIAL
OR PROMOTIONAL OR DISCOUNTED
PRICE THAT IS LONGER THAN
THIRTY ONE DAYS. BEFORE THE
EXPIRATION OF A SUBSCRIPTION
THAT AUTOMATICALLY RENEWS ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS OR LESS
FREQUENTLY. SECONDED TO ENSURE
THAT CONSUMERS DO NOT HAVE TO
JUMP THROUGH HOOPS AND INDOOR
LENGTHY LENGTHY CANCELLATION
PROCESS THE BILL SPECIFIES THAT
CONSUMERS MUST BE ABLE TO
CANCEL THEIR SUBSCRIPTIONS
ONLINE AT WILL AND WITHOUT ANY
FURTHER STEPS THAT OBSTRUCT OR
DELAY THEIR ABILITY TO CANCEL
IMMEDIATELY. WE'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH THE OPPOSITION OVER THE
LAST TWO YEARS AND I AM PLEASED
THAT THE LATEST ROUND OF
AMENDMENTS MOVED MOST OF THE
OPPOSITION TO NEUTRAL. WITH ME
TODAY BY PHONE IS ALAMEDA
COUNTY DEPUTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY
MATTHEW BELL TRAUMA ON BEHALF
OF THE ALAMEDA COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY NANCY O'MALLEY. AND
DANIELLE CANDLE KAISER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LOW
INCOME CONSUMER COALITION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MR
BELTRAME ALL. ARE YOU AVAILABLE
FOR MISS. CANDLE KAISER. THANK
YOU THIS IS A MEDICAL PROBLEM
HERE. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MATT
BELTRAME WELL I'M AN ASSISTANT
DISTRICT ATTORNEY IN THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY DA'S OFFICE I
SPEAK TODAY ON BEHALF OF OUR
ELECTED DISTRICT ATTORNEY NANCY
O'MALLEY IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE
NINETY. I SERVED AS AN ATTORNEY
IN THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE FOR APPROXIMATELY TWENTY
YEARS FOR TWELVE OF THOSE YEARS
I'VE HANDLED CASES INVOLVING
CONSUMER PROTECTION MATTERS
THIS IS IMPOSSIBLE ON BEHALF OF
THE PEOPLE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THE CASES INVOLVE
COMPANIES LARGE AND SMALL THAT
DO BUSINESS IN OUR STATE AND
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY AMONG
THE STATUTE THAT FREQUENTLY
ARISE IS CALIFORNIA'S AUTOMATIC
RENEWAL LAW. THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT PIECE OF CONSUMER
PROTECTION LEGISLATION
AUTOMATIC RENEWAL CONTRACTS CAN
BE TRAPS FOR THE UNWARY WHICH
CAN RESULT IN MONTHS AND
SOMETIMES YEARS OF UNNOTICED
CREDIT CARD CHARGES THE A. R.
L. REQUIRES COMPANIES THAT WISH
TO ENTER INTO SUCH CONTRACTS
WITH CONSUMERS TO MAKE CERTAIN
DISCLOSURES ENTERTAIN
AFFIRMATIVE CONSENT. MY
COLLEAGUES AROUND THE STATE NOW
I HAVE HANDLED DOZENS OF CIVIL
INVESTIGATIONS INVOLVING
VIOLATIONS OF THE A. R. L. THE
MAJORITY OF THESE ACTIONS HAVE
RESULTED IN STIPULATED COURT
INJUNCTION MEANT TO SAFEGUARD
CONSUMERS FROM AUTOMATIC REAL
CONTRACTS. THAT DO NOT COMPLY
WITH THE LAW. B. A. R. L. HAVE
BEEN A REAL ASSET CONSUMER
GETTING. CALIFORNIA'S ROLE AS A
LEADER IN CONSUMER PROTECTION.
D. A. R. L. AS CURRENTLY
WRITTEN HOWEVER IS NOT PERFECT
SOME HOMES REMAIN. FOR EXAMPLE
NOTHING IN THE CURRENT LAW
REQUIRES COMPANIES TO NOTIFY
CONSUMERS WHEN THEY'RE ABOUT TO
BE CHARGED EITHER AT THE END OF
A FREE TRIAL PERIOD. OR AT THE
TIME OF AN ANNUAL RENEWAL.
SINCE THE VAST MAJORITY OF
CONSUMER TRANSACTIONS THESE
DAYS ARE COMPLETED ONLINE SUCH
NOTIFICATIONS WOULD BE
INEXPENSIVE AND EASY TO
AUTOMATE. ALSO ALTHOUGH THE
STATUTE IS CURRENTLY WRITTEN
REQUIRES A COMPANY THAT OFFERS
AN AUTO RENEW CONTRACT ONLINE
TO ALLOW CANCELLATION ONLINE.
WE'VE SEEN COMPANIES MAKE
CANCELLATION TRICKY OR TIME
CONSUMING AND REQUIRES
CONSUMERS. TO JUMP THROUGH
HOOPS TO STOP THE CHARGES. THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY SUPPORT
EIGHTY THREE NINETY BECAUSE IT
STRENGTHENS ITS IMPORTANT
STATUTE BY HELPING TO PLUG THE
HOLES. FIRST IT REQUIRES THAT A
BUSINESS WILL NOTIFY CUSTOMERS
BEFORE THEIR CREDIT CARD IS
CHARGED EITHER CONCLUSION. OF
EVERY TRIAL PERIOD OF OVER
THIRTY DAYS OR BEFORE AN ANNUAL
RENEWAL PERIOD. GIVING
CONSUMERS SUCH NOTICE WILL HELP
AVOID CONFUSION AND THE
SURPRISE THAT OFTEN ARISES WHEN
BUSY CUSTOMERS FORGET THEY HAVE
ENROLLED IN THE- BUILDING FROM
PROGRAM THANK YOU SIR- THANK
YOU MISS. DANIEL KIND OF KAISER
YOU AVAILABLE. SHE GOOD
AFTERNOON SHERRIN AND DANIELLE
COUNTERPART THERE HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LOW
INCOME CONSUMER COALITION AND
WE'RE PLEASED TO CONTINUE OUR
SUPPORT AT EIGHTY THREE NINETY.
THE STATEWIDE COALITION OF
LEGAL SERVICE PROVIDERS THAT
STRIVES TO ENSURE THAT ALL
PEOPLE REGARDLESS OF THEIR
INCOME OR BACKGROUND HAVE
OPPORTUNITIES. UNDER THE LAW TO
ACHIEVE THEIR FULL POTENTIAL WE
SEEK TO ENSURE THAT ALL
CONSUMERS IN CALIFORNIA HOW
THEIR VOICES HEARD AND THEIR
NEEDS RECOGNIZED BY THE
LEGISLATURE. FOR MUSIC
STREAMING TO MEAL KIT TO
DIETING AND FITNESS OUT MORE
MORE CONSUMERS ARE SUBSCRIBING
TO PRODUCT AND SERVICES ONLINE.
AS THE STATE CONTINUES TO
RECOVER FROM THE ECONOMIC
IMPACT OF CODE NINETEEN MANY
CALIFORNIANS MUST FIND
ADDITIONAL WAYS TO SAVE MONEY.
DURING THE CHALLENGING TIMES IT
IS ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT THAT
CONSUMERS HAVE A CLEAR PATHWAY
TO DISCONTINUING SERVICES THAT
THEY AND THEIR FAMILIES NO
LONGER LONGER NEED OR CAN'T
AFFORD. THE COALITION CENTER
THE LEGAL AID NEEDS THOUSANDS
OF CALIFORNIANS EVERY YEAR WE
ARE KEENLY AWARE OF THE CURRENT
RECESSION NECESSITATE CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS. THAT REVENT OUR
MOST VULNERABLE RESIDENTS FROM
FALLING FURTHER INTO DEBT AND
FINANCIAL HARDSHIP. WE SUPPORT
THE AIMS AT EIGHTY THREE NINETY
TO BOLSTER CONSUMER PROTECTIONS
BY ALLOWING CONSUMERS TO CANCEL
THE PRODUCT AND SERVICES ONLINE
EASILY. WELL FORWARD TO OUR
CONTINUING SUPPORT OF THE BILL
AND WE REQUEST YOUR IDEAS.
THANK YOU- ALL RIGHT- ANYONE IN
THE GALLERY. IN SUPPORT NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ANYONE
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE. NOT SING IN
ONE ROOM ONE TWELVE BY THE WAY.
ONE TO RECOGNIZE THEIR GUESTS
IN THE GALLERY WE'RE HAPPY TO
HAVE- OBSERVERS RETURN HERE TO
THE CAPITAL SO THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US TODAY. ALL RIGHT.
LET'S GO TO OTHER SUPPORT ON
THE PHONE. SHARE TO SHOW YOUR
SUPPORT FOR- A. B. THERE ARE
SKEWS ME AT THIRTY THREE NINETY
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. ONE ZERO FOUR AB THREE
NINETY. WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE
CAN. HI GOOD AFTERNOON.
COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FINE GAEL WE
WORK ON BEHALF OF THE SAN DIEGO
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY SUMMER
STEPHAN WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY THREE NINETY
AND WE'VE HEARD TONIGHT THAT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND AGAIN
TO SHOW OUR SUPPORT FOR AB
THREE NINETY PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND MISTER
CHAIR NOBODY ELSE'S QUEUING UP
AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT LET'S
TURN THE OPPOSITION I DON'T
HAVE ANY PRIMARY OPPOSITION
WHEN THIS IS LISTED- THAT'S
ASKING THE GALLERY ANYONE OF
THE GALLERY IN OPPOSITION TO AB
THREE NINETY SEEING NON. ROOM
ONE TWELVE SEEING NO WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION AB THREE NINETY-
LET US TURN TO THE PHONE.
MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
IN OPPOSITION TO AB THREE
NINETY. EXPRESS OPPOSITION FOR
AB THREE NINETY PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. ONE FILED BY ZERO.
MOMENT WE DO HAVE A COUPLE
QUEUED UP. OPERATORS FOR
EVERYBODY ELSE GOING AT ONE
ZERO TO GET YOUR LINE NUMBER.
IT WILL BEGIN WITH LINE ONE
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BY BILL HOFFMAN ON BEHALF OF
INTERNET ASSOCIATION OF WESTERN
OPPOSITION BUT EVALUATING OUR
POSITION BASED ON MY RESUME AND
COMPLETE THE WORK. ALREADY
THANK YOU. OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
FIND ONE TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. RICHARD WOULD LEAD TO AN
APPLICANT TICKET ON THIS AND WE
HAVE A NEUTRAL POSITION WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THE WORK.
THAT I WOULD GET TO ME NUMBER.
AND EXTENT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT AND THE FINAL REMINDER
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO TO SHOW OPPOSITION. EIGHTY
THREE NINETY. AND MISTER
CHAIRMAN WE HAVE EXHAUSTED THE
QUEUE ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH BACK TO THE CHAMBER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS SIGNAL
MICROPHONES RAISED- CENTER
LAYERED MOVES THE BILL- THANK
YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER BRED BY THE
WAY I NOW UNDERSTAND WHY STILL
THE SUBSCRIPTION LIFE MAGAZINE-
I APPRECIATE YOU BRING A BILL
FORWARD OKAY- WOULD LIKE CLOSE
YOU DID A GREAT JOB CLOSING FOR
ME- RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU. MEANT TO
CANCEL IF YOU CALL THE ROLL YES
THIS IS EIGHTY THREE NINETY
WITH THE MOTION. BY SENATOR
LAYERED. THE MOTION IS TO PASS.
AMBERG BY AMBERG FIVE FORGES ON
BRIDGES I CAN BE AT ALL I. HAD
A I DID ALSO. ONE SILAS HI WHEN
SELES HI HURTS BERG. JONES
JONES I LAYERED ON A LAYERED
ICE STERN. WHITE HOUSE GARY WHY
CASKEY FIVE WINNER. WINNER I.
ALL RIGHT I HAVE EIGHT ZERO SO
FAR THANK YOU SO THE NUMBER
WE'RE GONNA PUT THAT ON CALL- I
SEE SOME REMEMBER GONZALEZ.
NEXT IS A B. TWO EIGHT SIX-
PHYLUM NUMBER NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GONZALEZ. THANK
YOU MR HELLO GO AHEAD ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
SENATORS A. B. TWO EIGHTY SIX
AIMS TO PROVIDE PRICE
TRANSPARENCY TO BOTH RESTAURANT
OWNERS AND CUSTOMERS AND FOOD
DELIVERY TRANSACTIONS ENSURING
THEY UNDERSTAND THE TRUE COST
OF THE SERVICE AND WHO IS
PAYING FOR THEM. IN RECENT
YEARS FOOD DELIVERY COMPANIES
HAVE AGGRESSIVELY ENTERED THE
FOOD SERVICE SPACE MAKING
PROMISES THAT THEY WILL GROW
RESTAURANT REVENUES AND EVEN
OFFERING LIMITED TIME DISCOUNTS
TO GET RESTAURANTS TO JOIN.
EXCHANGE FOR LISTING A
RESTAURANT UNDER SERVICE AND
PROVIDE A DELIVERY SERVICE
RESTAURANTS PAY DELIVERY
COMPANIES A COMMISSION ON THEIR
SALES THESE COMMISSIONS AND
FEES VERY. VERY RESTAURANT TO
RESTAURANT WITH COMMISSION
RATES FREQUENTLY REACHING AND
EXCEEDING 30% OF THE PURCHASE
PRICE. CONSUMERS ALSO PAY A
VARIETY OF FEES FROM SPECIFIC
LISTED DELIVERY FEES TO HIDDEN
COSTS INFLATED MENU PRICES.
TRANSPARENCY OF THE COST OF
SERVICE WOULD HELP EMPOWER ALL
PARTIES TO MAKE AN INFORMED
DECISION. ABOUT WHICH ENTITIES
TO PARTNER WITH AND PURCHASE
FROM. TRANSPARENCY TO
RESTAURANTS IS BENEFICIAL FOR
BUSINESS PURPOSES PARTICULARLY
TO HELP THEM DETERMINE THE
OVERALL VALUE OF THE FOOD
DELIVERY COMPANY BRINGS TO THE
INDIVIDUAL RESTAURANT. FOR
CONSUMERS TRANSPARENCY WILL
ALLOW THEM TO BETTER UNDERSTAND
HOW THE DOLLAR SUPPORT
RESTAURANTS. AND THE WORKERS TO
PROVIDE THEM THE FOOD AND
DELIVERY SERVICE AND HOW MUCH
GOES TO THE THIRD PARTY
DELIVERY COMPANIES. A. B.
TWENTY SIX WOULD SIMPLY PROVIDE
A FACTUAL ITEMIZED COST
BREAKDOWN OF THE SERVICES
PROVIDED BOTH. TO CONSUMERS AND
RESTAURANT OWNERS THIS WOULD
INCLUDE MAKING SURE CHARGES OR
FEES PAID TO THE THIRD PARTY
ARE LISTED AS SUCH. RATHER THAN
REFLECTED IN HIGHER MENU PRICES
AND OF SET BY THE RESTAURANT
WHICH CAN CAUSE CONSUMER
CONFUSION. FURTHER MORE THIS
BILL WILL ENSURE TIPS AND
GRATUITIES ARE PAID TO THE
DELIVERY DRIVER OR FOR PICK UP
ORDERS TO THE FOOD FACILITY.
HAVE WITNESSES ON THE PHONE-
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER I'D
THAT MIKEY NAB IS THAT YOUR
WITNESS OKAY- MIKEY NAP IF
YOU'RE AVAILABLE YEAH THE FLOOR
IS YOURS YES CAN YOU ALL HEAR
ME WE CAN. OKAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR AND FOUNDER. MY NAME IS
MIKE YOU KNOW I'M NOT IN THE
NATIONAL STRATEGY DIRECTOR FOR
READ HIGH ROAD RESTAURANT WHICH
IS. A NETWORK OF OVER A
THOUSAND RESTAURANTS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY TO MAKE COMMITMENT TO
WHAT WE CALL HIGH ROAD
EMPLOYMENT PRACTICES. INCLUDE
INCREASED WAGES AND IMPROVE
WORKING CONDITIONS AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY TO OUR MEMBERS THE
COMMITMENT TO RACE AND GENDER
EQUITY IN THE RESTAURANT
INDUSTRY AT LARGE. I'M HERE TO
TESTIFY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE FAMILY BILL TO EIGHTY SIX.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR HER WORK ON THIS
ISSUE OUR CONTINUED EFFORTS TO
ENSURE THE RESTAURATEURS
CONSUMERS. AND WORKER AND HAVE
A STRONG PROTECTIONS IN PLACE
WHILE UTILIZING THE GIG ECONOMY
COMPANIES. EIGHTY TWO EIGHTY
SIX AIMS TO SIMPLIFY. THE
TYPICALLY PROVIDE PRICE
TRANSPARENCY TO BOTH RESTAURANT
OWNERS AND CUSTOMERS. TO INSURE
THAT WE HAVE A FULL
UNDERSTANDING OF THE COST. OF
THE SERVICE PROVIDED BY THIRD
PARTY FOOD DELIVERY COMPANY.
AIRBNB CHARGED RIGHT THERE
PARTY COULD COME TO CUSTOMER
BUSINESS OWNER. ARE AT-
pBEEN EMPLOYING DESIGN PRACTICES
THAT OBVIOUS GATE FEES. BUT
ULTIMATELY IMPACTED FACILITIES
PROFIT AND WORKER PAY.
TRANSPARENCY IS HELPFUL TO
EMPOWER BUSINESS OWNERS TO
UNDERSTAND THE FULL SCOPE OF B.
THEIR CUSTOMER HEY AND THEREBY
MAKE. CLEAR DECISIONS ABOUT THE
VALUE THAT THE THIRD PARTY
DELIVERY COMPANY ACTUALLY
PROVIDES YOUR BUSINESS. EMERGED
OFF THE DESSERTS AND KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE PAYING FOR. THE SERVICE
TO BE A CHIP OR A MEAL. AND WHO
THEY'RE PAYING FOR IT SO THEY
CAN MAKE INFORMED DECISIONS
ABOUT WHETHER AND HOW TO
UTILIZE THE SERVICE. WITH AN
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW THE
SERVICES AFFECT THEIR WHOLE
ECONOMY LOCALLY- FEATURE IS ONE
OF MANY MECHANISMS AN ECOSYSTEM
OF CHANGE THAT WE NEE IN ORDER
TO FURTHER HOLD. THIRD PARTY
DELIVERY COMPANIES ACCOUNTABLE
THE MANY STAKEHOLDERS TO RELY
ON OUR SERVICES. THERE ARE
CITIES LIKE LOS ANGELES CHICAGO
AND WASHINGTON DC WASHINGTON DC
SHOULD BE A STATE CURRENTLY THE
CITY. HAVE IMPLEMENTED SIMILAR
MEASURES TO INCREASE
TRANSPARENCY FOR CONSUMERS.
CALIFORNIA STATE CAN AND SHOULD
LEAD THE WAY. FOR THESE REASONS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. AN EIGHTY TWO EIGHTY SIX
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU MR
KNAPP OTHERS IN SUPPORT I SEE.
R. ONE PERSON A POST
APPROACHING THE MICROPHONE- GO
AHEAD SIR IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN BIRDS RENEE MY
ORDER WITH SEIU CALIFORNIANS
WORK. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE IN THE GALLERY IN
SUPPORT. ABOUT ROOM ONE TWELVE
SEE NO ONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
LET'S TURN TO THE PHONES.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF MODERATE
IF YOU WOULD Q. THOSE UP IN
SUPPORT ON THE PHONE. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN THE PHONE LINE IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR
A B. TWO EIGHTY SIX PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
AN OPERATOR WILL GIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER OFFLINE. INITIAL SUPPORT
FOR. EIGHTY TWO EIGHTY SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AND WE
WILL ALIGN ONE THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. PAKISTAN ON
BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA IS THE
PART. NEXT AND THE FINAL
REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. THE ONE WE
HAD A GREAT ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
MUST BE HAVING A QUESTION
THEY'RE STILL WITH THE OPERATOR.
ABOUT THE DELAY AND WE DO HAVE
AMOUNT ONE THIRTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HAWAII STATE
CONFERENCE WE SUPPORT. IT WITH
THE BEAT THANKS THANK YOU- NO
OTHER PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT
THIS TIME MISTER CHAIR ALL
RIGHT LET'S TURNED OPPOSITION I
SEE THERE ARE TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES LISTED IN OPPOSITION-
LILY ROQUE WROTE JOHN AND DYLAN
HOFFMAN. OF THE STRUCTURE FOR
MR HOFFMAN YOUR AVAILABLE.
MODERATE MODERATOR IRELAND
EITHER OF THEM AVAILABLE.
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO HERE IF YOUR LINE IS NOT
OPEN AS A CO HOST OF ME TRYING
TO FIND THEM IN OUR- SPEAKER
LIST ONE SECOND PLEASE. WHAT
WAS THE GENTLEMAN'S NAME. MISS
ROACH UP FOR MR HOFFMAN. WELL
LET'S LET'S TURN TO OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION AND IF WE FIND THEM
WE'LL COME BACK SO IF YOU DO
NOT SEE THEM AS A CO HOST AT
THIS TIME ALL RIGHT AWAY SO IF
YOU'RE AN OPPOSITION IN YOUR IN
THE GALLERY YOU WISH TESTIFY
PLEASE APPROACH THE MICROPHONE
I SEE NO ONE MOVING- ROOM ONE
TWELVE I SEE NO ONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE LET'S TURN THE
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE LINE
AND ONCE AGAIN IF WE- LOCATE.
MISS ROACH- OR MR HOFFMAN WE
WILL COME BACK TO THEM. ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE IN OPPOSITION
TO A. TWO EIGHT SIX. HI MR
JERVIS OF DAWN HOFF AND I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU CAN HEAR ME- WE CAN
GO AHEAD AND- GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU THANK YOU AND APOLOGIES FOR
SOME TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES-
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN SENATORS
DON HOFFMAN ON BEHALF OF
INTERNET ASSOCIATION- AND WE
ARE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE DAY
EIGHTY TWO EIGHTY SIX- JUST
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT OPPOSED TO.
TRANSPARENCY FOR CONSUMERS OF
ALL RESTAURANTS- PROPOSED SOME
AMENDMENTS THAT- IN LINE WITH
THE BUILDING TEMPLATE CODIFY
CONSUMER DISCLOSURES- I
ITEMIZED PRICE BREAKDOWNS- NOT
ONLY FOR EACH ITEM BUT EACH
EACH MISSION ACROSS CHARGE TO
THE CONSUMER. AS WELL AS A
SIMILAR. I URGE DISCLOSURE FOR
RIGHT- BUT WE JUST SPOKE THAT A
THIRD PARTY DELIVERY COMPANY
SHOULD HAVE TO DISCLOSE
CONFIDENTIAL TERMS OF A PRIVATE
BUSINESS TO BUSINESS CONTRACTS
WHICH WE BELIEVE IS THE SPELL
WITH THEIR- ALL THE P. THE
FACILITY PAYS TO PAY FOR
DELIVERY. HARMAR CALLING TERRY-
AND ALSO CONFIDENTIAL AS PART
OF THE CONTRACT IN FRONT- WHEN
TREATED ISSUES TO PARTNER WITH
A DOG POPCORN DAY PAGE HE'S NOT
JUST FOR DELIVERY OR PICKUP
SERVICE BUT FOR A WIDE RANGE OF
OPTIONAL SERVICES AT ALL- SUCH
AS ADVERTISING AND MARKETING-
AND WE THINK. THIS GOES INTO
SPECIFIC COMMISSION WILL
USUALLY CUSTOMERS BECAUSE OF-
COMMISSIONS PAID OR ARE NOT FOR
THE DELIVERY HELLO-
ADDITIONALLY YOU KNOW THIS THIS
MARKET IS HIGHLY COMPETITIVE ON
THE TRAIN FOR DELIVERY-
COMPANIES. AND ALSO BETWEEN
THIRD FACILITIES- YOU KNOW SOME.
OFFERED DELIVERY USING OUR OWN
STAFF POSITIONS TO PARTNER WITH
COMPANIES LIKE OURS- AND THAT'S
WHAT YOU CHOOSE TO PARTNER WITH
A DELIVERY PLATFORM HAVE A WIDE
VARIETY TO CHOOSE FROM AND EACH
PLATFORM OFFERS. A VARIETY OF
PRODUCTS THAT ARE. MADE TO MEET
THEIR NEEDS- EXCEPT FOR THE
TRINITARIANS RETENTION- THESE
CONTRACTS SHOULD REMAIN
PRIVATE- I CAN'T IMAGINE THAT
WE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS- I WOULD
BE HAPPY TO. DISCUSS WAYS TO
PROVIDE GREATER TRANSPARENCY
FOR EACH BUT THIS CROSSOVER
REQUIREMENT. DOES GIVE US SOME
CONCERN. FINALLY THIRD PARTY
DELIVERY COMPANIES ALREADY
PROVIDE A 100% OF CHIPS TO
DRIVERS- AND WE- VOLUNTARILY
REPRESENTATIVES CATCHER AS PART
OF PROP TWENTY TWO- THIS
REQUIREMENT CAN BE FOUND IN THE
END HE CUT SECTION- SELLING FOR
FIFTY THREE C. AND SO FOR THAT
REASON- YOU KNOW WE THINK THE
PROVISION. IN THE BILL
REQUIRING THAT IS NOT NECESSARY
TO COLLECTIVES- AND SHOULD BE
STRICKEN BUT- NOT FOR THE
REASONS WE ARE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED. TO
EIGHTY TWO EIGHTY SIX AND THREE
TIMES. THANK YOU- MISS ROGER.
MR IS TRYING TO CALL IN- BUT-
MAY HAVE BEEN CUT BY THEM THE-
OPERATOR AT THE TIME. ALL RIGHT
LET'S TAKE OTHERS WHO ARE
OPPOSED TO MORE COMPACT MISS
ROACH. OKAY THE GERMAN IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY TWO EIGHTY
SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. I WILL BEGIN WITH WINE
ONE HUNDRED SIXTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD ONCE. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS JUSTIN HIRE PEOPLE
CONDOLEEZZA SHIP GROUP AND WE
MUST RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE
BILL THANK YOU. NINE ONE FORTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE DOESN'T WANT TO BE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION AB TWO EIGHT SIX.
THANK YOU. BY ONE TWENTY EIGHT
AT. GIVEN THE NATURE OF THE
HABITAT RESPECTED AS A TEACHER
AIDE. THANK YOU BILL BY ONE
SIXTY ONE YOU ARE OKAY. GOOD
AFTERNOON INTERNET GROUP
RESEARCHING HOP ON THE HOP
VERTICAL CIRCULATION CALIFORNIA
RESPECTIVELY AFTER A POLITICO
THANK. GIVE FINAL REMINDER TO
SHOW OPPOSITION FOR A. B.
TWENTY SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO WE'LL GO TO
LINE ONE SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS HANNAH
SMITH ON BEHALF OF GRUBHUB AND
WE ASK YOU TO RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE. THANK YOU. THERE IS NO
ONE ELSE SECURE AT THIS TIME.
ALL RIGHTY THANK YOU AND WE
HAVEN'T LOCATED MISS ROACH UP.
IF YOU ARE ON. PLEASE PLEASE GO
AHEAD AND ON YOUR PHONE. LET ME
CHECK REAL QUICK FOR YOU TO SEE
IF I SEE THEM. YEAH I'VE I'VE
I'M SORRY I DO NOT SEE A ROACH-
ON THE CALL RIGHT ALL RIGHT
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
CHAMBER QUESTIONS IN THE
CHAMBER. SO THE COUPLE EURO.
THANK YOU MR CHAIR- I WONDER IF
THE AUTHOR COULD. ADDRESS THE
ISSUE THAT WAS RAISED BY THE
OPPOSITION REGARDS TO THE
BUSINESS TO BUSINESS CONTRACTS.
THANK YOU SEVEN ORGANS ALICE.
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS TO
ENSURE THAT THE CUSTOMERS ARE
AWARE OF THE FEES CHARGED TO
RESTAURANTS- THROUGHOUT THE
PANDEMIC IMPACT WE SAW A LOT OF.
COMMERCIALS SUGGESTING HOW
THESE THIRD PARTY DELIVERY APPS
FOR KEEPING THESE RESTAURANTS
UPLOAD AND ALTHOUGH TECHNICALLY
THAT MIGHT BE TRUE A LOT OF
CONSUMERS DON'T UNDERSTAND THE
TRUE COST OF THAT A LOCAL
RESTAURANT- MUST BEAR IN ORDER
TO HAVE THE FOOD DELIVERED. WE
THINK AS ESPECIALLY COMING OUT
OF THE PANDEMIC FOR CONSUMERS
TO MAKE EDUCATED AND WISE
DECISIONS TO SUPPORT LOCAL
RESTAURANTS HAVING THAT
INFORMATION WILL HELP THEM MAKE
A DECISION ON IF THEY ARE
SUPPORTING. A RESTAURANT BY
HAVING DELIVERY OR PERHAPS JUST
GOING THEMSELVES TO PICK IT UP.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT
ANSWER I GUESS I THOUGHT THE
BILL I DON'T KNOW IF I WANT TO
SAY THAT I SUPPORT THE BILL I'M
GONNA VOTE FOR TODAY. BUT I- I.
I THOUGHT THE BILL WAS A
TRANSPARENCY BILL. IN REGARDS
TO THE CONSUMER AND HOW MUCH OF
CONSUMERS PAYING AND WHETHER
IT'S REALLY BENEFITING IN THE
RESTAURANT. IF A RESTAURANT
DECIDES THAT THEY WANT TO GO
WITH THAT PARTICULAR SERVICE.
AND IT'S MORE EXPENSIVE THAN
THE OTHERS BUT THE DELIVERY IS
BETTER. AND THE FOOD ACTUALLY
GETS THERE FASTER WHICH IS.
MEAN THAT'S ONE OF THE ONE OF
THE BENEFITS FOR ME IS THAT IF
THE FOOD GETS THERE AND IT'S
BEEN ON ITS WAY FOR HALF AN
HOUR IT'S JUST NOT AS GOOD AS
IF IT'S IF IT. ARRIVES RIGHT
AWAY- IF. I GUESS I THOUGHT
THAT THE ISSUE. WITH THE
PURPOSE OF THE BILL WAS A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT WHICH IS
WHY I ASKED THE QUESTION.
BECAUSE IT T SEEMS TO ME IF
YOU HAVEA BUSINESS TO BUSINESS
CONTRACT- RELATIONSHIP. IT'S
MUCH MORE. EQUAL THAN A
CONSUMER THAT HAS TO TAKE THAT
PARTICULAR. SERVICE AND THAT'S
ALL THERE IS TO IT. AND AND IT
MAY BE MUCH MORE EXPENSIVE THAN
THEY THOUGHT IT WAS GOING TO
BE. HI I AM I AM. I APPRECIATE
WHERE YOU'RE GOING WITH THIS
AND- I GUESS I JUST FEEL LIKE-
I. THE BUSINESS TO BUSINESS HAS
LESS OF A RELATIONSHIP TO THE-
CUSTOMER AND THEN. WHAT I WILL
PAY AS A CUSTOMER. IN ANY CASE
I'M GONNA SUPPORT IT
FINANCIALLY MEMBER CONSULTS YOU
COULD RESPOND RESPOND CLOSELY
AND TRANSPARENCY COULD BE FOR A
LOT OF REASONS RIGHT SO WE WANT
THE RESTAURANTS TO HAVE
TRANSPARENCY- THERE IT THIS
ISN'T VERY COMPETITIVE MARKET
BACK THERE I THINK. THREE
COMPANIES HAVE 95% MARKET
SHARE. AND SO- WE WANT
RESTAURANTS ESPECIALLY IN
REALLY WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
HERE IS SMALL MOM AND POP
RESTAURANTS HAVE NOW ENTERED
CONTRACTS INTO THESE DELIVERY
SERVICES. FOR THE PURE SURVIVAL
AND NOW WITH VERY MUCH LIKE
THEIR CUSTOMERS TO RETURN- AND
IN ORDER TO DO SO I THINK WE
NEED SOME- ACCURATE ACCOUNTING
OF. OF THE SITUATION THEY'RE IN.
SORRY THANK YOU THANK YOU-
CENTER BORDERS. THE RESEARCHER.
I'VE SUPPORTED- I THINK ONE OF
YOUR BILLS WAS LAST YEAR MAYBE
ONE YEAR BEFORE ON-
TRANSPARENCY EFFORTS WHEN IT
COMES TO FOOD DELIVERY SERVICE.
THIS BILL HOWEVER I THINK IT'S
DIFFERENT THAN SOME OF THE
MATERIAL THAT YOU'VE WORKED ON
IN THE PAST. ONE BECAUSE I
THINK. HOW MUCH MONEY THESE TWO
PRIVATE PARTIES ARE CONTRACTING
FOR SENSHI BECOMES PRIVILEGED
OR PROPRIETARY. AND TO FORCE
THE DISCLOSURE OF THIS TYPE OF
INFORMATION. IT'S NOT THAT I
WOULD BE SURPRISED IF IT'S
TRULY IN THE INTEREST OF THE
CONSUMER BUT MORE TOWARDS THE
NOTION THAT. YOU WANT TO-
DEMONSTRATE THE INFLATIONARY
ADJUSTMENTS OF FOOD DELIVERY
SERVICE- AND DISCOURAGE THOSE
FOLKS. FROM CONTINUING TO USE
THAT OUR FOOD DELIVERY SERVICE
IN OPT INSTEAD FOR EMPLOYEES
WHO MIGHT DELIVER IT FOR THEM
SO- FURTHER ON BEHALF OF THE
RESTAURANT OR ENCOURAGE FOLKS
COME BACK IN. SO EVEN THOUGH
I'VE SUPPORTED YOUR EFFORTS IN
THE PAST THIS ONE I JUST I
CAN'T BUY INTO. ONLY BECAUSE IF
WE WERE TO. MAKE AN EXAMPLE.
YOU KNOW DO I HAVE A RIGHT TO
ASK A RESTAURANT. YOU KNOW HOW
MUCH IT IT PURCHASES ITS
SUPPLIES FROM A PARTICULAR
DISTRIBUTOR. AND THEY TELL ME
TO POUND SAND. I'D BE LIKE NO
BUT THAT'S THE TYPE OF
TRANSPARENCY THAT I WANT
BECAUSE I WANT TO KNOW IF I
SHOULD KEEP IN FREQUENT YOUR
ESTABLISHMENT. THERE'S CERTAIN
BUSINESS TO BUSINESS
CONFIDENTIALITY THAT MUST
EXIST. IF YOU EXPOSE EVERYTHING
TO THE LIGHT OF DAY. THEN I
THINK THE OLD THE ULTIMATE
OBJECTIVE IS MAKING CERTAIN
THAT THE COMPETITORS KNOW
WHAT'S AT PLAY. CARDS ACTUALLY
DRIVE DOWN- THE COMPETITIVE
MARKET PLACE IN ULTIMATELY
EXPOSE THE PRINCIPLES. ARE IN
DRIVE THEM AWAY FROM USING FOOD
DELIVERY SERVICE SO IF. IF
WE'RE INTERESTED IN THE IN
PROMOTING PRIVATE ENTERPRISE
AND- IN FREE ENTERPRISE- THIS I
THINK IS JUST A BRIDGE TOO FAR
RESPECTFULLY- AND A UNITED- MAY
HAVE PHILOSOPHICAL DIFFERENCES
EVEN THOUGH WE'VE HAD A LOT OF
COMMON GROUND IN THE PAST. THIS
IS JUST ONE OF THOSE THINGS
HERE. GOVERNMENT SHOULD NOT
HAVE A ROLE IN FORCING THE
DISCLOSURE OF INFORMATION.
BETWEEN TWO PRIVATE CONTRACTING
PARTIES ESPECIALLY WHEN IT'S
VOLUNTARY. IF THE SMALL MOM AND
POP BELIEVES YOU'RE PAYING TOO
MUCH. TO FOOD DELIVERY SERVICE
FOR WHAT IS ACTUALLY WHAT WHAT
PRODUCT IS BEING DELIVERED.
THEY HAVE EVERY REASON TO STOP
DOING. AND FOR GOVERNMENT TO
STEP IN AND IN THESE VERY
INTIMATE LEVELS OF ENTERPRISE I
THINK IT'S JUST TOO FAR. THANK
YOU SEVERAL BOARD JUST ASSUME
MEMBER GONZALEZ DO YOU CARE TO
RESPOND NOW OR IN YOUR CLOSING
OR THE MICROPHONES RAISED I'D
BE HAPPY TO RESPOND NOW I DO
WANT TO POINT OUT THAT THE MY
PREVIOUS MANAGER ACTUALLY ALSO
POSED BY THESE COMPANIES WAS TO
REQUIRE THAT THERE BE A
CONTRACT BETWEEN THE RESTAURANT
AND THE FOOD DELIVERY COMPANY.
IN ORDER FOR THE FOOD DELIVERY
COMPANY TO AT. TO PROVIDE THE
SERVICE- THE STATE DOES HAVE A
REASONABLE INTEREST IN
INFORMING CONSUMERS AND BEEN
BUSINESS SAYS OF THE NATURE OF
THE RELATIONSHIP PARTICULARLY
IN THE- ORIGINS AND
DESTINATIONS THEIR MONEY IN THE
SCOPE OF A BUSINESS
TRANSACTION. I'D EVEN ARGUE
FURTHER NUMBER ONE THIS IS IN
PLACE IN CERTAIN CITIES ARE
READY. SO IT'S NOT. THE FIRST
UP WE ACTUALLY TOOK IT FROM
OTHER- LANGUAGE AND IN. METRO
AREAS- BUT I'D ALSO ARGUE THIS.
THIS IS A UNIQUE SITUATION
RIGHT WE HAVE COMPANIES QUITE
FRANKLY. THAT SOLD THE PUBLIC-
ON THEIR GENERAL BENEFIT TO THE
PUBLIC- WHICH MAY OR MAY NOT
HAVE BEEN TRUE. THEY ARE
COMPANIES THAT BECAUSE THEIR
BUSINESS TRANSACTIONS- AND
BECAUSE THE WAY THEY CONDUCT
BUSINESS WE AS TAXPAYERS ARE
ACTUALLY SUBSIDIZING- THEIR
WORKFORCE. SO I THINK IT'S
IMPERATIVE FOR- GENERAL
EDUCATION OF CONSUMERS TO
UNDERSTAND THE EXACT NATURE. OF
HOW MUCH MONEY IS BEING- TAKEN
IN BY THESE COMPANIES. BLESSED
HOW MUCH IS ACTUALLY BEING PAID
TO THE DRIVERS QUITE FRANKLY ON
THAT'S A DIFFERENT DISCUSSION.
BUT BUT- TO KNOW THAT- DELIVER
IS NOT FREE RIGHT I MEAN THIS
NOTION THAT THAT SOMEHOW. SOME
COMPANY IS PAIN HEY'RE NOT
PAIN BY THE WAY- YOU KNOW
MINIMUM WAGE OR OR THE EVEN
REQUIREMENTS THAT THEY- THEY
PROVIDED POP TWENTY TWO I THINK
FULL DISCLOSURE SOMETHING THAT-
WE AS CONSUMERS DESERVE
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE AS CONSUMERS
ARE ALSO WE AS VOTERS. ANDHAVE
BEEN- ADVERTISED AS SUCH A YOU
KNOW WE WERE ADVERTISED WITH A
GOOD PRODUCT AS WELL AS HOW HOW
GOOD THEY ARE FOR RESTAURANTS
HOW GOOD THEY ARE FOR THEIR
DRIVERS AND I THINK. HAVING
DISCLOSURE ON BUSINESS
TRANSACTIONS WHERE OUR MONEY IS
GOING IT IS A FAIR. A NEXT STEP.
BUT AGAIN AS YOU SAID WE CAN
AGREE TO DISAGREE. ALL RIGHTY
THANK YOU. IS THAT COMPLETE
YOUR COMMENTS ON OUR BORDERS.
WHAT THE HELL FOLLOW UP BY
MAINLY BECAUSE I DIDN'T THINK
THAT WAS A THAT WAS A CLOSING
THERE THERE ARE SOME MERITS I
BELIEVE TO WHAT TO WHAT- THE
AUTHOR- PUT PUT FORWARD.
PLASTERERS COUPLE WEEKS AGO I-
LOVE THIS THIS FANTASTIC INDIAN
PLACE IN- IN FRESNO. IN DURING
COATED. WE WOULD USE THE
DELIVERY SERVICES. WELL THE
PRICES I WAS IN THE POSITION
NOW TO FIGURE OUT THE REAL
DISTINCTION. AND I WAS
DISINCLINED TO ACTUALLY GO FOR
THE FOOD DELIVERY SERVICE
BECAUSE IT WAS THAT MUCH MORE
EXPENSIVE. BUT THAT'S MY CHOICE.
AS A AS AS AS AS A CONSUMER BUT
I DON'T HAVE A RIGHT BY. BY
VIRTUE OF LEGISLATION. TO PRY
INTO THE DISTINCTIONS OF THE
TWO PARTIES I CAN MAKE A
DECISION. THAT IT'S TOO
EXPENSIVE OR I PREFER TO DO
TAKEOUT BUT TO FORCE THESE
INDIVIDUALS TO DISCLOSE
PROPRIETARY INFORMATION ON
THEIR RELATIONSHIP. IS WELL
BEYOND THE REALM OF THE STATE
AND EVEN THOUGH THERE MAY BE
OTHER JURISDICTIONS THAT HAVE
SIMILAR- PROGRAMS IN PLACE I
THINK YOU'RE GOING TO FIND THAT
BY AND LARGE IT'S CITIES OR OR
METRO COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE
STRONG LABOR INTERESTS WHICH IS
REALLY WHAT THIS IS ABOUT IT'S
NOT ONSUMER TRANSPARENCY I
THINK THIS IS A STRONG-
MOVEMENT IN THE DIRECTION. OF
ORGANIZED- LABOR AND STANDARDS
AND EXPECTATIONS OF THE WORK
FORCE BUT I RESPECT THE WORK
EVEN THE FOUNTAIN AND NOT EVEN
SUPPORTED THAT THAT BILL PRYOR
SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
EXPLANATION WELL I JUST WANNA
BE CLEAR DESPITE MY STRONG
INTEREST TOWARDS LABOR ON THIS
BILL IN THE IDEAS OF THIS WHOLE
APPROACH ME IMPACT BY SMALL
RESTAURANT OWNERS AND IN MY
DISTRICT AND SO FORTH TALKED
ABOUT PROPRIETARY INFORMATION
THE TRUTH IS THIS AND THIS WE
KNOW FROM FROM ANOTHER
BACKGROUND IS MCDONALD'S PAYS
FAR LESS- IN DELIVERY FEES THAN
YOUR LOCAL MOM AND POP DOES-
YOU KNOW THERESTAURANT ITSELF
THE PURCHASE. PRICE FOR THE
RESTAURANT BECAUSE OF THE OF
THE SCALE OF IT AND I THINK
CONSUMERS WOULD WANT TO KNOW
THAT I WOULD WANT TO
DISTINGUISH BE ABLE TO BE
EDUCATED CONSUMERS IF YOU ASK
RESTAURANT OFTEN TELL YOU HOW
MUCH THEIR PAIN AND- QUITE
FRANKLY IT'S DISCOURAGING THANK
YOU SENT. A SIMILAR MEMBER
GONZALEZ SENATOR STERN. THANK
YOU MR CHAIR I JUST I JUST WANT.
A QUICK COMMENT AND THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME- D. THE
AUTHORS NOT JUST THE
PRESENTATION THE BILL BUT THE
COLLEGE WE HAD HERE THING WAS.
ILLUMINATING AND I AND I JUST.
THIS THIS NOTION THAT SOMEHOW-
FEED DISCLOSURE SERVICE FEE
DISCLOSURE WOULD BE SEEN AS
ANTI COMPETITIVE OR SOMEHOW
UNDERCUTTING- YOU KNOW BUSINESS
PROPRIETARY INFORMATION TO ME
IT IT THERE'S SO MANY OTHER
SECTORS WHERE WE REQUIRE.
SERVICE FEES AND COMMISSION
DISCLOSURES THIS IS NOT I DON'T
THINK WE'RE BREAKING SOME
DRAMATIC NEW GROUND HERE IN
FACT AND IT AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT GROUND BREAK BUT I
DON'T THINK IT'S NEW GROUND-
AND SO YOU KNOW I THINK ABOUT.
OTHER MAJOR TRANSACTIONS WE
MAKE BUYING CARS FOR- YOU KNOW
GOING THROUGH- VARIES IN THE
RETAIL TRANSACTIONS THAT OCCUR-
SO I THINK I DON'T SEE THIS AS
PARTICULARLY REVOLUTIONARY
CONTROVERSIAL BUT JUST A MATTER
OF SIMPLE TRANSPARENCY AND
CONSUMER JUSTICE AND- HI YOU
KNOW I JUST THIS WHOLE
LANDSCAPE AND GROWING UP
WORKING IN LOCAL RESTAURANTS
AND SEEING WHAT A STRUGGLE IT
IS TO SURVIVE AND SEEING HOW
MANY PEOPLE THAT I KNOW. WHO
ARE UPSIDE DOWN RIGHT NOW AT
LEAST WE CAN DO IS JUST TRY TO
GIVE THEM EQUAL FOOTING WITH
THE WITH THE GOLIATHS OUT THERE
TO SURVIVE IN CALIFORNIA SO AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME I'D LOVE
TO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR TO
AND- WOULD MOVE THE BILL. ALL
RIGHT MISTER SINISTER AND IT IS
THE APPROPRIATE TIME CENTER
STERN MOVES THE BILL- OTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS. CONSUMER
GOODS ALL SECURE CLOSE RESPECT
LAST NIGHT ABOUT RT THANK YOU
MANAGE ACCOUNTS OF THE CULTURAL
THE STATE B. TWO EIGHTY SIX BY
SOME MEMBER GONZALEZ. WITH THE
MOTION BY SENATOR STERN. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
RE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
BUSINESS PROFESSIONS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT UMBERG HI.
AMBER I BURGESS. NO BORDERS NO
COVERAGE AT ALL HI. I DID
AWESOME. GONZALEZ TERRY HI
HERTZBERG JONES. JONES OF JONES
NO LAYERED BY LAYERED BY STERN
STERN STERN HI WHITE HOUSE SKI
HIGH WEIGHT CASKEY HI WINNER HI
WINNER I SO FAR YOU HAVE SIXTY
TWO ALL RIGHT WE'LL PUT THE
BILL ON CALL NEXT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEAD ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN.
ONE ZERO SIX ONE SEVEN MEMBER
LEE THANK YOU FOR WAITING
CLOSURES THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
SENATORS AB TEN SIXTY ONE OR
PROTECT MOBILE HOME RESIDENTS
FROM UNFAIR WATER CHARGES I AM
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AND I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
ON THIS. THESE AMENDMENTS
CLARIFIED THAT MOBILE HOME
PARKS CAN RECOVER COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE PARK WATER
SYSTEM THROUGH OTHER MEANS
EIGHTY TEN SIXTY ONE ONE SHOULD
A MOBILEHOME PARK OWNERS ARE
NOT PROFITEERING OFF OF
PROVIDING THE RESIDENTS WITH
THE BASIC NECESSITY OF WATER.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS AND WITH ME I'M A WUSS IS
A ROBERT JOHNSON FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ACTION TEAM AND A
CHAIR VISIBLE AND I ALSO BRUCE
STANTON- WHO WILL BE AVAILABLE
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS IF
NECESSARY. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEE- MR STAND OR.
MR JOHNSON ARE YOU AVAILABLE ON
THE PHONE. YES ROGER JOHNSON
HERE ALL RIGHT THANK YOU MISS
JOHNSON GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON HEARING CENTERS MY
NAME IS ROGER JOHNSON. I'M A
SENIOR IN THE VETERANS LIVING
IN A MOBILE HOME ON A FIXED
INCOME. I'M THE LEGISLATIVE
LEADER FOR GSM WHILE. THE
GOLDEN STATE MANUFACTURED
HOMEOWNERS LEAGUE. AND WE ARE A
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION THAT HAS
BEEN REPRESENTING PEOPLE OF
MODEST MEANS WHO LIVE IN MOBILE
HOMES FOR OVER FIFTY YEARS. SHE
HAS A MORAL SUPPORT. MAY BE
TURNED SIXTY ONE. AS MOBILE
HOME RESIDENTS WHICH SHOULD
ABSOLUTELY PAY FOR THE WATER
THAT WE CONSUME. WE SHOULD PAY
OUR PRO RATA SHARE OF THE
SERVICE CHARGES THAT WATER
COMPANIES BILL TWO PARK OWNERS.
WHAT ISN'T FAIR IS WHEN WATER
IS SUB METERED AND THEN THE
PARK OWNERS MARK UP THE PRICE
OF WATER AND MAKE AN UNFAIR
PROFIT. TODAY MANY PARK OWNERS
ARE MULTIPLYING SERVICE CHARGES
TO EACH SPACE THROUGHOUT THE
PARK AND IN SOME CASES THEY'RE
MAKING UP THEIR OWN CHARGES.
SOME PARKS OR MAKING UP TO A
QUARTER OF A MILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR ON JUST WATER SERVICE
CHARGES. THE LEGISLATURE
ALREADY VOTED TO PROTECT
CONSUMERS OF WATER AND OTHER
SUB METERED CIRCUMSTANCES FROM
THESE SAME EXISTS EXCESSIVE
CHARGES HE BEAT TEN SIXTY ONE.
EXTENDS SIMILAR CONSUMER
PROTECTION TO RESIDENTS LIVING
IN MOBILEHOMES. WE ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT WE ASK FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MR JOHNSON MR STAND
AVAILABLE. ES THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR BRUCE STANTON ON BEHALF
OF GSM WELL ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
THIS PARTICULAR ECHO VICTOR DOT
COM YOUR AVAILABLE CREDIT
QUESTIONS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN ANYONE IN THE
GALLERY WISH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT YOUR NAME YOUR
FILIATION YOUR POSITION SITTING
ON THE GALLERY. ANYONE IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE NO ONE ROOM ONE
TWELVE LET'S TURN TO THE PHONE
LINES BUT- IF YOU COULD HELP
THOSE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT OF.
EIGHTY ONE ZERO SIX ONE. FOR
COMMENTS AND THE PORT OF AB ONE
ZERO SIX ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. BACK COMMAND
AGAIN. ONE ZERO. AND THE LINE
ONE SIXTY EIGHT YOU'RE MY KID
UP AND. BY. ONE SIXTY EIGHT. I
APOLOGIZE WE CAME TO A LOT ONE
ONE SIXTY EIGHT. BLAINE ONE
HUNDRED BY ONE HUNDRED FOURTEEN
YOU'RE MAKING UP. MY NAME IS
MARTHA O'CONNELL AND I LIVE IN
SAN JOSE WHERE WE HAVE FIFTY
NINE MOBILE HOME PARKS AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT A. B. TEN
SIXTY ONE. THANK YOU. A LINE OF.
ONE HUNDRED SEVEN. MY NAME IS
LYNN HELLO I'M A MOBILE HOME
RESIDENT IN THE CITY OF LONG
BEACH SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THOUSANDS OF MOBILE HOME
RESIDENTS THROUGHOUT OUR CITY
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT AT. TEN
SIXTY ONE WE URGE YOU TO VOTE I.
BLIND. ONE HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE.
HI MY NAME IS BOBBY MAGNUSON I
LIVE IN PARK ROYAL I'M ALSO THE
HLA PRESIDENTS AT OUR PARK
STRONGLY SUPPORT T TEN SIXTY
ONE THANK YOU. BLIND AT. ONE
HUNDRED SEVENTY TWO. THANKS FOR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE THIS IS
LAWRENCE MAC COULD DO- I
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB. M. SIXTY
ONE. BLIND OF ONE HUNDRED
THIRTEEN. LUCINDA LEMAN I LIVE
IN CONCORD CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT A B. TEN ONE
ZERO SIX ONE AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WHY NO. ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY THREE. MY NAME IS
CHRISTINE FLUTES ARE SKI I LIVE
IN FREMONT I STRONGLY SUPPORT
A. B. TEN SIXTY ONE. BLIND OF
ONE HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR. DUTY
PARABOLIC FOUNDER OF THE
SUNNYVALE MOBILE HOME PARK
ALLIANCE LOCATED IN THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA WE HAVE THE
THREE LARGEST PARKS IN
CALIFORNIA AND WE SUPPORT S. P.
EIGHT SIXTY ONE. I'M SORRY TEN
SIXTY ONE. A LINE OF. ONE
HUNDRED SEVENTY NINE. DON'T
MIND. ERIC CHURCH I LIVE IN THE
CITY OF HUNTINGTON BEACH WE
HAVE TWO THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY ONE MOBILE HOMES
AND I SUPPORT ALONG WITH MY
FRIENDS B. B. CAN. YOU. ONE
WELL I KNOW ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY
SIX. ANDERSON CALLING FROM
SANTA BARBARA CALIFORNIA I LIVE
IN A MOBILE HOME PARK WITH
THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY THREE
OTHER RESIDENTS STRONG THE
COURT OF EIGHTY TWO AND SIXTY
ONE. THANK YOU. AND MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT AT THE TIME ALL RIGHT
BUT LET'S NOT TURN TO. THE
OPPOSITION HI I HAVE A MISTER
JASON I CARED AND MR CHRIS
WYSOCKI- I SEE. SIR GO AHEAD.
MEMBERS AND CHASE AND I AGREE
WITH THAT- STEAM GILBERT ROZON
SMITH ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MOBILE HOME PARK
OWNERS ALLIANCE REGRETTABLY
ESSIE NPA REMAINS IN OPPOSITION
TO AB TEN SIXTY ONE AND I SAY
REGRETTABLY BECAUSE WE AGREE
WITH THE BASIC NOTION THAT A
RESIDENT IN A MOBILE HOME PARK
SHOULDN'T HAVE TO PAY MORE FOR
WATER SERVICE THAN THEY WOULD
IF THEY WERE SERVED DIRECTLY BY
WATER UTILITY. THE ISSUE WITH
AB TEN SIXTY ONE IS THAT IT
PROHIBITS A PART OWNER FROM
RECOVERING A FIXED COST OF
SERVICES AT THE SAME RATE
THAT'S BEEN SET BY A UTILITY
AND PARKS DEFINITELY HAVE FIXED
COST MEMBERS IN A PARK UNLIKE
AN APARTMENT YOU HAVE A WHOLE
WATER SYSTEM THAT STRETCHES
BEHIND YOUR MASTER METER TO
DELIVER WATER ACROSS THE PARK
THERE MEANS. BEAR UNDER A ROSE
IN THE PARK EXCAVATING THEM FOR
OPERATIONS MAINTENANCE AND
REPAIR IT'S POSSIBLY. AND THE
WAY THAT THE PARK IS ALLOWED TO
RECOVER THESE COSTS TODAY IS TO
LOOK TO THE LOCAL UTILITY. SEE
HOW THEY HAVE SENT THEIR
CHARGES FOR COVERING THEIR
FIXED COSTS. AND USE THAT AND
KNOW MORE AS A BENCHMARK FOR
WHAT THE PARK IS ALLOWED TO
RECOVER. AND SO AGAIN. THOSE
ARE THOSE ARE CHARGES THAT
WOULD BE PAID BY A RESIDENT IF
THEY WERE SERVED DIRECTLY BY
UTILITY THEY'RE PAID BY ALL OF
YOUR OTHER CONSTITUENTS WHO ARE
LIVING IN SINGLE FAMILY HOMES.
AND THEY ARE NOT SET BY THE
PARK ITSELF WE DON'T HAVE
CONTROL OVER IT UNDER THE LAW
SO WE BELIEVE THAT'S THE RIGHT
WAY TO GO. BUT THIS BILL
PROHIBITS IT WOULDN'T KNOW
WHETHER A MECHANISM IN PLACE
FOR RECOVERY OF COST. AND YOU.
IF YOU ARE IN A RENT CONTROLLED
JURISDICTION YOU ARE AT THE
MERCY OF A LOCAL RENT CONTROL
BOARD WITH NO EXPERTISE IN
WATER SERVICE. WHEN YOU GO TO
THEM AND ASK THEM TO ALLOW YOU
TO RECOVER THIS. THAT'S
ESPECIALLY PROBLEMATIC FOR
PARKS THE TWENTY YEARS AGO.
MADE A CHOICE TO REDUCE THEIR
RENT. TO REFLECT THE FACT THAT
THEY WOULD BE BILLING
SEPARATELY FOR UTILITY SERVICE.
LASTLY MEMBERS THERE IS A
CONSERVATION ISSUE IN THIS
BILL. WE METER AND SUB METER
WATER SERVICE IN CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE IT ENCOURAGES PEOPLE TO
USE LESS WATER. IF PARTS ARE
NOT ALLOWED FULL COST RECOVERY.
NO OTHER MOBILE HOME PARK GOING
FORWARD IF THIS BILL PASSES.
WILL I CHOOSE TO SUB METERED
WATER SERVICE AND SO FOR ALL
THESE REASONS. WE REMAIN IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THERE
ARE WAYS TO FIX IT WE DISCUSSED
IT WITH YOUR STAFF. AND ALL OF
YOUR STAFF AND WE CONTINUE TO
BE WILLNG TO- AND LESS
ADDRESSED- WE MUST REMAIN
FOCUSED AND REQUEST YOU KNOW
PLEASE. THANK YOU MR. OCCURRED
MR WYSOCKI. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS- MY NAME'S
CHRIS WYSOCKI NUMBER PRESENTING
THE WESTERN MANUFACTURED
HOUSING COMMUNITIES ASSOCIATION.
RESPECTFULLY WE MUST RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL EVEN
THOUGH THE BILLS GOT SOME
POTENTIAL AMENDMENTS WE REMAIN
OPPOSED FOR THE FOLLOWING
REASONS. FIRST WIN AB TEN SIXTY
ONE WAS INITIALLY DRAFTED IT
SOUGHT TO CODIFY A P. U. C.
DECISION THAT NOBODY COULD
PROFIT FROM WATER. WE ASKED FOR
ONE SIMPLE CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS. AND THAT WAS TO
ALLOW THOSE DELIVERING WATER TO
GET REIMBURSED FOR THAT SERVICE
NO MORE NO LESS. THAT
SUGGESTION WAS NOT ACCEPTED THE
MOBILE HOME PARK OWNERS HAVE
BEEN SENT ME DURING WATER AND
PARKS FOR DECADES DOING THE
RIGHT THING TRYING TO HELP
CONSERVE WATER AND HELP RAISE
THAT RESIDENTS SAVE MONEY. BY
AMENDING LANGUAGE INTO THIS
BILL FROM S. B. SEVEN. THAT WAS
PASSED IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
THIS BILL SEEKS TO TREAT MOBILE
HOME PARKS LIKE APARTMENT
BUILDINGS. MOBILE HOME PARKS
ARE TOTALLY DIFFERENT FROM
APARTMENTS AND THEIR WATER
SYSTEMS ARE MUCH MORE EXPENSIVE
TO MAINTAIN. FURTHER SB SEVEN
WAS PROSPECTING AND IT WAS
INTENDED TO ENCOURAGE APARTMENT
BUILDINGS TO INSTALL SEVEN
YEARS THIS BILL APPLIES
RETROACTIVELY TO ALL PARKS
APPLYING ONE ROTARY ACROSS THE
BOARD FOR THE ENTIRE STATE.
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL WE
BELIEVE FURTHER INTERFERES WITH
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES HAVE
CPUC APPROVED WATER DELIVERY
RATES. THIS BILL SHOULD AT
LEAST BE AMENDED TO GRANDFATHER
IN APPROVED WATER PROVIDER
RATES. ADDITIONALLY WE QUESTION
WHY LOCAL RENT CONTROL BOARDS
WILL BE IN CHARGE OF
DETERMINING WATER CHARGES WHEN
DECIDING ON RENT INCREASES AS
MISTER REICHARDT POINTED OUT.
IF WATER CHARGES ARE
INCORPORATED IN IRAN. HOW DOES
THAT INCREASE THE TRANSPARENCY
THAT CURRENTLY EXISTS FOR
RESIDENTS. IF THIS BILL
CURRENTLY PASSES IT WILL
DISCOURAGE FUTURE SUB METERING
OF MOBILE HOME PARKS A POLICY
THAT SEEMS TO RUN COUNTER TO
OUR STATEWIDE GOALS. TO CARVE
WATER WHENEVER POSSIBLE THANK
YOU FOR THOSE I KNOW THE
REASONS WE REMAIN OPPOSED THANK
YOU SIR THANK YOU SIR- ALL
RIGHT OTHERS IN OPPOSITION THE
GALLERY SEEING NO ONE ROOM ONE
TWELVE SAYING NO ONE LET'S TURN
TO THE PHONE LINE MR MODERATOR
CAN. QUEUE UP THOSE OPPOSED. TO
AB ONE ZERO SIX ONE. FOUR
COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION TO AB
ONE ZERO SIX ONE. PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. COMMAND AGAIN. ONE
ZERO. IN A LINE ONE HUNDRED
EIGHTY YOU'RE MY KID UP. MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS- MY NAME
IS MAURICE PRIEST. AND AS YOU
KNOW I'VE BEEN A HOMEOWNER-
ADVOCATE AND ADVOCATE FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR OVER
FORTY YEARS- I AM TESTIFYING
TODAY ON BEHALF OF OUR NON
PROFIT ASSOCIATION AFFORDABLE
COMMUNITIES INC. WE DO OWN AND
MANAGE TEN MOBILE HOME
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA FOR
THE BENEFIT OF LOW INCOME
SENIORS AND FAMILIES- I MUST
OPPOSE. AB TEN SIXTY ONE AND
I'D LIKE TO GIVE YOU A COUPLE
OF EXAMPLES WE OF MR PLACE MR
PRE SEVERAL. OUR MISTER PRIEST
YES I WE APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR
YOUR POINT OF VIEW BUT THERE
THERE'S ALREADY BEEN TWO
WITNESSES WHO TESTIFIED IN
FAVOR- SO. I UNDERSTAND YOUR
POSITION I THINK YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT. ON BEHALF OF BUT I
KNOW WE'RE WE'RE IN WE'RE ON
SIGNAGE AND MISTER CHAIRMAN
OKAY ALL RIGHT. B. WARY OF ID
NOT APOLOGIZE ADDITION TO THE
BILL I APOLOGIZE OKAY THANK YOU
SIR. ALL RIGHT. OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION. LINE AT. ONE
HUNDRED SEVENTY THREE. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MICHAEL
CIRILLO I AM WITH THE STAR
MANAGEMENT COMPANY WE OPERATE A
NUMBER OF MOBILE HOME PARKS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND WE
ARE IN OPPOSITION TO AB TEN
SIXTY ONE. THANK YOU. A LINE OF.
ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY TWO. YES
THIS IS LAWRENCE MACKEY DO WITH
BUSH CARMACK THE WAY ON FIVE
PARK IN ORANGE COUNTY AND I'M
IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO AB TEN
SIXTY ONE. THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT.
BRING IT BACK TO THE CHAMBER
QUESTIONS- CYNICAL EUROS
QUESTION. THANK YOU MR CHAIR- I
WAS WONDERING IF THE- IF THE
AUTHOR COULD RESPOND TO THE
ISSUES THAT WERE RAISED BY THE
OPPOSITION IN PARTICULAR THAT
KIND OF FIXED COSTS THAT HAVE
BEEN PUT IN THAT. WOULD BE
PROHIBITED FROM BEING RECOUPED
AS PART OF THIS BILL. YES
SOMEONE WILL GO AHEAD THANK YOU
SIR FOR THE QUESTION I MEAN
DEFER TO BRUCE STAND. THE LEGAL
COUNSEL WHICH IS OFTEN A
QUESTION. YEAH I'D BE HAPPY TO
TRY TO RESPOND IT IS THE ISSUE
HERE IS REALLY JUST A LACK OF
REGULATION. AS LONG AS THE PARK
OWNER CHARGES THE SAME
VOLUMETRIC RATE AS IT PAYS AS
THE WATER PURVEYOR AUTHORIZES
THE CPUC HAS NO JURISDICTION
AND THAT THERE IS NO
REGULATION. REGARDING THIS
RECURRING FIXED CHARGE ISSUES
SUCH AS THE CUSTOMER CHARGES
THAT ARE BEING REPLICATED
THROUGHOUT THE PARKS. AND SO
THE RESIDENTS REALLY HAVE NO
REMEDY IF THOSE CHARGES ARE
INCORRECT OR IF THEY'RE JUST
RAISING CONTINUE TO BE
REPLICATED. SO THE PROBLEM HERE
IS IN THE FAR CORNER HERE
SAYING WELL WE NEED THIS COST
TO MAINTAIN THE INFRASTRUCTURE.
BUT IN FACT WHAT HAPPENS IS
MANY PARK OWNERS WILL CHARGE
THE RESIDENT TO INSTALL THE
METERS WHEN WATER IS FOR
SENATOR. THEN THE REPLICATING
THE CUSTOMER CHARGE THAT
THEY'RE NOT ACCOUNTING FOR IT
THERE'S NO REGULATION THAT SAYS
YOU HAVE TO BANK BACK CUSTOMER
CHARGE OR OTHERWISE. THAT COUNT
FOR HER BUT SHE'S ACCUMULATED.
AND THEN WHEN THERE IS A REPAIR
OR MAINTENANCE ISSUE WITH THE
SYSTEM THE PARKING IS FREE. TO
PASS THAT THROUGH TO RESIDENTS
AS A CAPITAL IMPROVEMENT AND
THAT TYPICALLY HAPPENS BASED
UPON. WHAT LEASES AUTHORIZE
VERY COMMONLY OR- IN LOCAL RENT
CONTROL JURISDICTIONS THERE ARE
MANY TIMES SEPARATE CAPITAL
IMPROVEMENT PASS THROUGH
PROVISIONS THAT ALLOW. ANY KIND
OF CAPITAL EXPENDITURE TO BE
REIMBURSED SO REALLY HAD
NOTHING TO DO WITH RANCH- IT'S
ALL ABOUT A CAPITAL EXPENDITURE
CHARGE. PROBABLY FOR YOU AT THE
PARK UNDER GETS TO REPLICATE
THIS CUSTOMER CHARGE EVERY
STATE AND I'M NOT ACCOUNTABLE
AT. THE PARK AND JEFF
COLLECTING NOT ONLY THIS
CUSTOMER CHARGE BUT ALSO CAN GO
COLLECT. THE CAPITAL COST TO
REPAIR OR MAINTAIN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE. I THINK THE
CUSTOMER CHARGES CERTAINLY
INTENDED FROM THE SERVING
UTILITY OR WATER PURVEYORS
POINT IF YOU COULD BE A BETTER
STRANGERS COSTS- AND THAT'S
WHAT THIS BILL. AS WE YOU KNOW
TOOK THE PROVISIONS OF THE
FORMER SP SEVEN IS ALLOWED TO
PARK ON. YOUR RECUPERATED
MINISTRATION COSTS BUT NOT TO
REPLICATE THE CUSTOMER. CHARGE
WERE- NON RECURRING FIXED
CHARGES WERE ACTUALLY A
RECURRING FIXED CHARGES. THAT
THE WATER PURVEYOR CHARGES AND
I ANSWERED THE QUESTION. HEY
YOU PROBABLY HAVE I CAN'T SAY
THAT I FOLLOWED IT TOTALLY ME
JUST SAY THAT. TO THE EXTENT I
REALLY APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO IN THIS BILL. THIS
IS THE SECOND HOUSE IF THERE'S
GONNA BE ANY CHANGES TO THE
BILL THIS IS THE TIME TO DO IT
AND THAT THE THING THAT I FEEL
UNCOMFORTABLE ABOUT IS THAT
WHAT WE WANT IS SEPARATE
METERING. ON ALL RESIDENCES AND
THAT INCLUDES MOBILE HOME PARK
OWNERS SO THAT PEOPLE KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE USING. AND WHEN WE ASK
PEOPLE TO REDUCE. THEIR
CONSUMPTION TO CONSERVE THEY
HAVE A WAY TO BE ABLE T
DETERMINE WHETHER THEY'RE DOING
A GOOD JOB OR NOT IT'S A AS AN
EXAMPLE. HERE IN SACRAMENTO THE
RESIDENTS THAT I'VE BEEN LIVING
IN USED TO BE A FLAT FEET
BASICALLY FIFTY BUCKS. A MONTH
FOR THE WATER AND THERE USED TO
BE WATER RUNNING DOWN THE CURB
IN FRONT OF MY RESIDENCE. EVERY
SINGLE DAY FROM SOMEONE ELSE.
UP THE STREET WHO WAS PROBABLY
ALSO PAYING FIFTY BUCKS WHEN IT
FINALLY GOT METERED MY BILL
WENT DOWN TO BETWEEN TWENTY
FIVE DOLLARS TO THIRTY FIVE
DOLLARS A MONTH. SO I'M
ASSUMING THAT THERE IS WIND UP.
SIGNIFICANTLY BECAUSE THEY WERE
WASTING WATER WE WANT PEOPLE TO
KNOW WHEN THEY'RE WASTING WATER
AND TO CONSERVE. AND SO IN IN
THIS SCENARIO I AGREE WITH THE
OPPONENTS AND I THINK IT'S
GOING TO DISCOURAGE. B.
EXPENDITURE OF INFRASTRUCTURE
MONEY TO SEPARATELY METER
EVERYTHING WHICH IS STATE LINE
WHICH WE WANT THEM TO DO. AND
IF YOU'RE GOING TO BE SETTING
UP. AN A. STRUCTURE- IT SEEMS
ONLY FAIR TO ALLOW THOSE- PARK
OWNERS THAT HAVE BEEN
PROGRESSIVE AND GONE OUT AND
DONE THE WORK. TO BE ABLE TO
RECOUP. THAT INVESTMENT THAT
THEY MADE IN THE PARK. AND AND
CHARGER FEE WHICH THEY THEN CAN
PUT IN A SEPARATE ACCOUNT. AND
END USE IT ONLY. TO MAKE
UPGRADES IN TO FIX THE SYSTEM-
CAPITAL COSTS TO THE SYSTEM AND
AN ACCOUNT FOR IT TO THE
BENEFIT OF THE TENANT SO I GET
TO THE EXTENT THAT. THAT YOU'RE
CHANGING THE SYSTEM AND THEN
YOU'RE CREATING THIS NEW
SYSTEM. TO ME IT JUST SEEMS
LIKE IT IT MAKES SENSE TO BE
ABLE TO ALLOW THEM TO. TO
RECOUP SOME OF THE COST IN IN
IN THIS INFRASTRUCTURE AND TO
DO IT IN A WAY THAT PROVIDES
NOTICE TO THE TENANTS AND AT
THE ABILITY FOR THEM TO BE ABLE
TO FOLLOW HOW MUCH MONEY IS IN
THIS ACCOUNT. AND FRANKLY THAT
IF THE MONEY GETS TO BE
SIGNIFICANT ENOUGH THAT THAT
THAT CHARGE NO LONGER NEEDS TO
BE INCLUDED AS PART OF THAT OF
THE WATER WATER FREE SO. I WILL
NOT BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY BUT- I JUST THINK THAT
IT'S THAT THERE'S A FAIRNESS
ISSUE HERE AND- WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE INCENTIVIZING
PEOPLE TO DO THE RIGHT THING
WHICH IS TO PUT IN THE SEPARATE
METERS. THANKS THANK YOU
SENATOR CAFIERO. A SORT OF LIKE
ASKING. RESEARCHER I'M ON PAGE
SEVEN OF THE STAFF ALICE'S AND
I THOUGHT. THE AMENDMENT THAT
THE AUTHORS TAKING. INDICATES
THAT NOTHING IN THIS SECTION
SHALL BE CONSTRUED TO PREVENT
MANAGEMENT. FROM RECOVERING ITS
COSTS INSTALL MAINTAIN OR
IMPROVE. INTERNAL WATER
DELIVERY SYSTEM AS MAY
OTHERWISE BE ALLOWED IN ANY
RENTAL AGREEMENT OR LOCAL
REGULATION. SO WOULDN'T THE
RUB. B. IS IF THE RENTAL
AGREEMENT WAS SILENT ON OR
SOME LOCAL. CONTRIBUTE RENT
CONTROL SAID OR OR LOCAL
ORDINANCE SAID AND MOBILE HOME
PARKS YOU CAN ONLY CHARGE. FIVE
DOLLARS FOR CAPITAL
IMPROVEMENTS SOMETHING LIKE
THAT THAT WOULD LIMIT VERSES
WHICH WHAT THE- PARK OWNERS
GOTTA PAY THE BANK TO FINANCE
WHATEVER IT WAS THEY COULD
IMPROVE MY WRONG AND THEN. LET
ME ASK THE AUTHOR TO RESPOND.
I'M GOING TO DEFER IT TO MY
SPONSOR YES I. IN SHORT I DON'T
THINK YOU'RE WRONG CENTER WE
KNOW SKI BUT- IF MR STAND WHICH
IS A RESPONSE. YEAH I WOULD
AGREE MISTER CHAIR- CENTER
WORKOUTS SKI IS NOT WRONG- MANY
LONG TERM LEASES AS WE HAVE
CALLED THEM THREE YEARS HAVE
VERY SPECIFIC CAPITAL
IMPROVEMENT OUR CAPITAL
REPLACEMENT CAPITAL EXPENSE
PROVISIONS IN THOSE DOCUMENTS.
AND ANY RENT CONTROL ANY LOCAL
RENT STABILIZATION ORDINANCE
SHOULD BE CONSTITUTIONAL MUST
ALLOW FOR DUE PROCESS. TO OCCUR
HEARING PROCESS FOR ANYONE
INCREASED AGAIN MANY OF THEM
VERY SPECIFICALLY HAVE SEPARATE
CAPITAL EXPENDITURE PASS
THROUGH PROCEEDINGS THAT ARE
DOWN. ON SPECIFIC.
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEEDINGS THAT
DON'T REQUIRE THE PARKED OPEN
ALL THE BOOKS IT'S JUST
REQUIRED TO PROVE THAT A-
ENCOURAGED THAT CAPITAL EXPENSE
SO THAT'S WHY WE HAD THAT
LANGUAGE ADDED TO MAKE IT VERY
CLEAR THAT THOSE RAPID USE THAT
PARK OWNERS HAVE ALREADY BEEN
USING. ARE STILL STILL IN PLAY.
SAID IT'S YOUR QUESTIONS IN
WHAT ELSE HE DOES ALL RIGHT SIR
JONES YOUR MICROPHONE UP. IT
WAS THAT I HAD A SECOND
QUESTION. THAT YOU KNOW WHAT
YOUR MICROPHONE IS NOT ON. AS
THE WE COULD TURN ON CENTER
JONES'S MICROPHONE. TRUST ME
IT'S NOT INTENTIONAL SYNERGIZE.
WE NOW KNOW. WHAT CAN I DO TO
MAKE THIS THERE WE GO ALL RIGHT
AT THE SAME EXACT QUESTION SEMI
CASCADING GRILLE ON THE SAME
PAGE ALL RIGHT THANK YOU OTHERS
OTHERS OF QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CONCERNS SEEING NONE ALL RIGHT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE. LET'S SEE
IF THERE'S A MOTION. IS THERE A
MOTION. SENATOR STERN MOST OF
BILL ALL RIGHT SEVEN NUMBER
LEADING CARE CLOSE YES I
APPRECIATE ALL THE REPLIES
CONVERSATION SEND THE SENATORS
AND I DO ALSO WANT TO THANK THE
GREAT STAFF ANALYSIS WHEN I
LOOK AT PAGE SIX SEVEN NINE ON
THE SECOND AND THIRD PARAGRAPH
THERE DOES A REALLY GREAT
OUTLINING THAT. YOU KNOW OF A
PARK MOBILE POLL MOBILE HOME
PARK OWNERS CAN RECOVER COSTS
THE WRITER CAPITAL EXPENSE
HAMSTERS OR EVEN IN
JURISDICTIONS WITH RENT CONTROL
CAN ALSO RECOVER THAT IT'S THE
INTENTION OF THIS BILL NOT TO.
MAKE IT SO THAT NO ONE CAN
RECUPERATE THE COST OF
DELIVERING WATER BUT TO MAKE
SURE THAT NO ONE IS REALLY
PROFITEERING OFF THE WATER SO
I'M VERY HAPPY TO BE WORKING
WITH THE COMMITTEE AND THANK
YOU FOR CLARIFYING MOMENTS AND
I THINK YOU FOR- FOR THAT YOU
JUST CONVERSATION AND ASK FOR
EITHER. THANK YOU SO REMEMBER
BENCHES COUNCIL CULTURAL PLEASE
THIS IS EIGHTY TEN SIXTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEAVE WITH A
MOTION BY SENATOR STERN THE
MOTION IS DO YOU PASS AS
AMENDED- BURKE. HI AM BERG BY
BURGESS. PORGES SNOW. PROBABLY
IT'LL- MARIA NOT VOTING DID
ASAL. GONZALEZ HERTZBERG JONES.
JONES HI HI JONES I LAYEREDI
LAYERED HI STERN FIVE STERN I
WACO SKI HIGH WHITE HOUSE HE HI
WEINER WINNER I. YEP SIX TO ONE
SO FAR ALL RIGHT WE'LL PUT THAT
ON CALL THANK YOU. SIMPLY
MEMBER LEVIN. I DON'T SEE A
SEVEN MEMBER LEVINE I DO SEE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOGO SO WHAT
WILL GIVE SOME MEMBER LEVIN A
GOOD TEN SECONDS. ALL RIGHT SO
MEMBER LOW- LET'S NOT SEE THE
ITEM NUMBER. FOURTEEN EIGHTY
ONE ONE NINE FOUR. SEVEN MEMBER
LAW. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN COLLEAGUES HAVE FIRST
LIKE TO START BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE- AMENDMENTS AND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR WORK ON
THIS THIS IS WITH RESPECT TO
PERFORMING CONSERVATIVES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA- IN THE
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS. CODE
WE WORK HARD TO HELP INSURE
THAT WE HAVE THE TRANSPARENCY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE AND THANK THIS
COMMITTEE FOR AN ADULT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER ALL RIGHT.
LET'S GO TO SUPPORT- I HAVE
MISTER RICK BLACK IN SUPPORT
ARE YOU ON THE LINE MISTER
BLACK. MR BLACK WE WE'VE TAKEN
THIS BILL A BIT OUT OF ORDER SO
WE'LL GIVE A COUPLE. SECONDS
HERE- MODERATOR OF WE ARE NOW
ON ITEM NUMBER. FOURTEEN EIGHTY
ONE ONE NINE FOUR. AND WE HAVE
MR ELECTRIC CHAIR WE DO NOT
SHOW THAT RICK BLACK HAD
CONNECTED ALL RIGHT WELL LET'S
GIVE IT A SECOND AND IF THEE'S
ANYONE ELSE WHO'S ON THE LINE
IN SUPPORT WILL TAKE THEIR
SUPPORT POSITION. LET'S SEE ANY
MEDICARE IN THE GALLERY NOT.
AND SUPPORT. OF EIGHTY ONE ONE
NINE FOUR. PLEASE PRESS ONE
BUTTON ZERO. I COMMAND AGAIN
ONE ZERO ALL RIGHT LET'S LET'S
ASK ONCE AGAIN THE GALLERY
ANYONE IN SUPPORT THE GALLERY.
AB ONE ONE NINE FORCING NONE
ROOM ONE TWELVE SEEING NONE- MR
MODERATOR I DON'T KNOW IF MR
BLACK HAS BEEN FOUND BUT IF WE
COULD QUEUE UP THOSE IN SUPPORT
WILL TAKE THEM AND WHEN MR
BLACK. CHIMES IN WILL TAKE HIS-
TESTIMONY. WE STILL DO NOT
SHOWN AT THE BLACK TAP
CONNECTED A LINE OF ONE FIFTY
ONE YOUR MIKE AT THE- THANK YOU
FOR LISTENING R. AND GAIL
POWERS AND I WAS A- PROTECTIVE
SERVICES SUPERVISOR FOR TWENTY
FIVE YEARS IN THE COUNTY OF.
SAN DIEGO. AND I TAGGED HERE
PROGRAM WHICH STANDS FOR COULD
DO HERE YOU'D BE SPECIAL
CLEANING OUT FINANCIAL BE
SEXUAL THREE. AND ALL RIGHT TO
PROVIDE AND- BUILD WORLD
DIRECTLY WITH ELDERLY AND
DISABLED. AND THEY CONVINCED.
THANK GOD THAT CAME FROM ALL OF
THEM. IN THE- ALWAYS WANTED TO
FAIR THEY NEVER UNDERSTOOD THE
COURT PROCEDURES. DATE FELT
THAT THEY WERE MISLED THE ONE
THAT WAS QUITE COMPETENT. AND
WE OFTEN DISCUSS THE FACT THAT
GOVERNORSHIP WELL I'VE ALREADY
HAD BECOME A BILLION DOLLAR
INDUSTRY AND I THOUGHT OVER THE
YEARS THAT I'VE BEEN AROUND I
ALSO WAS VERY FAMILIAR WITH THE
INVESTIGATION THAT THE LA POND
DID JACQUELINE WAS ONE OF THE
REPORTERS I CAN NOW PLAY
BECAUSE I'M REQUIRED. ALL RIGHT
BOTH JACK LEONARD ALL RECORD IN
SUPPORT OF. SOME KIND OF BETTER
REGULATION AND OVERSIGHT WITH
THE PROBATE COURT WE FIGURED WE
WERE GOING TO BE IF WE DID NOT
AND AS WE KNOW THE THREE HAD
REPEATED ITSELF. ANY OVERSIGHT
THAT YOU CAN DO TO ENSURE. THAT
THE RIGHT OF THE CONSERVATIVES.
HE AND GUARDIANS. ALL PROTECTED
AND THAT INCLUDE WHAT OR NOT
THE BIG BIG VERY OR THE LAW
ATTORNEY. ALL THE- THEY GET IF
THEY VERY OR VERY SIMPLE DOG
SAID THAT THEN I CAN TELL YOU
FIRSTHAND THAT DID NOT WORK BE.
PEOPLE THAT ARE HAVING THE
RIGHT REMOVED FROM THEM. AND IN
ALL MY YEARS OF EXPERIENCE IT
ISN'T THE RIGHT WAY TO GO AT
ALL SO I AM DEFINITELY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND I
WOULD HOPE THAT THEY'LL BE EVEN
ADDITIONAL BUILD THAT WALL
HELLO. AND IT SHOWED THAT THE
PROBATE CODE THE COURTS AND THE
JUDGES AND THE ELDER LAW
ACCORDING ALL TAKE FULL
RESPONSIBILITY AS WELL AS
ANYBODY THAT'S THE POINT THANK.
YOU FOR LETTING ME THINK ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU MA'AM- YOU ONE
FURTHER WET WITNESS SOME
REMEMBER LOW- MISTER BLACK IS
MISTER BLACK THERE. SOUNDS LIKE
MR BLACK IS NOT ON THE LINE
LET'S SEE IF THERE'S OTHERS.
ANYONE ELSE ON THE CHAIR THERE
ARE. YES SIR THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THE TIME NO
FURTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
ALL RIGHT. LET'S TURN TO
OPPOSITION. I DO NOT SEE ANYONE
LISTED IN PRIMARY OPPOSITION.
TO THE BILL- IF THERE'S ANYONE
THE GALLERY IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE MOVE THE MICROPHONE
SEEING NO MOVEMENT. IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE ALSO NO ONE MOVING THE
MICROPHONE ALL RIGHT. LET'S NOW
TURN TO THE PHONE LINE MODERATE
IF YOU WOULD QUEUE UP THOSE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB. ONE ONE NINE
FOUR. FOUR COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION TO AP ONE ONE NINE
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. THAT COMMAND AGAIN. ONE
ZERO. AND THE LINE ONE HUNDRED
THIRTY YEAR MIKE IS OPEN. HELLO
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF MY NAME'S
JERRY DOES MAN AND ALBERTA
PROFESSIONAL FIDUCIARY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
CALLING IN TO NOTE THAT OUR
INDUSTRY IS WORKING TOGETHER
WITH A FAMILY MEMBER LOW ON IT
HE BEAT UP IN NINETY FOUR AS IT
MOVES FORWARD TO ADDRESS ISSUES
THAT WE'VE IDENTIFIED. THAT
WOULD LIKE TO JUST POINT OUT
THAT WE SHARE WITH THE AUTHOR
OR POET THE CONCEPT THAT THE
BEST INTEREST OF THE
CONSERVATIVES ARE PARAMOUNT.
AND THE ISSUES THAT WE'VE
IDENTIFIED THAT WE'RE WORKING
THROUGH INVOLVE ISSUES SUCH AS
ENSURING THAT THOSE DUE PROCESS
WHEN APPROPRIATE DECISIONS ARE
MADE AND ALSO ENSURING THAT THE
APPROPRIATE ROLE IN DISCRETION
OF THE COURT PROBATE COURTS IN
THESE MATTERS ARE ACKNOWLEDGED
AND DROPPED IT IN THE END AND
THE BEST WAY TO PROTECT THE
CONSERVATIVES. HAVE
DISAPPOINTED TO KNOW THAT IF WE
CONTINUE TO WORK ON- OUR ISSUES
WITH THE AUTHOR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND THE OTHER MISTER
CHAIR WE WIN WE NOW HAVE RECORD
BLACK ON THE LINE ALL RIGHT MR
BLACK GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN NUMBER SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF
TREMBLING AND LOW IN YOUR
STAFFERS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. OF SB ELEVEN
NINETY FOUR. MY NAME'S RYCHLAK
TERM THE DIRECTOR OF SPHERE IN
THE CENTER FOR STATE
ADMINISTRATION REFORM WERE FIVE
OH ONE SEE THREE AN ADVOCATE
FOR SENIORS AND INTELLECTUALLY
IMPAIRED ADULTS. TARGETED BY
THE PREDATORY LEGAL COMMUNITY.
IN POWER OF ATTORNEY TRUST THE
DOLL DARK CONSERVATORSHIP CROSS
WE'VE COUNSELED OUR RESEARCH
NEARLY FOUR THOUSAND
CONSERVATORSHIP CASES
NATIONWIDE. SINCE TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN. SPELLING TRANSPARENCY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY IN THE ADULT
CONSERVATORSHIP JUDY CATION
PROCESS. WE THANK THE HASHTAG
FREE BRITNEY MOVEMENT AND ITS
LEADERS- SOCIAL MEDIA SKILLS
AND COMMON SENSE THAT BECAUSE
HE CAPTURED LEADERSHIP'S
ATTENTION WHERE MANY PREVIOUSLY
FAILED. THERE ARE AMPLIFIER
CONTINUES TO CRY OUT HOW CAN A
SUCCESSFUL AND DEVOTED MOTHER
BE CONSCRIPTED INTO A THIRTEEN
YEAR UNNECESSARY AND EXPENSIVE
CONSERVATORSHIP. THE
CONSERVATORSHIP SYSTEM IS
BROKEN NATIONWIDE IT TOO OFTEN
FEEDS THE LIONS AT THE EXPENSE
OF THE LADY ON. BUT MANY JUDGES
BELIEVE THEIR JOB IS TO
ENTERTAIN FELLOW MEMBERS OF THE
BAR. INSTEAD OF PROTECTING THE
VULNERABLE THEIR LOVED ONES THE
FIRST STATE DOCUMENTS THERE
WERE STATES AND THE STATE AND
FEDERAL LAWS THAT PROTECT
VULNERABLE ADULTS. WHETHER A
VIBRANT CELEBRITY THE DEMENTIA
IMPAIRED OCTOGENARIAN OR THE
EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD CEREBRAL
PALSY VICTIM LOVINGLY CARED FOR
BY A PARENT. THIS SYSTEM MUST
ENSURE THEIR PROTECTION. AND
THE RIGHTS ARTICULATION AND
REWARDING PREDATORY ATTORNEYS
SHOULD NEVER BE TOLERATED IN
THIS PROCESS. MUCH LESS
REWARDED. SIMPLY BEEN LOWS
COMMITMENT TO MULTI
GENERATIONAL PLAN GIVES US HOPE
THAT THE IMPROVEMENTS THIS BILL
BRINGS ALONG WITH FUTURE
MANDATES WILL REDUCE
VICTIMIZATION IN CALIFORNIA.
PETER FOLEY ADORE THIS AB ONE.
AND REQUESTED THIS COMMITTEE'S
BEEN DOOR SHUT AS WELL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT THIS
MODERATOR ANYONE ELSE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO- A. B. ONE ONE
NINE FOUR. BETTER CARE WE HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENT FOR EITHER
SIDE. ALL RIGHT BRING IT BACK
TO THE CHAMBER OF QUESTIONS.
SEEING NO MICROPHONES RAISED IS
THERE A MOTION SENT EARLIER
MOVES THE BILL ALL RIGHT- SOME
REMEMBER LOW DO YOU CARE TO
CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
ALL RIGHT EXCELLENT CLOSE ALL
RIGHT. LET'S LET'S CALL THE
ROLL. AND TO CANCEL S. ADD THIS
IS AB ELEVEN NINETY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AT LOW THE
MOTION IS BUYING. SENATOR
CLAIRE. BY SENATOR LAYERED
THANK YOU AND THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND
AND RE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AMBERG HI AMBERG
HIGH BOARD YES. ZERO HI HOW ARE
YOU KNOW I DID ALSO. OCCURRED
TO ADDRESS SO. BUT SILAS
HERTZBERG. JONES JONES I
LAYERED HI LEHRER DIE STERNE
JOURNALISTS ZERO NINE WHITE
HOUSE SKI HIGH CASKEY I WINNER
FIVE WINNER I MEAN TO GO BACK
THROUGH BORJAS. REGIS I THE
RUSSELL GONZALEZ HERTZBERG. YOU
HAVE EIGHT ZERO SO FAR ALL
RIGHT WE'LL PUT THAT BILL ON
CALL I THINK IT'S A MEMBER LOW
ON ME NOW LET'S SEE WE SIMILAR
VEIN I'M EXCUSE ME SO AMERICA
LEVIN IS NOT HERE BUT I SEE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK SILVA IN
THE BACK SO- FOR THOSE OF YOU
WHO ARE WATCHING OR LISTENING
WE'RE GOING NOW TURN TO. A. B.
NINE SEVEN EIGHT PHYLUM NUMBER
FIFTEEN. AB NINE SEVEN EIGHT
PHYLUM NUMBER FIFTEEN. AND
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK SILVA
FLOOR'S YOURS. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS IT'S A
PLEASURE TO PRESENT TODAY ON
THIS RED FLOOR AND- AS THE
SENATE JUDICIARY CHAIR FOR MORE
DISCOUNTING MR AMBER- TODAY I
AM PRESENTING AB NINE SEVENTY
EIGHT I ENTERED THIS THIS BILL
IN AN EFFORT TO BUILD UPON THE
IMPORTANT POLICY DISCUSSIONS
THAT TOOK PLACE IN TWENTY
NINETEEN RELATED TO RENT
STABILIZATION BY EXTENDING THEM
TO MOBILE HOME PARK. RESIDENTS
JUST AS RESIDENT JUST HAVE AS
RENTS HAVE DRAMATICALLY
INCREASED STATE WIDE MOBILE
HOME RESIDENTS ARE ALSO FACING
DRASTIC RENT INCREASES FROM
PARK OWNERS. HOWEVER MOBILE
HOME RESIDENTS THAT ARE
EXPERIENCING RENT INCREASES
INCREASES FIND THEMSELVES IN A
VERY DIFFERENT SITUATIONS.
MOBILE HOME OWNERS JUST LIKE
TRADITIONAL HOME OWNERS PAY
MORTGAGE ON THE HOME. BUT MOST
MUST ALSO PAY FOR REPAIRS AND
MAINTENANCE AS WELL AS HOME
TAXES HOWEVER UNLIKE
TRADITIONAL HOMEOWNERS THEY
MUST ALSO BUDGET FOR RENT. AS
WE KNOW MOBILE HOMES ARE NOT
MOBILE EIGHTY NINE SEVENTY
EIGHT WAS NARROWED
SIGNIFICANTLY TO ADDRESS
OPPOSITION AND DISCUSSION
WITHIN THIS COMMITTEE. THERE IS
A MOBILE HOME PARK IN MY
DISTRICT RANCHO LOVE THE PLUS
WHERE THE RESIDENTS OF THE PARK
ARE SPLIT BETWEEN THE TWO
CITIES OF FULLERTON AND
ANAHEIM. THIS BILL ONLY FOCUSES
ON RANCHO LOOK BECAUSE- THESE
RESIDENTS ARE MY CONSTITUENTS
AND FIND THEMSELVES IN A VERY
DIFFICULT SITUATION SINCE A NEW
POLL PARK OWNER TOOK OVER IN
TWENTY NINETEEN. RESIDENTS OF
THIS PARK HAVE BEEN HIT WITH
BACK TO BACK DOUBLE DIGIT. I'M
GONNA REPEAT THAT DOUBLE DIGIT
RENT INCREASES AND EVEN THOUGH
THEY HAVE TRIED TO GET THIS
ISSUE RESOLVED AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL THE LOCAL CITY COUNCILS
TO DATE THEY HAVE NOT RECEIVED
ANY REPRIEVE. WELL I WOULD HAVE
PREFERRED TO RUN A STATEWIDE
BILL TO HELP ALL MOBILE HOME
PARK RESIDENTS I CANNOT SIMPLY
STAND ASIDE AND NOT CONTINUE TO
FOCUS ON THESE RESIDENTS WHO
ARE SUFFERING. IN MY DISTRICT
AT THE RANCHO PALOS PARK. MANY
OF THESE HOME RESIDENTS ARE
SENIORS VETERANS AND AS WE KNOW
ARE ON A- BIT LIVE ON A FIXED
INCOME. AS WE CONTINUE TO DEAL
WITH THE COVERT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC IN OUR AND NOW ADDRESS
OUR STATE'S HOUSING AND
HOMELESS CRISIS WE NEED TO DO
MORE TO KEEP PEOPLE IN THEIR
HOME. COLLEAGUES WE KNOW THAT
THE FASTEST WAY FOR PEOPLE TO
STAY ON OUR STREETS IS BY
LOSING THE RESIDENTS THEY LIVE
IN. AND BY KEEPING IN THE IN
THEIR HOMES IS THE BEST WAY TO.
DO WHAT WE CAN TO END THE
HOMELESS CRISIS WITH ME TODAY
BY PHONE TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY
IN SUPPORT R. A RESIDENT FROM
RANTULA PAUSE MISS LUPE
ROMERO'S COMMUNITY ADVOCATE AND
HOMEOWNER AT RANCHO APPLAUSE.
ALSO MISTER BRIAN A GUSTO THE
DIRECTOR OF RURAL HOUSING
PROJECT BUT THE CALIFORNIA
RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER- JUST TO BE
CLEAR YOU ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS
THAT ARE PROPOSED AND COMMON
FIVE ON PAGE SIX AND SEVEN YES
ALL RIGHT- BEFORE WE TURN TO
THE WITNESSES LET ME JUST APART
FROM WHAT WE HAD ANNOUNCED AS
OUR PRIOR PROCEDURE. ON THIS
BILL- BECAUSE OF BASICALLY
GLITCH IN SCHEDULING- WE'RE
GOING TO PERMIT- FIVE MINUTES
ON EACH SIDE TWO MINUTES FOR
THE FIRST TWO WITNESSES AND ONE
MINUTE FOR THE THIRD WITNESS
SO- MISS RAMIREZ MR GUSTA IF
EITHER OF YOU ON THE PHONE IF
YOU COULD MAKE YOUR PRESENCE
KNOWN. MODERATORS AND MR GUSTER
AND I'M HERE. THIS MEASURE
AMERICANS ARE APPROACHING GO
FIRST ALL RIGHT MR MIRRORS ARE
YOU AVAILABLE. YES I AM I NEED
AN ARTICLE. MR MIRRORS THE
FLOOR'S YOURS. EIGHT HUNDRED AT
THE MATRICULA HAS THE
TEMPERAMENT WOMAN CLICKS OF IT
THAT I AM A RESIDENT OF RANCHO
PALOS. WE OR IN A DIFFERENT-SITUATION THAN MOST OTHER
MOBILE HOME PARKS BECAUSE WE
ACTUALLY HAVE TWO CITIES IN OUR
PARK WE HAVE TWO DIFFERENT
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT WE HAVE TWO
DIFFERENT UTILITY PROVIDERS WE
HAVE TWO DIFFERENT CITY COUNCIL
WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH AND
PROBABLY AND THAT IS WHY WE'VE
NOT BEEN ABLE TO GET ANYTHING
DONE WE WERE BOUGHT BY A
PREDATORY BUYER AND HIS
REQUIREMENT WHEN HE BOUGHT THE
SPARKLY BABY HAD TO BE MAKING A
PROFIT IN TWO YEARS. PUBLIC%
CALIFORNIA PAC WAS BUYING NEW
PROPERTY THAT WAS ALMOST
IMPOSSIBLE AND THE ONLY WAY
THAT THAT COULD BE DONE WITH
THE GALS THE CURRENT DENTURES
HERE OF COURSE MOST OF US ARE
ON FIXED INCOMES MOST OF THE
CONTENT CAN FIGURE AT THE TABLE
AND WE HAVE QUITE A FEW
VETERANS IN HERE WE'VE HAD
PEOPLE HERE THAT ARE. SO
TERRIFIED ABOUT LOSING THEIR
HOMES. D. FOR READ. AND SOLD A
BARK BECAUSE THE WERE SO THEY
WERE TO LOSE HOMES. WE'VE HAD
TO P. ATTEMPT. ONE MOMENT HE
WALKED UP THE RAILROAD RACKS
THAT'S RIGHT NEXT DOOR TO
LESSEN THE CHANCE TO GET HIT BY
A TRAIN BECAUSE SHE WOULD HAVE
HAD NO PLACE ELSE. TO GO IF SHE
LOST HER HOME. WE HAVE NOT BEEN
ABLE TO GET ANY KIND OF RENT
CONTROL MEASURE BECAUSE WE'RE
BETWEEN TWO CITIES AND WE'RE
BETWEEN TWO DIFFERENT
JURISDICTIONS ON SEVERAL THINGS
THAT WE JUST KIND OF LIKE
FALLING THROUGH THE CRACKS. AS
WE WATCH. WE DO EVERYTHING WE
CAN WE TRY TO PUT A RALLY
TOGETHER WE'VE GONE TO THE NEWS
MEDIA. AND EVERYBODY SAID ALL
KNOW THIS IS REALLY TERRIBLE.
BUT NOT TOO MUCH IS HAPPENING.
DURING CODE WE HAVE FIFTEEN
DEATH IN HERE AND I KNOW THEY
WERE ALL STRESS RELATED
BECAUSE- THE ONLY THING YEARS
ARE VERY VULNERABLE AFFECT THE
HEALTH OF OUR SENIORS THAT. ARE
VERY IS VERY VULNERABLE. AND
PEOPLE HERE ARE JUST TERRIFIED.
I THANK YOU YOUR YOU'RE STILL
MORTGAGE AND BEACH THE MORTGAGE
IN THE BASEMENT THEY CAN'T STAY
IN THEIR HOMES. THE ONLY LOSE
THEIR HOMES WE KNOW OF AT LEAST
THREE PEOPLE IN HERE THAT HAVE
BECOME HOMELESS. THERE'S NOT A
BIG WHAT SENIOR HOUSING
ANYPLACE. AND AREN'T BEING USED
IF WE END UP ALMOST THE GONNA
NEED WHEELCHAIRS AND OXYGEN
MACHINES AND POSSIBLY IV BAG.
AND I'M NOT SURE WHERE THOSE
ARE GOING TO COME FROM. THAT.
THANK YOU MISTER MUSIC HERE
YOU'RE- THANK YOU MR. THAT
RIGHT. WE HAVE A FULL PANTRY
WHAT WE HAVE TO. BE FIFTY
PEOPLE THE CANOLA. BUY FOOD. SO
PLEASE HELP US PLEASE CRAFT THE
BILL ALL RIGHT THANK YOU MA'AM.
MR GUSTER. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS TRYING TO
GRAFT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION WE'RE-
PLEASED TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
AND WHILE. THEY PROVIDE
IMPORTANT PROTECTIONS FOR
HOMEOWNERS IN THE PARKING
DESCRIBED BY THE PREVIOUS
WITNESS WE'RE ALSO SUPPORTING
IT BECAUSE IT CLOSES THE GAP IN
THE- EIGHTY FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWOS PROTECTION. THAT BILL AS
YOU KNOW PROVIDED JUST BECAUSE
THE RENT GOUGING PROTECTIONS
FOR RENTERS. AGAIN CONVENTIONAL
RENTAL HOUSING BUT NOT TO THOSE
EITHER HOMEOWNERS OR RENTERS
LIVING IN A MOBILE HOME PARK
THIS BILL PROVIDES THE NARROW
EXPANSION OF THAT TO. PROTECT A
CERTAIN SUBSET OF RENTERS THOSE
WHO ARE LIVING IN A MOBILE HOME
THAT THEY ARE RANGING FROM THE-
FROM THE PARK OWNERS OF THE
RIGID ABOUT THE HOME AND THE
SPACE FROM THE OWNER OF THE
PARK THOSE WRITERS. ARE
CURRENTLY NOT PROTECTED BY THE
STATEWIDE PROTECTION THE
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO. THOSE ARE
CRITICAL PROTECTIONS ABOUT. THE
TECH FOLKS FROM. REASONABLE
RATE INCREASES BUT ALSO-
UNFAIR. VERY FUTURE REDUCTION.
DISPEL ALL. CLOSE THAT GAP BY
PROVIDING PROTECTIONS FOR THOSE
RENTERS. AND FOR THAT REASON WE
SPOKE WITH THE OWNER AND I
THOUGHT. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK SILVA
ANYONE ELSE- WISHING TO TESTIFY.
NO ALL RIGHT LET'S TRN TO THE
GALLERY AND LET'S TURN TO THE
ROOM ONE TWELVE IN THE GALLERY
ANYONE ELSE AND SUPPORT IN THE
GALLERY. SEEING NONE ROOM ONE
TWELVE NONE. ALL RIGHT. MR
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD QUEUE UP
THOSE IN SUPPORT OF. EIGHTY
NINE SEVEN EIGHT. THANK YOU MR
CHAIR FOR COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY NINE SEVEN EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. BACK
COMMAND AGAIN ONE. ZERO AND
MISTER CHAIR I SHOW NO ONE
QUEUING UP TO GIVE COMMENTS AT
THE TIME ALL IGHT- NOW LET'S
TURN THE OPPOSITION AS I
MENTIONED AT THE OUTSET- I SEE
MR BAKER AND MR WYSOCKI OR BOTH
IN THE GALLERIA TESTIFY. AND IF
THERE IS ANOTHER WITNESS WHO
WISHES TO TESTIFY WILL PERMIT
THAT. NAM FOR A TOTAL OF FIVE
MINUTES ALRIGHT MR WEIS SAKE GO
AHEAD THANK YOU MR CHAIR
MEMBERS- CHRIS WHY SAKE
REPRESENTING THE WESTERN
MANUFACTURED HOUSING
COMMUNITIES ASSOCIATION. I'LL
KEEP IT SHORT- WE GIVE WITH
RESPECT TO THIS BILL WE
APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS AND THE
WORK THAT THE AUTHOR IS GONE
THROUGH- TO MAKE THIS GO WHERE
IT IS BUT WE STILL MOST
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE. YOU
ESSENTIALLY THE MOST AT THE
CORE OF IT IS STATEWIDE RENT
CONTROL WE BELIEVE ARTIFICIALLY
INCREASES THE ACTUAL PRICE OF
THE HOME. AND FOR THAT AND MANY
OTHER REASONS WE CONTINUE OUR
OPPOSITION THANK YOU BYE THANK
YOU MISS WYSOCKI. STRIKER THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JASON I
COULD AGAIN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MOBILE HOME PARK
OWNERS ALLIANCE WOULD ECHO THE
COMMENTS MADE BY MR WYSOCKI WE
UNDERSTAND RESPECT TE SEVEN
MEMBER IS TRYING TO. ADDRESS AN
ISSUE WITHIN HER COMMUNITY BUT
AS A PRACTICAL MATTER C. N. PH
DOESN'T BELIEVE THE RING
CONTROLS IT A GOOD POLICY TOOL
FOR RESOLVING THAT THE HOUSING
CRISIS. BUT WE DO OPPOSE THE
PRECEDENT SET IN THE BILL OF
SETTING DIFFERENT RATES FOR
RENT CONTROL FOR. MOBILE HOME
PARK. IN A MOBILE HOME PARK
THAN IN ANY OTHER TYPE OF
HOUSING IN THE STATE- AND
LASTLY WHAT WOULD. THE BILL.
APPLIES DIFFERENT RULE FOR
RENT CONTROL TO. PARK ON HOMES
VERSUS RESIDENT OWN HOMES. YOU
COULD HAVE A SITUATION WHERE
TENANTS IN THE SAME COMMUNITY-
HAVE DIFFERENT LEVELS OF
PROTECTION UNDER RENT CONTROL
REPAIR DEPENDING ON WHO OWNS A
HOME THAT THEY'RE LIVING IN. WE
DON'T BELIEVE THAT'S
APPROPRIATE AGAIN WE DON'T
SUPPORT RENT CONTROL. AS A
POLICY TOOL BUT IF IT'S GOING
TO BE APPLIED IT NEEDS TO BE
APPLIED TO- HOUSING REGARDLESS
OF WHO OWNS. FAMOUS RECORD ALL
RIGHT MR MODERATOR IF THERE'S
ANOTHER WITNESS PRIMARY WITNESS
IN OPPOSITION IF YOU COULD
LOCATE THAT WITNESS AND ALLOW
THAT PERSON TO TESTIFY. BETTER
CARE WE HAVE A JAMES STOCKARD
ON THE LINE. ALL RIGHT GO AHEAD.
BY DAVID JAMES DOUGHERTY I AM
THE GENERAL COUNSEL BRUCE
SAUNDERS PROPERTY COMPANY IN
FULL PEACE RANCH L. OAKLEY
WHICH OWNS RENTAL POSSIBLE PARK.
IF YOU WERE TO BE PULLED YOU
HAVE A HOT. I'D LIKE TO BUY
SOME BEIJING TO GIVE THE
COMMITTEE A MORE COMPLETE SET
OF. WHO IS THAT BOTH THE
PARENTS AND THE SAYS THE
LACKING THIS MEASURE WITH
RESPECT TO THIS ONE R. THE MAIN
TARGET STATE. CONTACT BUT BE
UNDERSTOOD MOBILE PARK WAS ONLY
FOR DECADES BY A SINGLE
OWNERSHIP FAMILY. OPPOSITION
THIRTEEN PROPERTY INCREASES
INCREASED VERY SLOWLY OVER TIME
ALL THE MARKET VALUE OF THE
PROPERTY. WHEN THE PROPERTY WAS
EVENTUALLY SOLD. THE ATTACHMENT
TO THE MARKET VALUE INEVITABLY
RESULTED IN HUGE INCREASES IN
PROPERTY TAX AND WHEN THE
PROPERTY WAS PUT ON THE MARKET
SEVERAL COMPANIES PLAYED
OFFERED BY. OUR COMPANY HAD
BOUGHT IT SOMEONE ELSE WOULD.
HAVE HIT ANY CASE WHATEVER
BOUGHT IT WOULD REPLACE THE
CHARGING PLEASE NOT READY
PRINCES ABOVE THOSE WORN. BY
PRIOR OWNERS YEAH NO PROBLEM TO
BEGIN THE OWNER TO COME CLOSE
TO MAKING ENDS MEET. LETTER TO
MEDIC INCREASING REVENUE.
GROWTH INCREASES. BUT
IDENTIFYING BILL IN THE- LOBBY
FROM MATTER. I MORE THE COLUMN
SHOULD BE UNDERSTOOD WE'LL CALL.
THE STOCK. THANK YOU ALL OF THE
PERKS PARK PROPERTY TAXES
SKYROCKETED AMOUNT EQUAL TO A
HUNDRED DOLLARS PER MONTH PER
SPACE IN THE PARK. THAT'S ONE
THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED TWENTY
DOLLARS PER YEAR FOR EACH OF
THE THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY SEVEN
STATE. THERE IS NO ALTERNATIVE
BUT TO INCREASE FAVORITE SPRING
CREEK CLOSE TO MARKET VALUE AND
EVEN NOW. TWO YEARS LATER TO
INCREASE YOUR RATES ARE STILL
OPERATING AT A LOSS. TO SEVENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS A MONTH. ONLY
IS EXTREMELY AWARE OF THE
FINANCIAL. OF BURNING THE PARK
PRESS. CANADA COLD RAINY
CHRISTMAS PLAYED LONGER ON MANY
OF THE- OWNERSHIP TO GET MAKE
SURE WOULD KNOW TO NOT LOSE
THEIR HOMES IN THE BUILDING I
READ. YEAH WHAT ARE YOU. IT TO
THE RANKS OF THE PROGRAM. BY A
THIRD PARTY THEN WE CAN PLACE
THE TWO YEARS BACK. THE
AVAILABILITY OF THIS PROGRAM IS
MADE KNOWN TO ALL RIGHT THEN.
YOU KNOW SHIPPING GAUGE LIAISON
TO KNOCK ON EVERY DOOR TO
EXPLAIN THE PROGRAM AND
ASSISTANT PROFESSOR IN
COMPLETING. THE APPLICATION.
ANY CLAIMS THE CARD GOOD
PROGRAM WILL BE CALLED
WONDERFUL LOSING AN- HOME DUE
TO INABILITY TO PAY RENT. THERE
ARE THREE LEVELS OF THE BASICS
WHAT WE CALL THE SUPER CLOSE
THE IN EXTRAORDINARY
CIRCUMSTANCES. BUT IT CERTAINLY
IS THAT THAT THE LAND IS MORE
THAN 40% OF. THE MONTHLY INCOME
WHICH WE RECOGNIZE HIS MOST
CASES FIX THE TOTAL INCREASE IN
RENT IS SIXTY SEVEN DOLLARS A
MONTH ALL RIGHT IF YOU COULD
WRAP UP PLEASE. AT THE RATE OF
MORE THAN 50% THE RATE INCREASE
TO SEVENTEEN DOLLARS A MONTH. I
THINK YOU FEEL ABOUT YOUR
COMMAND YOU'LL FIND BOTH THE
ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA EMPHASIZE
THE BENEFITS ARE MORE GENEROUS
THAN ANY ARE UNDERMINING. THANK
YOU SIR. WE APPRECIATE AS MIKE
ONE QUICK QUESTION YOU SAID
THERE WAS NO ALTERNATIVE BUT TO
INCREASE AROUND COULD YOU
EXPLAIN THAT. WELL WE'RE NOT
GOING TO BE. THERE'S NO WAY
THERE'S NO WAY THAT WOULD BE
CLOSE TO COMING CLOSE TO
MEETING THE FENCE THERE WAS.
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS PER YEAR JUST INCREASE
TAXES ALONG. BUT APART. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU- OTHERS OTHERS
IN OPPOSITION. MR MODERATOR I
SEE NO ONE IN THE GALLERY I SEE
NO ONE ROOM ONE TWELVE IT IF WE
COULD HAVE THOSE IN OPPOSITION
TO A PLACE. THANK YOU MR CHAIR
FOR COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION TO
A. B. NINE SEVENTY EIGHT.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO THE
COMMAND AGAIN ONE SEVEN ZERO.
AN OUTLINE ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY
ONE YEAR MY GOODNESS. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
CREAM GREASY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE ONE
MORE COMMENT COMING FROM ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WHILE WE PROVIDE
THEM WITH THEIR LINE NUMBER.
LINE ONE HUNDRED NINETY ONE
YEAR MIGHT GIVE. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN THIS IS LAURENCE
MACKIN WITH BUSH CAR NAKED
COMMUNITIES. WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
AB NINE SEVEN EIGHT THANK YOU.
AND MISTER CHAIR THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU MR MODERATOR ANYONE
ELSE ON THE PHONE EITHER IN
SUPPORT OR IN OPPOSITION. WE
HAVE NO COMMENT FOR EITHER SIDE
AT THE TIME ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO THE CHAMBER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. PRESIDENT WAS TALKING.
I HAVE A QUESTION- IS HOW THIS
PROPERTY TAX ASSESSMENTS PLAY
IN TO THE BELLY OF ANY. LAND
LARGER INCREASE- OF THE FEES
THAT PEOPLE PAY WE HAD JUST HAD
A BILL ON. ON INFRASTRUCTURE
IMPROVEMENTS AND THAT SORT OF
SEPARATE FROM THE RANT. MAYBE
WHAT HAPPENS IF YOU RECEIVE A
TAX BILL FROM THE CITY AND FROM
THE COUNTY HOW IS THAT. IN THE
NORMAL COURSE OF BUSINESS WITH
US SAID SOMEBODY WHO'S FRIENDS-
LIMITATIONS ARE THIS IS A
QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR'S NOTE
FOR THE OFFICE OR FOR THE
OPPOSITION. I THINK I THINK FOR
THE AUTHOR I MEAN WE'RE WE'RE
THE OPPOSITION HAS SAID THAT
WE'RE PASSING ON THE REAL
PROPERTY TAXES TO THE TO THE-
COACH OWNERS ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK SILVA.
THIRTY CARRIERS SPAHN I DO I
THINK THEY'RE VERY SEPARATE
ISSUES AND WE ALL RECEIVE AN
ANNUAL TAX. BILL FOR OUR HOMES
IF WE HAVE THE PRIVILEGE TO OWN
A HOME AND IF YOU ARE A
LANDLORD IT YOU RECEIVE THAT
SAME TYPE OF- BILL AND WE DON'T
pTHERE'S A NEW TAX ASSESSMENT
THAT IMMEDIATELY RENTS GO UP
BUT IF YOU WILL ON NOTE ARE
THESE RENTS HAVE DOUBLED. TWICE
NOW AND THE LAST TWO YEARS AND
IF YOU ARE SOMEBODY WHO AS WE
KNOW MANY OF OUR SENIORS WHO
WON WE SAY FIXED IN INCOME WE
NEED TO KNOW WHAT FIXED INCOME
MEANS MANY TIMES THAT FIXED
INCOME. IS SOMEWHERE BETWEEN
FIFTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH
PARTICULARLY IF YOU'RE SOMEBODY
WHO'S DISABLED THESE ARE THE
TYPES OF- MONTHLY INCOME
SOMEBODY'S LIVING ON AND THEN
TO DOUBLE SOMETIMES THE AMOUNT
FOR THE PARK RENTAL SPACE. THAT
MEANSAS WE'VE HEARD IN THESE
ARE NOT DRAMATIC TESTIMONIES
ARE ABSOLUTELY THE TRUTH OF
SOMEBODY DECIDING CAN THEY-
AFFORD THEIR MEDICATION CAN
THEY AFFORD. FOR MILLS AND SO
FORTH BUT CERTAINLY WE KNOW
PROPERTY TAX IN ORANGE COUNTY
IS CERTAINLY VERY EXPENSIVE SO
I UNDERSTAND THAT FROM THE PARK
OWNER BUT THEY ALSO UNDERSTOOD
UNDERSTOOD THE TYPE OF PROPERTY
THEY WERE BUYING AND WHAT THAT
WOULD LOOK LIKE. AND THIS IS
NOT THE FIRST TIME THE SPECIFIC
PARK OWNER HAS DONE THIS WHICH
IS BY A PARK AND IT NOW SINCE
ESCALATE- THE RENTS IN A VERY
DRAMATIC FASHION. THANK YOU
DOES THAT ANSWER YOUR QUESTION
SIR WHAT ELSE WELL I GUESS I MY
UNDERSTANDING OF FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO- WAS TO LIMIT PRICE
GOUGING SO I DON'T KNOW IT
SEEMS THAT THERE'S AN
INTERCEDING- PIECE OF
INFORMATION SOMEBODY MAY HAVE
THIS IS. A COMMERCIAL PROPERTY
OR MOBILE HOME PARK THAT WAS
ASSESSED IN NINETEEN FIFTY
EIGHT AND THEN THEY GET SUCCESS
IN TWENTY NINETEEN THERE'S A
BIG PRICE DIFFERENCE THERE THAT
WHETHER THE- NEW PROPERTY TAXES
WERE GO GO UP. I GUESS. WHEN WE
HAD THE DESIGN. OF FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO WAS TO WAS TO HIT
THE BUTTON- THAT INCREMENT THAT
WISHES HE WERE A PROFIT NOT
COVER YOUR COSTS BUT MAYBE I'M-
MISS. THINKING OUR- WHAT DID
WHAT THE- FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO
WAS A WAS ABOUT- MY
UNDERSTANDING OF IT AT THE TIME
THAT THERE WAS A THERE WAS A
RUSH BECAUSE PRICES WERE UP
RUSHING NOT. I'M PASSING ON THE
COST OF PAYING MY TAXES TO THE
PEOPLE WHO RENT. THE D. DID YOU
WISH THAT SOMEONE RESPOND TO
THE COMMENT OR I THINK MAYBE
AMENDMENT ARE. CONSIDER A GAS
TAX ID COULD BECAUSE BECAUSE
THIS IS I DON'T REMEMBER
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO HITTING
LIKE THE TAX ASSESSMENTS. I'M
SORRY YOU SAID BRIAN. AUGUSTA
WITH THOSE DURING THE INTER.
OKAY THANK THE MEASUREMENT
WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO RESPOND
YES. FIVE MISTER MARK OWSKI I
THINK YOUR QUESTION INTO THE
PRIOR SPEAKERS COMMENT. THE
CONSTRUCTION OF THIS MIDDLE
DIFFER SLIGHTLY IN TERMS OF THE
PERCENTAGES THAT ARE INVOLVED
WITH THE CONSTRUCTION OF THIS
BILL. THESE LIMITS ON THE
ANNUAL PERCENTAGE- THIRD ANNUAL
COST OF. GROSS RENTAL RATE THEY
COULD BE CHARGED. IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY THE CALCULATION
TAKING INTO ACCOUNT THOSE
CHARGES THAT SPIKE ASSESSMENTS.
FOR OTHER THINGS IT'S SIMPLY
LOOKING OUT A CALCULATION OF
THE RENTAL RATE THAT'S BEING
CHARGED. AS A PERCENTAGE OF THE
PRIOR YEAR. OR TWELVE MONTH
PERIOD SHOW AND THAT IS THE
SAME STRUCTURES FORTY TWO IT
DOES NOT NECESSARILY TAKE. INTO
ACCOUNT THAT WAS. IN PLACE BY
THE WAY IN WHICH THE- I HAVE
BEEN SET IN LOWE THAN FOR TWO
THE WAY IN WHICH THE PRESIDENT
PERCENT HAVE BEEN SET FOR.
PROVIDE PLENTY OF ROOM FOR A
PROPERTY OWNER TO RECOUP THOSE
COSTS OVER THAT TIME PERIOD SO-
BUT IT DOES NOT BECAUSE WE'RE A
STATE WIDE LEVEL- CONTEMPLATE A
SORT OF- INDIVIDUALIZED
ASSESSMENT OF COSTS PERSON'S.
RENTAL INCREASES- ALTHOUGH
THERE'S ALWAYS GOING TO BE A
CONSTITUTIONAL LIMIT ON THOSE
SORTS OF. SORT OF ALREADY AKEN
HERE. BUT WE DON'T LOOK AT THAT
FIND GREAT ANALYSIS AND EITHER.
EITHER THIS PROPOSAL IN THE
CURRENT LAW. HI THANK YOU SIR
ANYTHING FOR THIS SORT OF WORK
OWSKI NON ALL RIGHT- ANYONE
ELSE MICROPHONE RAISED I SEE NO
OTHER MICROPHONES RAISED- IS
THERE A MOTION. THE SENATOR
ALSO MOST OF THE- ALL RIGHT-
SEVEN AND A QUICK SURVEY TO
CARE CLOSE. JUST RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AND I VOTE ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU MENTION CANS OF YOU
CALL ROLL THIS IS EIGHTY NINE
SEVENTY EIGHT BY FAMILY MEMBER
KIRKSVILLE THAT WITH THE MOTION
BY SENATOR DID US SO THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED- BERG HI.
AMBER I BOARD YES. CARRY IT ON
I GOT IT- I DID OUT SO. DID I
SO I'D GONZALEZ. HERTZBERG
JONES LAYERED ON LAYERED ICE
STERN. STERN I WAKE HOUSE HE
ARE Y. CASKEY I WEINER WEINER
II YOU HAVE SEVEN TO ZERO SO
FAR THANK YOU WILL PUT THE BILL
ON CALL THANK YOU SIMPLY MEMBER
TEAM MEMBERS ALL RIGHT. ALL
RIGHT- WE HAVE CERTAINLY MEMBER
RACE WHO'S HERE- AFTER ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RACES BILL. WHICH IS A.
B. EIGHT FOUR NINE ITEM NUMBER
SIXTEEN THEN WE HAVE ONLY ONE
MORE BILL TO BE HEARD TODAY AND
THAT IS ITEM NUMBER TWELVE.
EIGHTY EIGHT TO FIVE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS. I WANT TO
BEGIN BY THANKING THE CHAIRMAN
OF STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
BILL AND ON THIS ISSUE I'M
PLEASED TO SHARE THAT I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS I'VE SEEN ON PAGE
EIGHT AND PAGE NINE IN THE
ANALYSIS WHICH WILL PROVIDE
GUIDANCE TO JUDGES IN ASSESSING
DAMAGES. BASED ON THE SEVERITY
OF VIOLATIONS TO RESIDENTS.
EIGHTY EIGHT FORTY NINE WILL
PROTECT THE RIGHTS OF SENIOR
LIVING AND SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES BY CLARIFYING THAT
UP TO. FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS IN
DAMAGES CAN BE AWARDED HER
VIOLATION OF RIGHTS RATHER THAN
IN TOTAL. SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY
TWO THE LAW HAS STATED THAT
RESIDENTS CAN BRING A CIVIL
ACTION AGAINST FACILITIES THAT
VIOLATE THEIR- OF THE
FACILITIES MUST PAY FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS PER VIOLATION.
IN TWENTY TWENTY THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SUPREME COURT IN GERMAN
VERSUS H. C. R. MANNER KERR.
INTERPRETED THIS LAW TO MEAN
THAT THE MAXIMUM A VICTIM CAN
RECOVER AND DICK IN DAMAGES
FROM VIOLATIONS IS FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS. REGARDLESS OF HOW MANY
VIOLATIONS RESIDENTS SUFFERED.
THIS INTERPRETATION FROM THE
COURT HAS RESULTED IN A LACK OF
ACCOUNTABILITY. FOR THE
INHUMANE TREATMENT OF OUR
SENIORS. IT IS CLEAR THAT
CAPPING DAMAGES AT FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS REGARDLESS OF THE
NUMBER OR SEVERITY OF
VIOLATIONS IS NOT ENOUGH TO
DETER AND REMEDY VIOLATIONS. OF
THE RIGHTS OF OUR SENIORS. A.
B. EIGHT FORTY NINE WILL
SAFEGUARD SENIORS RIGHTS BY
CLARIFYING THAT UP TO FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS IN DAMAGES CAN
BE AWARDED PER VIOLATION OF
RIGHTS RATHER THAN IN TOTAL. IN
THIS WAY WE CAN BALANCE THE
SCALES OF JUSTICE. AND ENSURE.
THAT THOSE WHO HARM OUR SENIORS
ARE HELD ACCOUNTABLE AND THAT
SUCH FINDINGS WILL SERVE AS A
DETERRENT TO OTHERS. HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT THIS BILL
TODAY. IS TWENTY SECOND TELL.
WITH CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES FOR
NURSING HOME REFORM. AND JANICE
GERMAN THE PLAINTIFF AND
APPELLANT IN THE GERMAN CASE
WHOSE FATHER SUFFERED REPEATED
VIOLATIONS WHILE RESIDING AT A
SKILLED NURSING FACILITY. THANK
YOU- I BELIEVE IS IT DISCERN A
SON TESTIFYING ALSO. I'M SORRY
THE NEW NUMBER IS COULD YOU
TELL ME WHO YOUR WITNESSES ARE
AGAIN YOUR PRIMARY WITNESSES.
TONY CHECK OUT CHECK TO TELL
WITH CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES. FOR
NURSING HOME REFORM. AND JANICE
GERMAN ALL RIGHT IS IT MR CHECK
IT TELL- IF YOU'RE ON THE LINE
IF YOU COULD MAKE YOURSELF NOW.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU
CHAIRPERSON NUMBER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND STAFF FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY ON
EIGHTY EIGHT FORTY NINE MY NAME
IS TONY CHECK ITSELF- THE STAFF
ATTORNEY FOR CALIFORNIA BECAUSE
FOR NURSING HOME REFORM. I'VE
SPENT PRETTY MUCH MY WHOLE
CAREER REPRESENTING OLDER AND
DISABLED ADULTS AND FIGHTING
FOR THEIR RIGHTS. WHEN I BEGAN
WORKING IN NURSING HOMES I WAS
APPALLED THAT THE SIGNIFICANT
RIGHTS DEPRIVATIONS THAT
OCCURRED ROUTINELY.WITHOUT A
SECOND THOUGHT TO RESIDENTS WHO
HAD VERY LITTLE POWER. HEALTH
AND SAFETY CODE SECTION
FOURTEEN THIRTY B. IS A
REMARKABLE STATUTE. IT EMPOWERS
RESIDENTS TO ENFORCE THEIR OWN
RIGHT AND SHOULD NOT BE RELIANT
ON THE STATE. THAT'S ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THE STATE
ENFORCEMENT OF RESIDENT RIGHT.
AT TEN AND I'M SPEAKING
CHARITABLY HERE HISTORICALLY AN
ADEQUATE. I'LL TELL YOU ONE
QUICK STORY ON PUBLIC
ENFORCEMENT OF NURSING. WE KNOW
THAT THE PATIENT STAFFING IS
CRITICAL TO RESIDENT CARE IT'S
THE NUMBER ONE VARIABLE FOR
TELLING WHETHER NURSING HOME
CARE IS GOING TO BE GOOD OR
BAD. NOT SURPRISINGLY THERE'S A
STRONG CORRELATION BETWEEN
UNDERSTAFFING POOR INFECTION
CONTROL THE EXTENT OF COLD
OUTBREAKS IN NURSING HOMES OVER
THE PAST SIXTEEN MONTHS. IT
EXPECT THE PH TO BE. THE
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH TO BE
VIGILANT WHEN MONITORING
FACILITY STAFFING ENFORCING OUR
MINIMUM STATE. STAFFING LAWS.
WELL USING EASILY ACCESSIBLE
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE NURSING
STAFFING DATA I CAN TELL YOU
THAT A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FOUR
CALIFORNIA NURSING HOMES ARE
UNDER THE STATE'S MINIMUM
STAFFING REQUIREMENTS. ON THE
AVERAGE DAY NOT ONE OR TWO DAYS
EVERY MONTH BUT ON THE AVERAGE
DAY. THIRTY DO THIS BIG
UNDERSTAFFED BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
THERE'S NO ENFORCEMENT
RESIDENTS SUFFER THIS IS WHY
FOURTEEN THIRTY B. HEALTH AND
SAFETY FOURTEEN THIRTY B. IS SO
CRITICAL TO NURSING HOME
RESIDENTS. THEY USED FOURTEEN
THIRTY BETWEEN SURE ADEQUATE
STAFFING SO THAT THEY CAN GET
HELP TO THE TOILET IN TIME.
THEY USE FOURTEEN THIRTY B. TO
GET COMPENSATION WHEN THEY'VE
BEEN ILLEGALLY DUMPED INTO
HOSPITALS OR HOMELESS SHELTERS.
THESE FOURTEEN THIRTY B. TO
STOP ILLEGAL DRUGGING WITH
PSYCHOTROPIC DRUGS WHICH HAS
BEEN ON THE RISE. DIMMICK
STARTED BUT THE GERMAN CASE
CRITICALLY DAMAGED FOURTEEN
THIRTY B. FIVE HUNDRED DOLLAR
CAP PERVERSELY MAKES IT
PROFITABLE TO HARM NURSING HOME
RESIDENTS POLICE ARE OFF THE
HOOK FOR FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS
NO MATTER HOW OFTEN OR HOW
VICIOUSLY THEY VIOLATED
RESIDENT RIGHT. IN FACT THEY'VE
TAKEN RECENTLY DEFENDING
VICTIMS FIVE HUNDRED DOLLAR
CHECKS WITH A LETTER THAT SAYS
BASICALLY NOW GO AWAY. EIGHTY
EIGHT FORTY NINE RESTORES
FOURTEEN THIRTY B. TO WHAT IT
WAS AND WHAT IT REALLY SHOULD
BE. AN IMPORTANT TOOL IN THE
FIGHT TO PROTECT RESIDENTS AND
THEIR WELL BEING. PLEASE VOTE
YES ON EIGHTY EIGHT FORTY NINE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER SHE
COULD TELL- MISS GERMAN. YEAH.
JAMES GERMAN GO AHEAD. OKAY
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JANICE GERMAN MY FATHER WAS
JOHN GERMAN- IT NINETY YEARS OF
AGE HAD AN ACTIVE LIFE SWIMMING
IN A POOL THREE TIMES A WEEK
AND LIVING IN ITS OWN HOME. MY
FATHER WAS SUPPOSED TO GET
REHAB THERAPY AT A MANOR CARE
NURSING HOME FOLLOWING HIP
SURGERY AND THEN COME HOME IN A
COUPLE OF MNTHS. THIS TIME
THERE BECAME A LIVING NIGHTMARE
NO ONE RESPONDED TO HIS CALL
LIGHT AND CALLS FOR HELP. ONE
TIME I VISITED HIM AND FAMILY
AND HALF NAKED AND COVERED IN
FECES. NURSING HOME STAFF WOULD
LEAVE HIM SITTING ON A BED PAN
TELLING HIM TO PRESS THE CALL
LIGHT WHEN HE WAS DONE. HE TOLD
ME THAT HIS BOTTOM HURT AND WE
DISCOVERED PRESSURE SORES ON
ITS BOTTOM THIS LASTED FOR
THREE MONTHS. I FELT HELPLESS
AND CAN'T IMAGINE HOW MY FATHER
MUST HAVE FELT. WE WENT TO
TRIAL AGAINST THE NURSING HOME
THE JURY FOUND THAT MANORCARE
VIOLATED MY FATHER'S RIGHTS.
THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO TIMES.
I FELT THAT THE JURY HEARD MY
FATHER THAT DAY BUT MY FEELING
THAT JUSTICE WAS DELIVERED WAS
SHORT LIVED I WAS SURPRISED AND
SADDENED TO LEARN THAT LAST
YEAR THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME
COURT WIPED AWAY THE JURY'S
VERDICT REDUCING ALL THREE
HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO VIOLATIONS
DOWN TO FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS.
IT PAINS ME TO THINK THAT THE
NURSING HOME COULD VIOLATE MY%
FATHER'S RIGHTS OVER AND OVER
AGAIN AND GET AWAY WITH IT FOR
ONLY FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS. WHAT
DETERRENCE IS SHARING.
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING. IT ANGERS
ME TO THINK THAT NURSING HOMES
WILL GET AWAY WITH THIS WITH
EVERYONE ELSE WHO HAS TO STAY
AND LIVE IN ONE. THAT'S WHY I'M
HERE TODAY SPEAKING HERE TODAY.
AS MUCH AS I WISH I CANNOT TAKE
AWAY ALL THE TIME MY FATHER WAS
TREATED WITH INDIGNITY AS IF HE
WERE LESS THAN HUMAN. I ALSO
KNOW THAT I HAVE TO ACCEPT THE
SUPREME COURT'S DECISION. BUT I
HOPE THAT YOU HEAR MY FATHER'S
STORY TODAY JUST LIKE THAT JURY
DID SHOW TAT MANOR CARE AND
ALL OTHER NURSING HOMES YOU
KNOW THAT THEY CANNOT GET AWAY
WITH THE NIGHTMARES THAT CAUSED
FOR THE MALL PRICE OF. FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS AND EACH
RESIDENT. I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
THE FAMILY BILL EIGHT FORTY
NINE. SO THAT OTHER FAMILIES
DON'T LOSE ACCOUNTABILITY AND
SO THAT OTHERS DO NOT SUFFER
LIKE MY FATHER DID THANK YOU
MENTION SO MUCH THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN- WE'RE SORRY FOR YOUR
LOSS AND YOUR FATHER SUFFERING.
ALL RIGHT- TAKEN IN THE GALLERY
OTHERS IN SUPPORT IN THE
GALLERY SEEING NO ONE ELSE IN
THE GALLERY AND SUPPORT THOSE
IN OPPOSITION EXCUSE ME STRIKE
THAT- IN ROOM ONE TWELVE IN
SPORT SEEING NON. MODERATE IF
YOU QUEUE UP THOSE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU MR
CHAIR FOR COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY. EIGHT FORTY NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. THAT
COMMAND AGAIN. ONE ZERO. AND
ONE ONE HUNDRED NINETY THREE
YOUR MY GET UP. IF ANYONE COMES
INTO PLAY THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ONE ONE HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT-
MY COULD OPEN. PAKISTAN ON
BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER TRYING
TO CALIFORNIA SO THE PRIORITY
FOR OUR ORGANIZATION WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. N. LINE ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
TWO YOU'RE MY KID UP. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS TO ME TO
DO I'M A VOLUNTEER WITH AARP
WITH OVER THREE POINT THREE
MILLION MEMBERS. AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT A. B. EIGHT
FORTY NINE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
M. F. KIRCHER THERE NO FURTHER
COMMENT AT THE TIME ALL RIGHT
LET'S TURN TO THE OPPOSITION I
SEE MR LEVIN. IN THE GALLERY-
MISTER LEVIN FLOOR'S YOURS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBER SHANE LEE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
HEALTH FACILITIES. REGRETTABLY
HERE WE ARE AGAIN BEFORE THIS
LEGISLATURE POSING ANOTHER
LIABILITY BILL TARGET AT THE
NURSING HOME INDUSTRY. BY MY
COUNT THIS IS THE SEVENTH BILL
INTRODUCED OVER THE YEARS
TARGETING THIS PARTICULAR
FOURTEEN THIRTY B. STATUTE.
STATUTE CREATED IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY TWO THAT WAS NEVER MEANT
TO BE THE MAIN CAUSE OF ACTION
IN FACT JUST SO WE'RE CLEAR.
AND CAN PURSUE A WHOLE HOST OF
REMEDIES AGAINST NURSING HOMES
IN FACT. THE SHEET I'M HOLDING
UP RIGHT NOW CONTAINS NO LESS
THAN TWELVE DIFFERENT LEGAL
REMEDIES. THE SUPREME COURT
THIS JUST THIS PAST AUGUST
STATED THE FOURTEEN THIRTY
VIEWS TO BE INTERPRETED AS A
PER CASE FINE. NOT FOR
VIOLATION ON A FIVE TWO VOTE.
THE COMPLETE OPPOSITE OF WHAT
THIS BUILD US SO WHY ARE WE
HERE. BECAUSE THE PROPONENTS
REALIZE THAT ALL THEY NEED TO
DO IS PROVE THAT THE VIOLATION
MERELY OCCURRED. TO CORRECT TO
COLLECT MASSIVE AWARDS. THEY DO
NOT NEED TO SHOW OR PROVE HARM
SEVERITY INTENT NEGLIGENCE AND
SO ON. SO THEY JUST NEED TO
SHOW THAT A VIOLATION OCCURRED.
PERIOD THIS WILL BANKRUPT
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES
THAT'S A FACT NOT AN
EXAGGERATION. WE **** FOR THIS
COMMITTEE IS HELPING THE CHAIRS
UP TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH US
TO NARROW THIS BILL AND ITS
IMPACTS OUR INDUSTRY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR LEVIN. OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION DR CARL STEINBERG
MISTERS DR STEINBERG AVAILABLE.
THANK YOU R CHAIR NUMBERS MY
NAME IS CARL STEINBERG AND I'VE
BEEN A NURSING HOME PHYSICIAN
AND MEDICAL DIRECTOR IN SAN
DIEGO COUNTY SINCE NINETEEN
NINETY FIVE I'M THE CURRENT
PRESIDENT OF AMDA THE SOCIETY
FOR POST ACUTE AND LONG TERM
CARE MEDICINE. TO BE CLEAR
WE'RE A NATIONAL ORGANIZATION
OF FIVE THOUSAND PLUS WORKING
ON DOCTORS WE ARE NOT INDUSTRY
ADVOCATES OUR PRIMARY MISSION
IS TO ENSURE THE BEST CARE OF
THE BALL OF THE POPULATION WE
LOOK AFTER I'M ALSO A DELEGATE
O THE AMA AND GMA AND SERVE
THE PURPOSE OF BUYING EXPERT ON
BEHALF OF PLAINTIFFS AND
DEFENDANTS IN WORKING ON
LITIGATION. I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY ON
BEHALF OF AND THE IN OPPOSITION
TO A BE A FORTY NINE. DOLLAR
DEVICE BILL WHICH IS PRESENTED
UNDER THE GUISE OF IMPROVING
NURSING HOME QUALITY AND
COMPENSATING AGREED NURSING
HOME RESIDENTS THERE'S A LITTLE
MORE THAN A GIFT THE
PLAINTIFF'S ATTORNEY AFTER THE
DISASTER KILLED HEALTHCARE
VERDICT IN TWENTY TEN IN WHICH
ALMOST SEVEN HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS WAS AWARDED BASED ON
FOURTEEN THIRTY B. VIOLATION IN
THE ABSENCE OF ANY DEMONSTRABLE
HARM TO ANY RESIDENT AND IN
WHICH THE AVERAGE PLAN OF.
RECOVERED ONLY TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS OUR SUPREME COURT HAS
ALREADY RULED ON THIS ISSUE AND
DETERMINED THAT THE IMPOSITION
OF FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS PER
INCIDENT F BEACH
ADMINISTRATIVE VIOLATIONS THE
EXCESSIVE BASICALLY UNLIMITED
AND NOT REFLECTIVE OF THE
ORIGINAL INTENT OF FOURTEEN
THIRTY B. I WOULD GET A LOT OF
NURSING HOME CHARGING THEY'RE
ALWAYS MINOR CHARTING
DEFICIENCIES. GOING TO CHECK A
BOX ON A FORM OR SERVING A MEAL
A FEW MINUTES LATE PLANES
ATTORNEYS WILL BE ABLE TO FIGHT
COUNTLESS SUCH HARMLESS
ANOMALIES WHEN THEY GO THROUGH
CHARTS WITH A FINE TOOTH COMB
ON A FISHING EXPEDITION I'M
NINETY NINE BED FACILITY
BECAUSE OF A LAST MINUTE SIP
CALL IN BY A CNA ON ONE SHIP.
THAT WILL NOW BE AT TWO POINT
THREE NINE INSTEAD OF TWO POINT
FORTY EIGHT HOURS PER PATIENT
DAY COULD RUN INTO A FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLAR REWARD JUST FOR
THAT ONE SHIPPED UNDER THIS
PROPOSAL WHAT THE CURRENT FEES
DESPITE NO HARM TO ANY RESIDENT
JUST BASED ON THAT ONE CALL ON.
FOURTEEN THIRTY B. WOULD NEVER
MEANT TO COMPENSATE. PATIENTS
FOR DAMAGES OR BE AWARE MANY
FOR NETFLIX. CALIFORNIA NURSING
HOME RESIDENTS THE ATTORNEY WHO
ARE. THEM RT HAVE AMPLE ACT TO
COME. THROUGH METAL MOUNT. LAW
GROUP AND OUR ELDERS THAT.
PLACE TO TURN FILLER RETURNING
WHICH THE CAN EASILY RUN SEVEN.
UNDER THE CURRENT. OF FOUR
THIRTY B. AWARDS THANK YOU
THANK YOU DARLA STEINER ALL
YEAR ROUND COVERED BY LIABILITY
INSURANCE. SO THEY HAVE THE
POTENTIAL TO PULL MORE POINTING
A LEARNING THE ACTUAL THANK YOU
DOCTOR REMEMBER RIGHT RIGHT
ABOUT OUR BUSINESS. AND THEN
PUT MORE FACILITIES AND
COMPANIES OUT OF BUSINESS HAS
OCCURRED WITH THE SKILLED
LAWSUIT. TAPPING A. B. A. FORTY
NINE WOULD OPEN THE DOOR TO
MARRY THANK YOU VERY MUCH DONNA
STEINBERG WE PROVIDE TESTIMONY
EIGHTY EIGHT FORTY NINE NOW
OWNS OTHERS IN THE GALLERY GOOD
AS ANYONE ELSE IN THE GALLERY
AND MAKE IT TOUGH TO FIGHT. IN
OPPOSITION TO AB EIGHT FOUR
NINE. I SEE NO ONE IN THE
GALLERY. NOW MOVING TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE I SEE NO ONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE- JUST TO BE CLEAR. SOME
OF THE RACE YOU'VE ACCEPTED THE
AMENDMENTS AS PROPOSED IS THAT
RIGHT. THAT IS CORRECT ALL
RIGHT RIGHT. NOW WE COULD QUEUE.
UP THOSE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU MR CHAIR
FOR. THERE OP. TO EIGHT. FORTY
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO RECOMMEND AGAIN ONE ZERO.
LINE ONE HUNDRED NINETY EIGHT
YOU'RE MY KIND OF. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE BRANDED MARCHING WITH
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION I'M CURRENTLY
OPPOSED TO THE BILL-
RESPECTFULLY AND ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS WITHOUT A MENTION OF
THE- THANK YOU. BLINDNESS TWO
HUNDRED ONE NEAR MY COULD OPEN.
THE U. TERM MEMBER SERVICE ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE DISTRICT.
SHE THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WHITE.
ONE HUNDRED NINETY FIVE. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE AT A RALLY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE WE
CURRENTLY HAVE A COUPLE OF THE
MONTH MEDITATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AN ONLINE. TWO
HUNDRED. HELLO AND GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR NUMBER. WITH
READING H. CALIFORNIA WE REMAIN
OPPOSED TO THE BELL AND ECHO
THE COMMENTS OF THE GERMANS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
MATT RECORD SURE THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THE TIME ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH IN
AND- BACK TO THE FLOOR AND
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES- THE
CONCERNS BEEN EXPRESSED I'M
GOING TO SUPPORT THE BILL BUT
THE CONCERNS BEEN EXPRESSED
WITH RESPECT TO. VIOLATIONS
THAT SEEM TO BE EITHER
TECHNICAL ADMINISTRATIVE SO FOR
EXAMPLE A GLITCH IN PAPERWORK
VERSUS SOMEONE WHO'S BEEN-
FLICKED WITH BED SORES OVER A
NUMBER OF DAYS. AND I KNOW
YOU'LL CONTINUE TO WORK TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT- THE MINISTRY TO
VIOLATIONS I REALIZE THAT THAT
THE DEVIL'S IN THE DETAILS BUT
THAT ADMINISTRATIVE VIOLATIONS.
AREN'T SUBJECT TO THE SAME
KINDS OF VIOLATIONS AS I
MENTIONED AS FOR EXAMPLE
BEDSORES WHICH HAVE PERSISTED
OVER A NUMBER OF DAYS. IS THAT
RIGHT. THAT IS CORRECT ALL
RIGHT OKAY. THANK YOU- BACK TO
THE FLOOR QUESTIONS COMMENTS
SENATOR STERN YOU HAVE A
QUESTION. YES SIR THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- JUST TO GET SOME
CLARIFICATION THOUGH. I GUESS
I'M- I'M PARTICULARLY SENSITIVE
TO. WHAT MAY BE SEEMINGLY
TECHNICAL OR ADMINISTRATIVE
VIOLATIONS THAT CUMULATIVELY
OVER TIME TO RESULT IN
SIGNIFICANT HARM TO THE PATIENT
SO SOME OF THE EXAMPLES BROUGHT
UP I THINK BY DR STEINBERG FOR
INSTANCE LIKE THE MEALS NOT
COMING ON TIME WE COULD. WE
COULD EASILY DISMISS THAT AND
SAY WELL THEY WERE JUST LATE
FIVE MINUTES FOR ONE MEAL OR
THEY DIDN'T BRING AT THAT TIME
BUT- THERE'S A CUMULATIVE
IMPACT TO THINGS LIKE. THE
SIMPLE AS YOU KNOW. GETTING
SOMEONE HYDRATED WHO DOESN'T
HAVE FULL FULL USE OF THEIR
FACULTIES- I HAVE A VERY
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE WITH THIS
WERE YOU KNOW IF YOU'RE NOT
GETTING YOUR SIPPY CUP. FIFTEEN
TIMES A DAY YOU'RE GOING TO GET
SO DEHYDRATED THAT YOU DO GET A
U. TI AND THEN YOU END UP IN
THE I SEE YOU AND THEN THAT
COULD BE THE END OF YOU. AND SO
THOSE. THE DEATH BY A THOUSAND
CUTS- IS SOMETHING I'M REALLY
WORRIED ABOUT AND I THINK THAT.
MAKES THIS BILL SO NECESSARY
MAKES THE SUPREME COURT
DECISION SO CONFOUNDING THAT
THE LEGISLATURE COULD HAVE
ASSUMED THAT. THAT WAS SORT OF
THE FULL EXTENT OF JUSTICE THAT
WE WERE ENVISIONING BACK AT
THAT TIME BUT I APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S WORK ON RECTIFYING
THIS AND I WOULD JUST SAY HE IS
A CAUTIONARY NOTE GOING FORWARD
I THINK. NOT TO BE DECEIVED BY
WHAT MAY SEEM LIKE A- AN
INFRACTION THAT DOESN'T HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT BUT WHEN
WE'RE NOT HITTING OUR NURSE TO
PATIENT STAFFING RATIOS FOR
INSTANCE PEOPLE ARE DYING AS A
RESULT I MEAN LET'S BE CLEAR I
DON'T MEAN OVER IT SAYS IT'S
NOT EVERY TIME NOT IF SOMEONE
DIDN'T SHOW UP FOR THE SHIFT
BUT- THAT BUT- OVER THE COURSE
OF THE WORK IN OUR NURSING HOME
SECTOR ESPECIALLY. IN THE FOR
PROFIT SPACE YOU KNOW WE ARE
ABANDONING OUR SENIORS IN THERE
AND- IT'S A GRIM REALITY THOSE
OF YOU WHO HAVE NOT SORT OF
GONE THROUGH THAT- BUT I
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S WORK
AND I'D BE HAPPY TO MOVE THE
BILL AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
THANK YOU SENATOR STERN OTHER
QUESTIONS I SEE CENTRE HURTS
FOR HIS HIS MICROPHONE UP
CENTERS FOR. THANK YOU- MISTER
TAKE A STAND UP IT'S OKAY I'M
JUST USED TO AT THIS DESK- YOU
KNOW I HAVE THE GREATEST REGARD
FOR MY COLLEAGUE THE- MAJORITY
LEADER. OF THE OTHER HOUSE AND
I PLAN ON. VOTING TO MOVE THIS
BILL TODAY HOWEVER. I WANT TO
RESERVE MY RIGHT NOT TO VOTE
FOR THIS ON THE FLOOR AS I
SHARE. WHEN YOU SHARE A COUPLE
OF. OBSERVATIONS THAT I HAVE
WITH RESPECT TO THIS MEASURE.
AND AS WE'VE BEEN EXPERIENCED
AS WAS MENTIONED OVER THE YEARS-
FOR ONE I DO BELIEVE THAT THERE
WILL INDEED BE A FLOOD OF
LITIGATION AGAINST THESE SNAPS
THESE SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES INORDINATELY HIGH
DAMAGE CLAIMS ATTACHED TO THAT
LITIGATIONSECOND THIS IS
ESPECIALLY TROUBLING IN MY VIEW
BECAUSE AS WE KNOW IN STUDYING
THE LOGS OVER TWELVE DIFFERENT
CAUSES OF ACTION. OR LEGAL
REMEDIES FOR AGGRIEVED PARTIES
ATTEMPTED TO SEEK REDRESS FROM
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES AND
THIS SELECTION ISSUE THE
SECTION EXCUSE ME AT ISSUE IN
THIS BILL WAS NEVER MEANT TO BE
THE PRIMARY AVENUE FOR LEGAL
DRESS REDRESS I DO APPRECIATE
THE CHAIR THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS WHICH IS A STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION BUT I
WANTED TO INCLUDE MY AMMUNITION
ON THIS WITH RESPECT TO THE
MEASURE STILL THINK IT NEEDS A
LITTLE BIT OF WORK BUT I THINK
THAT. ALWAYS TO AFFORD THE
LEVEL OF RESPECT A TO MY
COLLEAGUE IN THE MAJORITY
LEADER OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSEMBLY WILL BE SUPPORTING
THIS TODAY. THANK YOU SIR HERS
BERG OTHER COMMENTS QUESTIONS I
SEE NO OTHER MICROPHONES RAISE.
UP BRING IT BACK IS OUR MOTION
SENATOR WIENER YES MOST OF
BILL. ALL RIGHT SO A NUMBER
RAISED TO CARE CLOSE. YES THANK
YOU AND I APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS OF. MY SENATE
COLLEAGUES I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND THAT
WITH THE AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN OFFERED WHICH I HAVE
ACCEPTED IT DOES GIVE THE JUDGE
THE TRIAL JUDGE THE ABILITY TO
CONSIDER THE NATURE OF THE
SERIOUSNESS OF THE VIOLATIONS.
AND THE HARM THAT IS CAUSED TO
THE PATIENT. OR THE DECEDENT'S
BECAUSE WE ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT
SOME OF THEM DON'T MAKE IT TO
FILE THEIR CLAIM SO IT IS OUR
FAMILY WHO THEN JUST LIKE. LIKE
MRS JARMAN WHO HAD TO FILE THE
CLAIM ON BEHALF OF HER FATHER.
BUT I REMAIN COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING THE CONVERSATION
WITH THE STAKE HOLDERS OF THE
OPPOSITION TO RESOLVE. THEIR
CONCERNS TO THE EXTENT.
POSSIBLE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
MANAGE ACCOUNTS OF YOU CALL THE
ROLL THIS IS A V. EIGHT FOUR
NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER ANDREAS
WITH A MOTION BY SENATORWIENER
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED- BURKE. AND BURKE I
BORJAS WILL. FORGE A SNOW
PROBABLY AT ALL HI KELLY AT ALL
I DID ALSO. GONZALEZ HI WHEN
SELES I HURTS BURGLARY. HURTS.
BERG HI JONES. MARY BY LAYERED
ICE STERN HI- AND I WHITE HOUSE
SKI NINE. CASKEY I WINNER
WINNER I YOU HAVE EIGHT TO ONE
SO FAR. ALL RIGHT GOING BACK
NOW TO IT WILL PUT THAT ON CALL
TO PHYLUM NUMBER TWELVE EIGHTY
EIGHT TWENTY FIVE BY SEVEN
MEMBERS OF MAINE'S I SEE SEVEN
SEVEN MEMBER LIVING IS HERE
THANK YOU- A COUPLE. NOTES THAT
UP I MAY HAVE TO DEPART TO GO
TO ANOTHER COMMITTEE- AND I
KNOW THAT THERE ARE SOME THAT
HAVE ALREADY- INFORMED US THAT
THAT THEY ARE. ENGAGED ANOTHER
COMMITTEE IN THE ASSEMBLY SO
E'RE GOING TO ASK FOLKS TO
COME BUT WE'RE ALSO GOING TO
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN HERE FOR-
FOR A WHILE TO MAKE SURE
EVERYBODY WHO IS IN THE
BUILDING AS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
VOTE ALL RIGHT SO REMEMBER
LEVIN A. B. EIGHT TO FIVE
CLOSURES THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR. ABC TWENTY FIVE
OR CAR CALIFORNIANS BE NOTIFIED
IF THERE'S BEEN A BREACH OF
THEIR PERSONAL GENETIC DATA BY
INCLUDING GENETIC DATA IN THE
DEFINITION OF PERSONAL
INFORMATION IN CALIFORNIA'S
DATA BREACH NOTIFICATION LAW
FOR BOTH BUSINESSES AND PUBLIC
AGENCIES PHONETIC INFORMATION
IS OUR MOST PERSONAL
INFORMATION IS INFORMATION
ABOUT WHAT MAKES US WHO WE ARE.
THE SENSITIVE INFORMATION IN
THE WRONG HANDS WRISTS FAR MORE
THAN IMPACTING OUR CREDIT SCORE
IT COULD NEGATIVELY IMPACT OUR
HEALTH PRIVACY MAKE US
SUSCEPTIBLE TO GENETIC
DISCRIMINATION AND SUBJECT US
TO A NEW GENERATION OF IDENTITY
THEFT AT THE HANDS OF GENETIC
DATA FEEDS. AS THE LA TIMES
REPORTED IN TWENTY NINETEEN DNA
TESTING SERVICE PROVIDED GENE
INC LEFT THOUSANDS OF CLIENT
GENETIC RECORDS EXPOSED ONLINE
FOR YEARS AT THE TIME OF THE
ARTICLES RELEASED THE COMPANY
NOT NOTIFY CLIENTS ABOUT THEIR
EXPOSURE OF THEIR INFORMATION
ONE CUSTOMER SAID SHE HEARD
FIRST. ABOUT HER DNA BEING LEFT
UNSECURED WHEN BLOOMBERG NEWS
CONTACTED HER ABOUT THE STORY
SOME OF THE DOCUMENTS INCLUDED
CLIENTS. CONTACT INFORMATION
SUCH AS SOME WORK EMAIL
ADDRESSES MAKE IT EASIER TO
CONFIRM. PEOPLE'S IDENTITIES.
CALIFORNIAN SHOULD NOT FOR OUT
THERE TO DATA BREACHED. FROM A
REPORTER. UNDER THE LAW COMPANY
OR GOVERNMENT AGENCY MUST
DISCLOSE. TO AN INDIVIDUAL AT
THEIR PERSONAL INFORMATION OR
OTHER IDENTIFYING INFORMATION
ISN'T REACHED JUST LIKE YOUR
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER OR
MEDICAL INFORMATION. EIGHTY
EIGHT TWENTY FIVE ENSURES THAT
COMPANIES AND GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES NOTIFY CALIFORNIANS IF
THERE IS A BREACH AND USE
REASONABLE SECURITY MEASURES TO
PROTECT OUR MOST PERSONAL
INFORMATION. THEIR GENETIC DATA
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR- WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF MAUREEN MAHONEY AND
SABINA THE CAR. ARE THERE VIEW
AVAILABLE ON THE PHONE. YEAH
AND WHICH WHICH YES IS THAT
WITNESS. I'M MORE IN THE HONEY
FROM CONSUMER REPORTS ALL RIGHT
JUST WANT TO GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TODAY MY NAME IS
MAUREEN MAHONEY OMITTING YOUR
POLICY ANALYST AT CONSUMER
REPORTS AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE B. EIGHTY FIVE. WHICH WOULD
ENSURE THAT CONSUMERS SENSITIVE
THAT A DATA IS COVERED BY THE
STATE DATA BREACH NOTIFICATION
AND DATA SECURITY STATUTES AND
WOULD PROVIDE APPROPRIATE
INCENTIVES FOR COMPANIES TO
COMPLY. AND OF GENETIC DATA IS
WIDESPREAD ABOUT ONE IN FIVE U.
S. CONSUMERS HAS TAKEN A DIRECT
TO CONSUMER GENETIC TESTS. MANY
OF THEM LIKELY ASSUME THEIR
DATA IS COVERED BY A STRONG
LEGAL SECURITY PROTECTION. NOT
A DATA CLEARLY WARRANT SUCH
PROTECTION PARTICULARLY IN
LIGHT OF THE PLETHORA OF DATA
BREACHES IN RECENT YEARS GOING
INTO THE MATCH IN JULY OF LAST
YEAR. IT ALSO REVEALED
INFORMATION ABOUT BLOOD
RELATIVES WHO MAY NOT EVEN BE
AWARE THAT THE CONSUMERS SHARE
THEIR GENOME WITH A DIRECT TO
CONSUMER GENETIC TESTING
COMPANY WHICH MAKES A
PARTICULARLY DESERVING OF
PROTECTION. FROM HACKERS ASIDE
FROM THE INHERENT PRIVACY
INTEREST IN KEEPING THAT
INFORMATION SECURE AT THE STATE
BECOMES PUBLICLY AVAILABLE DUE
TO A BREACH. INFORMATION ABOUT
POTENTIAL HEALTH ISSUES SUCH AS
AFFORDABILITY DEPRESSED CANCER
COULD POTENTIALLY BE ACCESSED
BY OTHER THAN USED TO
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST CONSUMERS.
NO ONE SHOULD HAVE TO WORRY
THAT THEIR MOST PERSONAL
INFORMATION WILL BE STOLEN MADE
AVAILABLE WITHOUT THEIR
KNOWLEDGE OR CONSENT THESE
REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. PHONE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. MISS HOLLY BEST CAR YOU
VALUABLE. YES HER NUMBER IT BE
A COP COULD BE MURDERING THE
CALIFORNIA HERE TODAY AND JOHN.
EIGHT TO FIVE. NO NEED COULD
YOU KNEW WHEN IT. MARCH OF THE
PROVIDED NEW FOR ONLINE P.
CONSUMER REALLY CARE ABOUT THE
HARM THAT OCCURRED. IT EACH
CRYSTAL AND I CAN MEET.
PRESIDENT EITHER FEAR FOR THEIR
OWN VEHICLES THE EIGHT. READ BY
PERSONAL DATA IS NO LONGER A
DAY. IT CANNOT BE ALTERED OR
CHANGED BECAUSE THE ONE CREDIT
CARD OR ACCOUNT NUMBER. EIGHTY
FIVE A PEG COMMENTED. RICHARD
HI THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT OF SAYING NO ONE IN THE
GALLERY- IN SUPPORT NO ONE IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE- WHICH YOU
TESTIFIED SUPPORT THE SCHOOL
THE PHONE LINE. MODERATE IF YOU
QUEUE UP THOSE IN SUPPORT OF A.
B. TWO FIVE. THANK YOU MR CHAIR
FOR COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF THE
V. EIGHT TO FIVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. THAT COMMAND
AGAIN. ONE ZERO. AND MISTER
CHAIR I SHOW NO COMMENTS COMING
THROUGH AT THE TIME ALL RIGHT
LET'S TURN THE OPPOSITION- I
BELIEVE THERE ARE TWO PRINCIPAL
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION MR SHOW
VOMIT- ARE YOU- ARE YOU ON THE
PHONE LINE OR MR. CAMERON
DIMITRI. MR MAHABIR CAME INTO
THE TREES ON THE WELL I WOULD
YOU LIKE ME TO START RIGHT MR
DIMITRI GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON SURE MEMBERS MANY
CAME TO ME TREE AND THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
TECHNOLOGY. THE TECHNICIAN THE
NATIONAL BIPARTISAN NETWORK OF
TECHNOLOGY CEOS AND SENIOR-EXECUTIVES THAT PROMOTES THE
GROWTH INNOVATION ECONOMY AND
REPRESENTS OVER EIGHTY
COMPANIES AND FOUR MILLION
EMPLOYEES. WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE AB EIGHT TO FIVE AND
HAVE APPRECIATED THE DIALOGUE
WITH DOCTOR'S OFFICE. ABOUT AN
IMMINENT THREAT OPEN EIGHTEEN
CONTACT TRACING EXCEPTION BUT
THIS WAS REJECTED BY THE
DOCTOR'S OFFICE. WE REMAIN
CONCERNED ABOUT THE POTENTIAL
SCOPING INTO COVERAGE CONTACT
CREATING TASKING THERE ARE SOME
COKE ATTACHED THE ANALYZED RNA.
FOR SIGNS OF THE VIRUS AND
VIRUS COMMUNITY. MAYBE EIGHTY
FIVE DEFINITION OF GENETIC DATA
COULD RESULT IN A TEST DRIVE
FROM GENETIC MATERIAL I. E.
ECHO THE NINETEEN ANTIBODY TEST.
THE CRITICAL LIABILITY FOR
BUSINESSES TO CONDUCT CONTACT
TRACING LAST YEAR THE GOVERNOR
VETOED SB NINE EIGHTY THE
CONCERNED OVERLY BROAD
DEFINITIONS THAT CAN MOVE AND
COVER TESTING. CONDITIONALLY
THE REASON CAL OSHA EMERGENCY
REGULATIONS REQUIRE MOST
CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES TO
PROVIDE COVER TENSION ENGINE
FOR YOU. CONSEQUENTLY AB EIGHTY
FIVE CAN CREATE SIGNIFICANT
GESTURE DAMAGES. WITH NO PROOF
OF ENTRY FOR DISCLOSURE
ATTACHED RESULTS DERIVED
GENETIC INFORMATION. AND WAYS
TO HELP PEOPLE WITHOUT THEIR
COVER TASKS WHICH THEY DO AT
TIMES COMPANIES CAN BE SUED FOR
EACH OF THESE DISCLOSURES WITH
IMPROVEMENT ENTRY WITH
SIGNIFICANT STATUTORY DAMAGES.
CALIFORNIA SHOULD NOT BE
CREATING A SCENARIO INCREASE IN
RATES FOR THOSE HOLDING DATA
PLAN TO KEEP THE PUBLIC SAFE.
FROM SPREADING A DEADLY VIRUS.
HARMFUL WHAT HELP AND SUPPORT
OUR PUBLIC HEALTH OBJECTIVES.
THIRTY REASONS GIVEN THE ON
THIS THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU MR
MITRI MISTER MUHAMMAD ARE YOU
AVAILABLE. GOING ONCE GOING
TWICE GLITTERED RETURNS MISTER
CHAIR WE DO NOT SHOW THAT
MISTER MUHAMMAD HAD CONNECTED
ALL RIGHT- LET'S THEN MOVE TO
THE GALLERY NO ONE IN THE
GALLERY WHICH DESPITE
OPPOSITION. NO ONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION LET'S GO TO THE
PHONE LINE AND QUEUE UP. THOSE
IN OPPOSITION. FOUR COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY EIGHT TO
FIVE. PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO THE COMMAND AGAIN. ONE
SEVEN ZERO. AND MISTER CHAIR
THERE ARE NO COMMENTS COMING
THROUGH AT THE TIME OKAY LET'S
BRING IT BACK TO THE CHAMBER
CENTER WINNER OF THE BILL SO WE
ARE MOSTABILITY CENTER BOARD
JUST HAS A MICROPHONE UP DID
YOU WANNA SPEAK CENTER MORICHES
YOU DO OKAY GO AHEAD. MR JUST A
QUICK POINT ON THE STRETCHER- I
WILL CERTAINLY BE SUPPORTING
THIS BILL TODAY AND I THINK-
GENETIC MATERIAL IS OF SUCH A
CHARACTER THAT SHOULD BE
CONSIDERED CONSIDERED PERSONAL
INFORMATION AND OFFER THE
PROTECTIONS- BUT I THINK
PREMISEDWITH PERSONAL
INFORMATION. IS THAT DOES THIS
BILL IN ANY WAY. CREATE
CHALLENGES. BETTER SIMILAR TO
DISAGGREGATED INFORMATION THAT
ARE USED IN OTHER CONTEXTS
MEETING THAT IDENTIFYING
INFORMATION BE TAKEN OUT FOR
RESEARCH OR OTHER USEFUL
PURPOSES SO THAT IT'S NOT-
ACCESSIBLE YOU KNOW WHETHER IT
BE FOR SCHOLASTIC OR ACADEMIC
OR MEDICAL RESEARCH. SEVEN
NUMBER YOU CAN RESPOND. YEAH
IT'S A IT'S A IT'S A GOOD
QUESTION CENTER BORDERS AND I
WOULD YOU KNOW IT I HEAR THAT
YOU'RE INTERESTED IN SUPPORTING
THE BILL- BUT I'M ALSO
INTERESTED IN MAKING SURE THAT
I GIVE YOU A DETAILED QUESTION
TO RESPOND TO THAT
APPROPRIATELY AND I WANT TO
MAKE SURE I DO THAT- WHICH I'M
NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO DO RIGHT
NOW. I UNDERSTAND I UNDERSTAND.
LET'S I THINK THIS ISN'T THE
RIGHT- IT'S IN THE RIGHT VEIN
OF LOOKING AFTER- PERSONAL
INFORMATION IN TREATING IT
CORRESPONDINGLY- SO I'LL BE
SUPPORTIVE BUT IF YOU CAN GET
THAT ANSWER BEFORE THIS ENDS UP
GOING TO THE NEXT ROUND. OF
FLOOR BUILDING THAT THAT WOULD
BE HELPFUL I THINK OTHER FOLKS
MIGHT FIND THIS INFORMATION
USEFUL AS WELL. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. OF OTHER
QUESTIONS COULD NO OTHER
QUESTIONS IT'S BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR WIENER- THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVIN AS YOU
KNOW- WE ARE ALSO INTERESTED IN
THIS VERY SAME SPACE. SO ALL
RIGHT- KERR CLOSE YEAH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU ALSO MEMBERS I ALSO
WANT TO EXPRESS MY GRATITUDE TO
STAFF COUNSEL WHO NOT ONLY ON
THIS BILL BUT ON SO MANY BILLS.
AT PRIOR TO THIS INCLUDING. MY
ELEVEN THIRTY A COUPLE OF YEARS
AGO ON BIOMETRIC DATA HAVE BEEN
SO EXTRAORDINARILY HELPFUL IN
CRAFTING. LEGISLATION AND NOW
LAW- SO THANK YOU FOR THAT AND
I APPRECIATE AND RESPECT THE
HOUSE FOR A VOTE. ALREADY MAN
CHIEF COUNSEL IF YOU WOULD CALL
THE ROLL THIS IS EIGHTY EIGHT
TO FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LEVINE- WITH A MOTION BY
SENATOR WIENER THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS- BURKE. HI AMBER
I MORTGAGES. FOR JUST I'D CARRY
IT ALL I. HAVE YOU KNOW I DID I
SO. ONCE ALL THIS. HERTZBERG
CONNIE HERZBERG I JONES NO.
JONES KNOWS LAYERED ON A
LAYERED ICE STERN. WHAT CASKEY
HI GREG CASKEY I WINNER WINNER
I. YOU HAVE SEVEN TO ONE SO FAR
WE'LL PUT THE BILL ON CALL I'M
GONNA DO IS WE'RE GONNA LIVE
CALLS HERE MOMENTARILY AND THEN
I BELIEVE I'M GOING TO RECESS
THE COMMITTEE I'VE GOT TO
ABSENT MYSELF FOR A FEW MOMENTS
TO- GO TO AN ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE- ALL RIGHT SO LET'S
LIST THE CALL THEM WILL
DETERMINE WHEN WE'RE GOING TO-
WRITTEN OF TO- RECONVENE ALL
RIGHT LET'S BEGIN. OKAY ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR WITH THAT
YOU'RE VOTING I DID ALSO
HERTZBERG HERZBERG HI JONES
JONES HI STERN. WINNER HI
WINNER HI- YOU HAVE TO TWO
MEMBERS WHO DID NOT VOTE ALL
RIGHT SO IT IS NINE O'CLOCK
HERE RIGHT NOW. THE BACK ON
CALL PERHAPS THE NEXT ITEM IS
OUR FINAL ITEM ONE A. B.
THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT WITH THE
CHAIR OF VOTING I DID ALSO.
HERTZBERG I HEARD SPRIG ICE
STERN. WINNER WINNER HI. YEP
NINETY ZERO SO FAR BILLS BACK
ON CALL THE NEXT ITEM IS FILE
ITEM TO AB THREE NINETY FIVE
WITH THE CHAIR READING I DID
ALSO HURTS BERG. PRESSBURG HIGH
STERN- YOU HAVE NINE TWO ZERO
SO FAR ON THAT ONE ALL RIGHT
BILL BACK ON CALL AT THE NEXT
ITEM IS FILE ITEM NINE A. B.
TWO EIGHTY SIX. WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I. DID I SELL GONZALEZ.
HERTZBERG HIGH RATES BERG HI-
SO FAR YOU HAVE SEVENTY TWO ON
THAT ONE WITH THE MEMBER'S
MISSING ALL RIGHT PUT IT BACK
ON CALL OKAY THE NEXT ITEM IS
FIVE ITEM ELEVEN AB TEN SIXTY
ONE BY FAMILY MEMBER WILL BE
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I. THAT
WAY AT ALL DID I SELL. GUNS
ALICE HERZ BERG. BY IT'S BERG
HI YOU HAVE SEVENTY ONE ON THAT
ONE WITH SOME SENATORS MISSING.
CALL THE NEXT ITEM IS FILE ITEM
FOURTEEN BY A FAMILY MEMBER
HELLO AB ELEVEN NINETY FOUR
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I DID
ALSO GONZALEZ HERTZBERG. IT
HURTS BERG YEAH HI HI. HI
THAT'S NINE TWO ZERO WITH SOME
SENATORS MISSING. THE NEXT BACK
ON CALL THE NEXT ITEM IS ITEM
FIFTEEN AB NINE SEVENTY EIGHT
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK SILVA
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I BURGESS.
NO GORGEOUS NOW ONCE THAT ONCE
ALL THIS HURTS BERG. HERTZBERG
NOT VOTING. JONES NUMBERING
JOHN'S NOT VOTING YOU HAVE-
MEMBERS ARE MISSING AND YOUR
VOTE SO FAR AS FOR I'M SORRY
SEVEN TWO ZERO ALL RIGHT BACK
ON CALL THE NEXT ITEM IS FIVE
ITEMS SIXTEEN BY S. AND THE
NUMBER IS EIGHT B. EIGHT TO
FOUR NINE WITH THAT YOU'RE
VOTING I DID ALSO. JONES I'M
SORRY WHICH ONE OKAY IT'S FILE
ITEM SIXTEEN. BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
ADDRESS IT'S AB EIGHT FOUR NINE
NO SHARE VOTING HI. ADDRESS SO
JONES NO JONES NO SO YOU HAVE
EIGHTY TWO SO FAR ON THAT ONE
ALL RIGHT THOSE BACK ON CALL
AND ONE MORE REALLY QUICK WE'LL
DO EIGHT TO FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT
TWO FIVE FIVE EIGHT AM TWELVE
SHARE VOTING I DID ALSO
CONSOLIDATES STERN. STILL
SEVENTY ONE. ALL RIGHT BILL
REMAINS ON CALL- ALL RIGHT WE
THE TIME IS NOW- FOR EIGHTEEN
WE WILL RECESS UNTIL. FOUR
THIRTY- TO ALLOW MEMBERS TO
COME AT THAT POINT WE WILL- WE
WILL. WE WILL OPEN THE ROLE ALL
RIGHT.
AND WE'RE GOING TO OPEN
UP THE BILLS THAT ARE ON CALL
CURRENTLY MADAM CONSULTANT CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE CURRENT
BILLS. THE CHAIR IS CURRENTLY
IN A DIFFERENT COMMITTEE SO
THEREFORE I AM HERE IN THIS
COMMITTEE. IN HIS PLACE SO
WE'LL START FROM THE TOP MADAM
CHIEF CONSULTANT SURE- THIS IS
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR DID
ASAL HI DID I SO HI. AND STERN.
WE STILL HAVE ONE MISSING
MEMBER BUT SO FAR WE HAVE TEN
TO ZERO RATE WILL PUT THE
CONSENT ON CALL. THE NEXT ITEM
IS FIVE ITEM NUMBER ONE A. B.
THIRTEEN TWENTY WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I. DID I SO I DID I SELL
BY STERN. WE AVE TEN TO ZERO
SO FAR WITH ONE MEMBER MISSING
THANK YOU NEXT BILL- THE NEXT
BILL IS AB THREE NINETY. FIVE
ITEM TO BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I
DID I SO I DID- SO I STERN. WE
HAVE TEN TO ZERO SO FAR SO
HOLDING IT OPEN. WELL HOLD THAT
BILL OPEN. A CALL THE NEXT BILL
IS EIGHTY TWO EIGHTY SIX FILE
ITEM NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GONZALEZ WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
I DID I THOUGHT I DRESS UP HI
GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ HI AND
THAT'S- FIVE SIX SEVENTY THAT'S
NINE TWO TWO AND THAT EVERYONE
ON THE COMMITTEE VOTING OKAY
THE BILL GETS OUT GREAT. THE
NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN
AB TEN SIXTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEAD WITH THE
CHAIR OF VOTING I CAN BE AT ALL.
THE RUSSELL I. DID I SO I WENT
SILENT HI WHEN SILAS I. THAT
BILL IS. HE NINE THAT'S NINETY
ONE AND THE MEMBER WHO'S
MISSING DECIDED TO NOT VOTE FOR
IT THE BILL GETS OUT WELL. THE
NEXT ITEM IS FILE ITEM FOURTEEN
AB ELEVEN NINETY FOUR BY FAMILY
MEMBERS HELLO WITH THE CHAIR
READING I DID ALSO I DID SO I
CAN SATISFY WHEN SELES HI. THAT
BILL IS ELEVEN TWO ZERO ALL
MEMBERS HAVE VOTED GREAT THAT
BILL GETS OUT AS WELL. THE NEXT
ITEM IS ITEM FIFTEEN AB EIGHT
NINE SEVENTY EIGHT BY QUIRK
SILVA WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I.
CONSOLIDATES HI WHEN SELES I-
SEVENTY YOU HAVE EIGHTY ONE AND
THE OTHER MEMBERS DECIDED NOT
TO VOTE OKAY THAT BILL IS OUT.
THE NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER
SIX AND SAFE ITEM NUMBER
SIXTEEN A. B. EIGHT FOUR NINE
BY RAY AS- BUT THE CHAIR OF
VOTING I. DID I SO I DID A SO I
SAID THAT IS. THAT'S NINE TWO
TWO EVERYONE HAS VOTED THAT
BILL IS OUT. THE NEXT ITEM IS
FILE ITEM TWELVE EIGHTY EIGHT
TO FIVE BY LEVINE WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING I DID I SELL ON
THE REST SO I GONZALEZ HI WHEN
SELES HI STERN. THERE'S ONE MAN
MISSY ON THAT BILL AND THE VOTE
COUNT IS. NINE TWO ONE SO FAR
RIGHT THAT BILL IS OUT AS WELL
IT'S DID YOU WANT TO PUT IT ON
CALL WELL I'M SORRY THAT ONE IS
ON CALL WITH US AS A SENATOR
STERN OUT OKAY THANK YOU AND
THAT. ALL THE WAY THROUGH THE
ROLE OKAY WILL LEAVE THE BILLS
CURRENTLY ON A CALL AGAIN AS
THE JUDICIARY CHAIR IS STILL
OUT AND HE'LL RETURN SHORTLY
AND WILL RECONVENE AND WE'LL
TAKE A SHORT RECESS.
YEAH
JUDICIARY- MADAM CHIEF
CONSULTANT CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE BILLS ON CALL PLEASE PRESS-
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR. STERN
HI STERN I THAT'S ELEVEN TWO
ZERO THE BILL IS OUT THANK YOU.
THIS NEXT ITEM IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE ABC. THIRTEEN
TWENTY. BUT THE CHAIR VOTING
ICE STERN HI STERN I THAT'S.
ELEVEN ZERO. EVERYONE VOTED
THAT'S ABOUT A ZERO THAT BILL
GETS OUT THANK YOU THANK YOU
THE NEXT ITEM IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER. TWO EIGHTY THREE NINETY
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BERMAN WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING I. STERN I
STERN HI THAT HAS ELEVEN TWO
ZERO EVERYONE HAS VOTED FOR THE
BILL ITSELF THANK YOU. THE LAST
ITEM IS FILE ITEM TWELVE AB
EIGHTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LEVIN WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I.
STERN HI STERN I THAT'S. THAT'S
TEN TO ONE THE BILL IS OUT. I
THINK IT'S. OKAY HAT CONCLUDES
OUR BILLS THANK YOU MADAM CHIEF
CONSULTANT THANK YOU SENATOR
STERN- AND THAT CONCLUDES OUR-
MEETING ALL IN HEARING ON THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE THANK YOU
TO ALL INDIVIDUAL INDIVIDUALS
WHO PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU ARE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE OR VISIT
OUR WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US
AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS. THANK YOU AND
WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION THANK YOU
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION WE HAVE CONCLUDED
THE AGENDA THE SENATE GOP
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY IS
ADJOURNED THANK YOU.